HEARING A JOINT HEARING OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEES TO
ORDER THE SENATE IS STILL IN
SESSION BUT OUT OF RESPECT FOR
THE PARTICIPANTS AT THE-
PANELISTS AND FOR ALL OF YOU
WHO ARE HERE TO WATCH THE
PRECEDING THEY'VE ASKED US TO
GO AHEAD AND START WITHOUT
THEM. THEY WILL JOIN US AS SOON
AS THEY ARE I'M ALLOWED TO
LEAVE THE FLOOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY JUST ARE GOBBLED DOWN
A FEW MINUTES AGO SO WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE ON THEIR WAY UP HERE AS
WELL BUT OUT OF RESPECT TO ALL
OF YOU WERE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN- THE SO I DO WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY WHO'S PATRICIA
PARTICIPATING TODAY I'D LIKE TO
ALSO THANK. THE SENATE AND
SENATOR STERN- JOINED TO A- OF.
A PRESIDING- OVER THIS HEARING-
LAST YEAR AT THE SUMMER OIL
FIELD THE FOURTH. HIGHEST
PRODUCING OIL FIELD IN
CALIFORNIA. LOCATED WEST OF
BAKERSFIELD IN KERN COUNTY HAD
ONE OF THE LARGEST OIL SPILLS
IN THE STATE'S HISTORY. THERE
ARE OVER TWO THOUSAND ACTIVE
WELLS AT THE SOME RECOIL FIELD
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED CYCLIC
STEAMING WELLS. THERE BEEN
NUMEROUS OIL SPILLS OR SERVICE
EXPRESSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND GROWING CONCERN THAT
CURRENT CYCLIC SEEM PRACTICES
MIGHT LEAD TO MORE. OF THE
SERVICE EXPRESSIONS OR SPILLS.
THIS HEARING WILL LOOK AT THE
SUMMER OIL SPILL IN THE SERVICE
EXPRESSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THE HEARING WILL
ALSO TAKE A BROADER LOOK AT OIL
AND GAS REGULATION IN THE
STATE. OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
JOGGER HAS FREQUENTLY BEEN. YES
WE'LL SAY IN THE DOG HOUSE FOR
LAX OVERSIGHT. OF THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY AND FAILURE TO
ADHERE TO STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW. A. B. TEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
LAMAR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND.
RENAMED DARKER TO CAL JAM AND
WE HOPE TO HEAR FROM THE NEW
SOME ADMINISTRATION TODAY ABOUT
HOW. CAL JOHN WILL BE POLISHED
UP TO MAKE IT A SHINING
EXAMPLE. OF THE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION OF
HOW WE CAN. HOPEFULLY SET THE
STANDARD FOR OIL AND GAS
EXPLORATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER WE DO IN THE STATE IS.
AS SAFE AS IT CAN POSSIBLY BE.
SO I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
FIRST PANEL I WOULD HAVE ASKED
FOR COMMENTS FROM THE PANELISTS
BUT THEY'RE NOT HERE YET SO I
MAY VERY WELL ALLOW PEOPLE TO
COMMENT- AT THE END OF THE
PANEL TO GET SORT OF OPENING
COMMENTS AS THEY ARRIVE. BUT
FOR. THANKS MISTER FLORA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU. VICE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HE FOR SO FOR OUR FOR
OUR FIRST PANEL WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE WE'D CROWFOOT FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. THE
BILL FOR. AND YOU ARE THE ONLY
PANELIST THIS PANEL. WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
FRIEDMAN- VICE CHAIR FLORA
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE- I AM GLAD TO BE
HERE TODAY TO SHARE I HAD A HAD
A BROAD LEVEL ON THE NEWS
MINISTRATIONS APPROACH TO
BOILING GAPS OVERSIGHT. AND
THEN ALSO DETAIL SEVERAL
INITIATIVES- THAT WE FIVE WE
HAVE UNDER WAY.
I INCREASING.
THE REGULARITY OF FIELD
INSPECTIONS IMPROVING OUR
ENFORCEMENT AND OF COURSE
ENSURING THAT OUR OPERATORS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SAFELY DE
COMMISSIONING THE WELLS SO
FIRST PRINCIPLE CONTINUE TO
PROFESSIONAL EYES AND STRENGTH
AND REGULATORY OVERSIGHT I'LL
SAY THAT WE'RE BUILDING UPON A
STRONG FOUNDATION OF
IMPROVEMENTS IN RECENT YEARS-
THAN DOG- I INITIATED A RENEW
ALL PLAN IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT
BEGAN TO IDENTIFY WHERE IT'S
RULE MAKINGS ITS REGULATIONS
NEEDED TO BE STRENGTHENED AND
HOW IT COULD PROFESSIONAL EYES-
AN IMPROVED IT'S OVERSIGHT. AND
MANY IMPROVEMENTS FOR WENT
MERMAID THAT WERE WERE REALLY
BUILDING UPON- SO FIRST FROM
CORPORATE DOUBLE STRENGTH AND
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT SECOND
PRINCIPLE IS TO ALIGN THE
DIVISION- WITH THE STATE'S A
LEGAL REQUIREMENT TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND-
IN THE VISION TO ACHIEVE
CLIMATE NEUTRALITY BY THE
MIDDLE PART OF THE CENTURY I AM
REALLY UPDATING THE OF THE
VISION TAKES TO FOR EXAMPLE
REDUCE THE ENERGY FOOT PRINT OF
EXTRACTION REDUCE FUGITIVE
EMISSIONS COMING FROM
EXTRACTION ETCETERA. TO
IMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
VISION- FOR OIL AND GAS
OVERSIGHT WE HAVE TWO NEW
LEADERS AND I'M PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU HERE TODAY
THIS IS I THINK THE FIRST TIME
THEY'LL BE TESTIFYING IN FOR
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE FIRST
BEHIND ME IS DAVID CHIU
BAYESIAN GIVEAWAY DAVID SO YOU
SEE WHO HE IS WE TESTIFYING IN
A MOMENT DAVID COME TO US FROM
THE SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS. A COP OUT WHERE HE
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS FOCUSED AT
THE INTERSECTION OF LAND
CONSERVE ARE FOR YOU BY FOR
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY WELL IT WILL
TALK TODAY ABOUT OBVIOUSLY OIL
AND GAS OVERSIGHT BUT ANOTHER
CORE MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION IS JUST THAT
LAND CONSERVATION AND HOW DO
WE- PLAN AND SUPPORT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES GROWING IN WAYS
THAT SUSTAIN THEIR ECONOMIC
VITALITY AND ADVANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY.
SO DAVID BRINGS EXPERTISE
ENVISIONED IN THAT AREA AND IS
GETTING UP TO SPEED UP CORD ON
ON OIL AND GAS. AS WELL. AND
THAT LEAD. THE DIRECTLY
OVERSEEING OIL AND GAS ODOR
OVERSIGHT IS WHO DO ACTON TALK.
ARE WHO GET COMES TO US FROM
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WHERE
HE SERVED AS OIL AND GAS US
ADMINISTRATOR. WHO TO WALK IS-
HAS THAT BACK EDUCATION AND
CAREER AS A PETROLEUM ENGINEER
SO BRINGS A HIGH LEVEL OF
TECHNICAL SOPHISTICATION- AND
ALSO. A LEGACY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGAGEMENT OUR HE WAS ONE OF ON
GREEN FOR ALL ITS FELLOWS ON
FOR EXAMPLE. HE'S BEEN A
REGULATOR IN LONG BEACH AND- IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
OVER A DECADE SO WE'RE REALLY
QUITE FORTUNATE TO HAVE BOTH. I
DAVID IN WHO TO WALK IN ANY
WILL BE TESTIFYING HERE TODAY.
I CHAIR FRIEDMAN YOU MENTIONED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE MOANS BILL
TEN FIFTY SEVEN THAT UPDATED
THE MISSION OF THE DIVISION
OVERSEEING OIL AND GAS- WE KNOW
THAT DIVISION HISTORICALLY AS
DAGR OR THE DIVISION OF OIL GAS
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES AND IT HAS
BEEN RENAMED THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
DIVISION BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THAN THE NAME CHANGE ITS ITS
MISSION HAS BEEN UPDATED ARE
BOTH TO ELEVATE- THE FOCUS OF
THE DIVISION ON PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. AS
WELL AS- THE NEED TO ALIGN THE
DIVISION WITH THE STATE'S
BROADER CLIMATE AND ENERGY
GOALS- SO THE INITIATIVE THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT- NOW INTO
ACTION JUST A MOMENT ARE REALLY
BEING IMPLEMENTED THROUGH- THIS
THIS DIVISION WITH ITS NEW AN
UPDATED OUR MISSION I'LL
MENTION THAT WE CONTINUE TO
BUILD CAPACITY OF THE DIVISION-
TO- SAFELY REGULATE- THIS
ACTIVITY. I THINK YOUR STAFF
REPORT NOTED THAT THIS
DIVISIONS THE STAFF HAS HAS
TRIPLED IN THE LAST DECADE
WHICH REALLY REFLECTS THE NEED
AND THE RECOGNITION THAT MORE
STAFF IS NEEDED TO ENSURE FULL
AND FAIR MEDITATION UP THE
STATE'S LAWS AND REGULATIONS ON
OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION. SO LET
ME TURN TO. A SET UP OF
INITIATIVES THAT WERE ANNOUNCED
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR THAT
REALLY SPEAK TO THAT FIRST
PRINCIPLE OF STRENGTHENING
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AND- I'LL
FOCUS ON THREE. AND EACH OF
THEM REALLY IS- IT IS
PRIORITIZING ADVANCING
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT THAT IS
SCIENCE DRIVEN. SPECIFICALLY
PROTECTIVE OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND OF COURSE ECONOMICALLY
RESPONSIBLE. AB THE FIRST
REGULATORY ACTION IS A
MORATORIUM THAT IS PLACED ON A
CERTAIN PRACTICE OF INJECTING
HIGH PRESSURE STEAM I INTO THE
GROUND I HAD A PRESSURE WHAT'S
CALLED ABOVE THE FRACTURE
GRADIENT- THIS IS A PRACTICE
WHICH WE KNOW AS A CYCLIC
STEAMING ABOUT THE FRACTURE
PRESSURE. THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SURFACE EXPRESSIONS
THAT YOU ARE OVER VIEWED IN
YOUR INTRODUCTION- A MORATORIUM
WAS PLACED ON NEW WELLS- THAT
WOULD INJECT USING THIS
PRACTICE ON WHILE A REVIEW IS
CONDUCTED BY CAL JAM AND THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL
LABORATORY. ON THIS PRACTICE TO
DETERMINE IF IT IS SAFE TO
CONDUCT IN CALIFORNIA AND IF IT
IS SAFE TO CONDUCT UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS IS IT SAFE TO
CONDUCT- THIS HI PRESSURES
SIXTEEN AND ABOVE THE FRACTURE
GRADIENT. THAT REVIEW AS I SAID
WHAT IT WILL BE AT A TANDEM
EFFORT OF CAL JAM AND LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABORATORY
AND IT IS ANTICIPATED TO TAKE
UPWARDS OF SIX MONTHS ARE FOR
THAT REVIEW TO TAKE PLACE. THE
SECOND REGULATORY ACTION THAT
WAS ANNOUNCED IN LATE NOVEMBER
IT WAS AYE INITIATING A RULE
MAKING ART TO IMPROVE OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS. ARE OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS COMMUNITIES AND- FOLKS
LIVING ADJACENT TO OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION- OUR ANNOUNCEMENT
MADE CLEAR THAT WE ARE STARTING
A RULE MAKING WHICH IS THE WAY
THAT WE UPDATE TE STATE'S
REGULATIONS- FOCUSED ON.
IMPLEMENTING NEW HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS- DESIGNED TO
INCREASE AND EXPAND
PROTECTIONS. ARE GOALS WITH
THIS RULE MAKING ARE A TRUE OUR
DEBT TO ESTABLISH A TRANSPARENT
SET OF RULES. NOT TO UTILIZE
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
DATA. TO ENGAGE I PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES AN ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AUTHORITIES INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY. THAT WE HAVE
A PROCESS THAT'S INCLUSIVE ARE
BOTH FOR OUR COMPANIES IN OUR
INDUSTRY AND COMMUNITIES
ADJACENT TO THESE FACILITIES SO
WE ARE PLANNING A VIGOROUS PRE
RULE MAKING PROCESS WERE
ACTUALLY GOING OUT ACROSS THE
STATE TO SEEK OUR SOLICIT.
INPUT THAT WILL GUIDE THIS RULE
MAKING AND SUPERVISOR AND TALK
AND EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT- PUBLIC
MEETINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. OUR
ANNOUNCEMENT WITH CLEAR THAT WE
WILL CONSIDER A FULL RANGE OF
PROTECTIVE MEASURES- AND REALLY
ALL IDEAS ARE ALL POTENTIAL
MEASURES THAT COULD BE PUT IN
PLACE- TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY- INCLUDING- THE
POSSIBILITY OF- RESTRICTING OUR
OIL AND GAS ACTIVITIES WITHIN
CLOSE PROXIMITY IS OF HOMES AND
SCHOOLS INSENSITIVE RECEPTORS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT-
THAT. THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT COME THROUGH THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS WILL BE GUIDED
BY AGAIN THAT BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES SO I KNOW
CONCLUSIONS HAVE BEEN DRAWN
ABOUT WHAT MEASURES WHAT SAFETY
MEASURES BOB MAKES SENSE TO
INTEGRATE BUT- THAT WILL OF
COURSE BE PART OF WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN THE PRE RULE
MAKING AND THEN. SUBJECT TO THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS. AND I'LL
MENTION THAT- THIS RULE MAKING
WILL COMPLEMENT- THE
COMPREHENSIVE AIR MONITORING
THAT TAKES PLACE IN COMMUNITIES
ARE LOCATED AT NEW OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS UNDER EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN. THE THIRD-
INITIATIVE AGAIN FOCUSED ON
STRENGTHENING OUR REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT- HAS TO DO WITH
PERMITTING ON SPECIFICALLY
PERMITTING OF WELL STIMULATION
ARE WHICH IS THE TECHNICAL NAME
OF HYDRAULIC FRACTURING OR
FRACKING AS WELL AS UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROLS OR CYCLIC
STEAMING- EARLIER IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. OUR CONCERNS WERE
RAISED ABOUT THE PERMITTING
PROCESS OF THOSE PRACTICES- AND
SPECIFICALLY WHETHER- THE
PERMIT PROCESS WAS BEING
CONDUCTED APPROPRIATELY- BY
THEN DOCTOR STAFF- THE GOVERNOR
TOOK THIS QUITE SERIOUSLY. AND
TOOK A SERIES OF ACTIONS- TO
ENSURE THAT OUR PERMITTING
PROCESS IS INDEED LEGALLY
APPROPRIATE AND ABOVE REPROACH-
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A- A
HYDRAULIC FRACTURING PERMIT OR
WELL STIMULATION PERMIT ISSUED-
SINCE THOSE CONCERNS WERE
RAISED. AND MOVING FORWARD WE
WANT TO ENSURE THE VALIDITY OF
THE PERMITTING PROCESS AND SO
WE ARE. NOT TAKING TO ACTIONS-
THAT WERE ANNOUNCED IN
NOVEMBER- THE FIRST IS
INITIATING AN AUDIT BY THE
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THAT
ENTITY WILL REVIEW THE
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR THESE
PRACTICES. OF SOUP TO NUTS OUT
IN COMING MONTHS AND WILL ISSUE
A PUBLIC FINDINGS ON THE
PERMITTING PROCESS AND WE HOPE
I AS AS APPROPRIATE- MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS HOW TO
STRENGTHEN THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. WHILE THAT SAY AUDIT
IS I IS TAKING PLACE- PERMITS
FOR THESE PRACTICES- THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED TO CAL JAM I
WILL BE. INDEPENDENTLY REVIEWED
ON A PERMIT BY PERMIT BASIS- BY
EXPERTS AT THE LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABORATORY.
THE NOTION IS IN ALL FAIRNESS
OUGHT TO THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
THAT ARE ENGAGE IN THIS
PRACTICE WHICH IS LEGAL UNDER
STATE LAW. WE ARE. OPEN TO
CONTINUING TO APPROVE THOSE
PERMITS IF INDEPENDENTLY
REVIEWED- UNTIL THAT AUDIT IS
BACK THAT REALLY. GET
ULTIMATELY ASSESSES THE
PERMITTING PROCESS MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CONFIRMS
THE VALIDITY OF OUR PERMITTING
PROCESS THAT'S REALLY THE THIRD
SET OF REGULATORY ACTIONS TAKEN
PLACE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO CAL JAMS OUT ROLE
IN THE STATE'S EFFORT TO REDUCE
CRIME AND- IT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CARBON NEUTRALITY
AND I'LL MENTION. TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM THAT NEWS MY
MINISTRATION AND TWENTY
NINETEEN- THAT REALLY RAISE
THIS QUESTION OF THE TRANSITION
TO OUR CLIMATE NEUTRALITY AND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR OIL AND GAS
SUPPLY. HI THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN PROTECTION AGENCY IS
INITIATING TWO INDEPENDENT
STUDIES FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ONE FOCUSED ON THIS
QUESTION OF. HOW IS- IS OIL AND
GAS- POLICY IMPACTED BY A
DECLINE IN THE DEMAND FOR
FOSSIL FUELS OVERTIME SO REALLY
THIS QUESTION OF HOW DO WE
MANAGE THE DECLINE OF DEMAND
FOR FOSSIL FUELS AND WHAT DOES
IT MEAN FOR OUR SUPPLY POLICY.
THAT STUDY IT HAS BEEN PUBLICLY
SCOPED MEANING IT IT RECEIVED
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
WHAT THE STUDY SHOULD- SHOULD
FOCUS ON. AND IS GETTING UNDER
WAY I BELIEVE IN COMING WEEKS A
TANDEM STUDY OR COMPANION STUDY
ARE ALSO OVERSEEN BY THE-
CALLIE PA WILL FOCUS ON HOW WE
CAN REDUCE. EMISSIONS
TRANSPORTATION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE RECOGNIZING THAT'S
GOING TO BE ESSENTIAL TO MOVE
TOWARD CLIMATE NEUTRALITY. IN
ALLOW BUDGET LAST YEAR'S BY GOV
ALSO MADE A FIVE YEAR
COMMITMENT REGARDING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- TO ENSURE THAT AS
OUR DEMAND FOR ENERGY CHANGES
AND AS THIS TRANSITION TAKES
PLACE TO REDUCE THE WARY REDUCE
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS.
THAT OPPORTUNITIES EXIST FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE PART IN
THOSE NEW INDUSTRIES AND THAT
AT THIS TRANSITION TAKES PLACE
NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND. WHO IS
IN A WORKING IN IN WHATEVER IN
VARIOUS INDUSTRIES SO THAT IS A
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OUT THROUGH OUR G.
G. R. AFTER A GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND PROGRAMS- EACH
YEAR FOR THEEXT FIVE YEARS.
LET ME JUST LASTLY SAY THAT- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
FIVE BILLS THAT FURTHER
STRENGTH AND REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT. ON OIL AND GAS AND
THEN BELIEVE LAST WEEK I. WAS
IN CLEAR OPPOSITION DE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EFFORT TO
EXPAND OIL AND GAS- EXTRACTION
ON FEDERAL LANDS ARE WITHIN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. SO
HOPEFULLY I PROVIDED WHAT ARE
OUR OVER ARCHING PRINCIPLES
GUIDING OVERSIGHT OF OIL AND
GAS AND THEN GIVEN AT LEAST TOP
LEVEL SUMMARY OF RECENT
INITIATIVE THAT WE HAVE
ANNOUNCED. AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE. THE LONG AND SENATOR.
AND THEN LET THEM ON BEHALF OF
PLACES THEY WANT AND THEY TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS THE FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL FOR ME TO WATCH
THE NEXT CHANNEL I WANT THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND- FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I'M VERY
BY. FOCUS APARTMENT. THREE
TWENTY. WHEN WE GOT ON WITH HIM
AND IN GENERAL I'M VERY HAPPY
TO HEAR ON WHAT SHAPING UP TO
BE A VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND I
THINK HOMELESS OR THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU. YOU IF YOU HAVE
TO DESIGN THE WHAT BUT I HAVE A
FEW MORE THAT I WILL YOU KNOW
ASK SURE NOW MOVES TO MY
KNOWLEDGE FIRST YOU SEE I HAVE
USED THAT YOU WERE WORKING IS A
LITTLE MORE ON LOOKING AT THE
SCIENCE OF THAT DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE AND I'M LOOKING
PERMIT BY PERMIT. DO YOU ANY
KIND OF UP HI AM SORRY OKAY
NONE OF THAT WAS HEARD ANYBODY
EXCEPT FOR YOU MAYBE EIGHT TO
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT ROOM I JUST
FOR THE FOLK THAT WERE ON
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHEN I SAY
I WANTED I THANK THE SECOND FOR
BEING HERE FOR. ADMINISTRATIONS
COMPREHENSIVE AND HOLE LIKE A
PRO I'M AND THE. THAT WAS
PRETTY MUCH AT IT WAS A LONG
WAY OF THAT I'M- TO. SEE THEM.
WORK ON FULL ON THE THEY- MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE I THINK A THIS
AREA YOU KNOW THE- KIND OF OUR
FOR OUR- FUTURE I'M WITH REGARD
TO OIL AND GAS AND CLIMB. SO MY
FIRST WAS A THE WEALTHY. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A- A MORE RIGOROUS AYE TYPER
PERMITTING AND LOOKING PERMIT
TO PERMIT. DO YOU ENVISION ANY
SCENARIO WHERE YOU WILL EITHER
SEVERELY RESTRICTED NEW PERMITS
AFTER THE MORATORIUM OR EVEN
JUST STOP THE PRACTICE ALL
TOGETHER OR IS IT TOO EARLY TO
EVEN SPECULATE. WELL FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THE LEGISLATURE.
FOCUSED VERY INTENSELY ON ON
THE PRACTICE OF HYDRAULIC
FRACTURING IN SENATE BILL FOR-
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND HAS
ESTABLISHED YOU KNOW CLEAR
LEGISLATIVE OP PARAMETERS AS IT
RELATES TO THAT PRACTICE. SO
OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN LAST ABOUT
REEVALUATING THAT PRACTICE AND
IN THIS CASE MORE ABOUT
ENSURING THAT VIOLATED THE-
THOROUGHNESS OBJECTIVE NOUS OF
OUR PERMITTING PROCESS. SO I
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT WITHIN
THESE PERMIT BY PERMIT REVIEWS
OR WITH IN THIS AUDIT PROCESS.
THAT WE WOULD MAKE FINDINGS
PROBABLY FURTHER RESTRICTING
THE PRACTICE. THIS FOCUSED ON
BOTH THE SAY AUDIT AND THE
PERMIT BY PERMIT REVIEW IS
REALLY ENSURING THAT THE-
APPROPRIATE STEPS IN THE
PERMITTING PROCESS HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED. OKAY AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN REQUIRED CAL GEMS PURPOSE
TO REGULATE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION TO INCLUDE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AS YOU
MENTION OF SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
INCLUDING REDUCTION IN
MITIGATION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HYDROCARBON AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES IN A
MANNER THAT MEETS THE ENERGY TO
NEEDS OF THE STATE HOW DO YOU
INTERPRET THAT REQUIREMENT HOW
DO YOU SEE. YOUR POLICIES
ALTERING TO SATISFY- THAT
DEMAND YEAH THE GOVERNOR'S
TALKED ABOUT A LONG TERM
TRANSITION TO REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND-
AND ULTIMATELY ACHIEVING
CLIMATE NEUTRALITY AND THAT
WILL OBVIOUSLY INVOLVE A
TRANSITION. ARE AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS I'LL MENTION THAT
OUTSIDE OF POLICY MAKING THE
PRODUCTION OF OIL AND OIL AND
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY DECLINE
SINCE THE LATE EIGHTIES- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AS A RESULT OF.
MEDICATIONS AND ACTUALLY BEING
ABLE TO ADD- BY THE SUPPLY BUT
IN ANY EVENT OUR VISION IS
THERE IS CLEARLY A TRANSITION
THAT NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE. IN
ORDER TO ABIDE STATE WATER
REDUCE EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN
THE STATE DIVISION FOR CLIMATE
NEUTRALLY. THAT TRANSITION
HOUSE TO BE THOUGHTFUL. AND
TAKE I AM YOU SAID IT BOTH BOTH
REVIEWS BOTH THOSE WORDS IN
TERMS OF THOUGHT FALL. AND TAKE
TIME AND THAT WE MEAN. AFTER AN
WRECKED AS THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF WOMEN IN CAL WORK AS AN. AND
ANY TRACK XIN. ARMED THAT CHEFS
OUR DEPENDENCE ON AND A SOURCE.
ARE WE REALLY HAVE TO PHùON
IN A- CONTINUED OPPORTUNE FOR
THOSE THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHAT
IS KNOWN IN. IN THIS IN THESE
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AS A JUST
TRANSITION- BUT THEN ALSO
RECOGNIZING OUR CONTINUED
DEMAND FOR OIL AND GAS IN THE
STATE- AS YOU ALL PROBABLY KNOW
OUR VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IS.
NOT BEING REDUCED AND HOW WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE. HIGH DEMANDS
FOR. GASOLINE ABOUT A THIRD OF
WHICH IS PRODUCED USING
CALIFORNIA A SUPPLY. OUR NEXT
STEP TO REALLY NAVIGATING WHAT
IS THE PATHWAY- ON THIS
INTERSECTION BETWEEN- FOSSIL
FUEL DEMAND AND ANY SUPPLY
POLICY IS THIS INDEPENDENT
STUDY AT THE UC IS INITIATING.
AND THAT WILL IDENTIFY OP
POTENTIAL PATHWAYS ON THAT
COULD INFORM OUR SUPPLY POLICY
AS WE REDUCE OUR DEMAND IN
COMING DECADES- WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION NOR ARE WE DIRECTING
CAL JAM TO BE IN A POSITION TO-
MAKE- BLASTING DECISIONS
REGARDING. OUR OIL SUPPLY-
SHORT OF AN ESTABLISHED PATHWAY
THAT'S THAT'S NOT TRANSPARENT
AND I AND IN STUDY VERY
CAREFULLY. AND I'M CURIOUS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER NATIONS AND
WE'RE NOT A NATION BUT ARE
THERE ANY NATION'S WE CAN LOOK
TO WHERE YOU FEEL THAT THEY ARE
ACTIVELY TRYING TO MANAGE THAT
A DEMAND REDUCTION ANY ANY GOOD
MODELS OUT THERE. WELL
CERTAINLY I MEAN I THINK
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN
REDUCING OUR DEMAND IN THE
SENSE THAT WE HAVE- ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PENETRATIONS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE'VE SHIFTED.
MANY OF MUCH OF OUR ENERGY
GENERATION TO FOLLOW UP ALSO
FREE- OF ENERGY. I THINK THAT
ARE REALLY STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
THAT CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
BASES ACROSS THE WORLD TO
REDUCE. OUR FOSSIL FUEL DEMAND-
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED COMPLY.
QUESTION ABOUT- HOW TO MANAGE
OUR OIL AND GAS SUPPLY- WHILE
WE ARE WHILE OUR ECONOMY'S TO
ME. THAT RESOURCE. I'M SORRY
YOUR WE FIRST SO LEGISLATOR MAN
MANDATE REPORTS FROM CAL JAM
THE WEEK BEFORE THIS HEARING
AND WE APPRECIATE THE RELEASE
OF THE REPORTS AND CERTAINLY
FOR OUR HEARINGS- PURPOSES IT
WAS GOOD TIMING BUT MANY OF
THESE REPORTS WERE ALMOST SIX
MONTHS LATE AND I'M WONDERING
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT WAYS OF
SPEEDING UP THE- TRANSPARENCY
IN RELEASE OF INFORMATION TO
THE PUBLIC AND- WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT REPORTS
ARE TIMELY IN THAT INFORMATION
GETS OUT IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER YEAH WELL SAY. WE NEED
TO DO BETTER OUR COMMITMENT IS
TO GET THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION
NOT TO THE LEGISLATIVE
LEGISLATURE AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN- IT'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN A YEAR
OF TRANSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION AND AT CAL JAM
I IN SO MUCH OF OUR FOCUS WAS
GETTING THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP IN
PLACE IN ANNOUNCING THESE
INITIATIVES ABOUT MOVING FOR IT
I THINK YOU CAN AND SHOULD
EXPECT- THAT MORE TIMELY
DELIVERY OF INFORMATION THAT
YOU REQUEST. THANK YOU NOW ALL
TURNED TO A MY- FELLOW MEMBERS-
IS THE AMOUNT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I THINK YOU SECRETARY
CROWFOOT FOR YOUR PRESENTATION-
A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF ITEMS
THAT YOU'VE TOUCHED ON AND
FIRST YOU TALK YOU MENTIONED
THE MORATORIUM. AND THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT CAME LAST.
SUMMER IT IN A YOU KNOW AS A
RESULT. OF SOME OF THE
CONCERNS- I FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHERS IN
OUR STATE. THE MORATORIUM
SPECIFICALLY AS- IT IS RELATED
TO STEAM INJECTION- AT BUT IT
DOESN'T COVER ALL TYPE OF THE-
STEAM INJECTION SO. CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY THE
LOW PRESSURE- WAS NOT COVERED
UNDER THE MORATORIUM OR WITH
THE THOUGHTS ARE FOR YOU KNOW
WHERE THE MORE TRAIN WAS REALLY
ABOUT PARTIAL USE NOT VERSE IS
NOT FULL. YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO
THE MORATORIUM ON HIGH PRESSURE
STEAM INJECTIONS ABOVE THE
FRACTURE GRADIENT. INTENSELY
FOCUSED ON THIS CHALLENGE THAT
THE STATE IS HAVING WITH
SURFACE EXPRESSIONS OR SO
CALLED OIL SPILLS WHERE THERE
IS UNPREDICTED ON TROLL OIL
BUBBLING UP TO THE SURFACE. OUR
TECHNICAL STAFF AT JAM BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS AN ASSOCIATION IN
AT LEAST SOME OF THE OIL FIELDS
ARE BETWEEN THIS HIGH PRESSURE
STEAM INJECTION ABOUT THE
FRACTURE GRADIENT AND THOSE
UNCONTROLLED UNPREDICTED OIL
SPILLS. REGULATIONS THAT TOOK
EFFECT LAST APRIL- SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBIT SURFACE EXPRESSIONS.
AND INSTITUTED NEW RULES TO
ELIMINATE SERVICE EXPRESSIONS
DESPITE THOSE STRONGER
REGULATIONS AS OF APRIL WE
EXPERIENCE THIS SPATE OF
SURFACE EXPRESSION THROUGHOUT
THE SUMMER INCLUDING THE
LARGEST. OIL SPILL LAND BASED
OIL SPILL IN IN IN RECORDED
HISTORY IN THE STATE THE SAME
RECOIL SPELL THAT YOU HEAR MORE
ABOUT. AS A RESULT OF THAT. OUR
TECHNICAL STAFF A CAL JAM ARE
RECOMMENDED A MORATORIUM ON
THIS PRACTICE ON UNTIL AN
INDEPENDENT REVIEW. PLACE I'M-
OUT CHEN BUT WITH LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
IF THAT PRACTICE OF HIGH
PRESSURE STEAM INJECTIONS BUT
THE FRACTURE GRADIENT CAN BE
CONDUCTED SAFELY IF. AND THEN
IF IT CAN BE CONDUCTED SAY.
WHERE AND HOW IT CAN BE.
CONDUCTED SAY. OUR OUR WILL OR
ACTUALLY A RESPONSIVE IS TO A
LIMB SURF EXPRESSIONS TO
ELIMINATE THESE UNCONTROLLED
UNPREDICTABLE- LAND BASED OIL
SPILLS ARE MORATORIUM HELPS US
GET WE BELIEVE GET A HANDLE ON
WHETHER THAT PRACTICE IS
ESSENTIALLY PART OF THE PROBLEM.
AND MORE TRAM AGAIN IT WAS
PARTIAL AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHY THE IT WAS INCLUDED IT WAS
IT JUST BECAUSE IT WAS A
RESPONSE TO THIS IMMEDIATE OIL
SPILL OR WAS IT BECAUSE THERE
IS GREATER RESEARCHER CITY
THAT'S GOING TO BE DONE ON LOW
PRESSURE. SUPERVISOR IN TALK AT
A PETROLEUM ENGINEER WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION
MORE INTELLIGENTLY THAN I WILL
BUT I WILL SAY. THAT THE
PRACTICES OF CYCLIC STEAMING
BELOW THE FRACTURE GREAT IN AND
SEPTIC STEAMING ABOVE THE
FRACTURE GRADING WE'RE ACTUALLY
BREAKING SUBSURFACE OP- ARE TWO
DISTINCT PRACTICES AND IT FELL
OUT- ABOVE THE FRACTURE IN
WHERE IF OUR TECHNICAL EXPERTS
HAVE THE MOST CONCERN LEADING
THE FOR SERVICE EXPRESS. Q. AND
THE OTHER PIECE THE I WANTED TO
AND ARE CHAIR AT TO TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ON IT WAS THE C. C.
S. T. S. SUMMARY. AND IN
ADDITION TO JUST THE TIMING OF
IT I'M ACTUALLY- WANTING TO
KNOW WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT IF THERE'S
ANY THOUGHTS- THERE ARE
CURRENTLY OVER FIVE THOUSAND
OIL WELLS IN CALIFORNIA- THAT.
THAT TO US WE COULD END UP
PLAYING THE CLEAN UP COST FOR
THAT OUR ORPHAN WELLS SO. IF
THAT WERE THE CASE WORST CASE
SCENARIO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ANYWHERE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO FIVE TO NINE BILLION
DOLLARS- DEPENDING ON- THE YOU
KNOW THE OUR ABILITY TO CLEAN
UP AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF
YOU CAN COMMENT. ON HOW YOU
KNOW WHAT'S NEXT YEAH SO ACROSS
THE COMPANY ARE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- GOVERNMENTS FACE THIS
CHALLENGE OF POTENTIALLY LARGE
VERY LARGE- FINANCIAL
LIABILITY. OFF FOR- OF WELLS
THAT HAVE ESSENTIALLY BEEN
ORPHANED ON THAT WERE ONCE
OWNED BY A PRIVATE OPERATOR BUT
THAT GET LAPPED- HAVE PROBLEMS
I THEN GOT NEED TO NOT. AND
ACTUALLY STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE FACING THIS I
WOULD- OBSERVE WE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE THIS CHALLENGE AS WELL.
AND SO LJ I'M ACTUALLY BE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO I REQUESTED
THAT CCS T. WHICH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY REALLY OBJECTIVE
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS. STUDY THE
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL LIABILITY
THAT THE STATE HAS- THAT
REPORT- THAT WAS JUST RELEASED
DEMONSTRATES A SIGNIFICANT OUT
OUT. THANKS LIABILITY FOR THIS.
I'M OUR RESPONSE IS AT LEAST
TWO FOLD- ONE IS TO IMPLEMENT
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
BILL YOU AUTHORED THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS THAT ACTUALLY INCREASES-
BINDING REQUIREMENTS I'M
COMPANIES. THAT ACTUALLY HAVE
TO PUT UP MORE RESOURCES MORE
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT THERE
CAN BE SAFE CLEAN UP OF THEIR
ASSETS- BUT SECONDLY IT'S
ACTUALLY TO BRING IN MORE
CAPACITY AT CAL JAM. TO
ACTUALLY QUANTIFY WHAT BONDING
REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE- THERE'S
SOME LEVEL OF SENSITIVITY ONTO
A BINDING REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
WE HAVE VERY LARGE COMPANIES IN
THIS INDUSTRY AND WE HAVE
SMALLER COMPANIES AS YOU KNOW.
AND SOME OF THE SMALL COMPANIES
ARE CONCERNED WITH WHAT THEY
WOULD CONSIDER TO BE EXCESSIVE
BONDING REQUIREMENTS SO WE HAVE
TO GET THIS RIGHT WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT COMPANIES ARE
COVERING THEIR OWN FINAL INCH
FINANCIAL LIABILITY BUT DO IT
IN A FAIR WAY. SO IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ACTUALLY RECALL. LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL. POSSESS TO ACTUALLY.
ON APPROPRIATE AND ADEQUATE
BONDING UP FOR PRIVATE
COMPANIES. WELL IT'S A GREAT TO
HEAR THAT IN AND WHILE TEN
FIFTY SEVEN- WAS AN INCREASE IN
MEAN IT FALLS REALLY SHORT OF
THE OF THE POTENTIAL THAT WE
SAW IN THE C. C. S. T. REPORT
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT YOU
KNOW MAXIMUM BONDING THIRTY
MILLION VERSUS WHAT WERE
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT- AGAIN
WORST CASE SCENARIO WE DON'T
KNOW THE CONDITION OF EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE ABANDONED
WELLS- WHETHER THEY YOU KNOW
TYPE OF REMAIN. CAN THEY WILL
NEED BUT ANYTHING THAT TO
TAXPAYERS FIVE TO NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN A WORST CASE AND-
I'M IS FINITELY ALARMING IT
MAKES THE THIRTY MILLION
INCREASE JUST SEEM LIKE IT'S
PENNIES- IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE TO CLEAN UP I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THERE'S GONNA
BE MORE. ON THE U. YOU SOME
NEVER SURE TO. OUR CITY. THANK
YOU. MR SACK ARE WELL. TO JOINT
COMMITTEE HEARING ARM. I AT THE
GOV. AND YOU'RE LEADERSHIP. AS
EXPRESSED IN THE YEAR NOVEMBER
AT ASSIGNMENTS ANNOUNCEMENT-
ON- A SERIES OF MEASURES TO-
MADE TO ENSURE THAT OUR OIL.
AND GAS EXTRACTION PRACTICES
ARE OUR A- A PROTECTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND- THIS YEAR
YOUR YOUR TIMING IS PERFECT
WHICH IS DEBATED A- A BILL MY
BILL ON- THE ISSUE. OF WHETHER
OR NOT STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I
SHOULD HAVE- AND MINIMUM HEALTH
AND SAFETY. BOB JONES BETWEEN
OIL EXTRACTION ACTIVITIES AND-
LAW CENTER POPULATIONS LIKE-
SCHOOL'S PLAYGROUND. AND HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES ARM. BUT YOU
KNOW I WELL WE I DON'T KNOW FOR
A IF YOU. IT TALK MORE A DETAIL
INTO OF WELL WHAT YOU IN THE
GOVERNOR ARE- ARE CONSIDERING
AT THIS POINT IN TERMS OF- VIA
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY BUFFER
ZONES- SO I'D LIKE TO START
WITH THAT. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO AS I
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED IN AND WE ANNOUNCED
IN NOVEMBER NOW THE INITIATION
OF A RULE MAKING PROCESS- TO
IMPROVE UP PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY MEASURES- OF OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION TO PROTECT-
COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE- WE ARE
KICKING THAT PROCESS OFF. IN
REALLY JUST A FEW WEEKS I
BELIEVE WITH OUR FIRST. PUBLIC
MEETING IN WHAT WE CALL THE PRE
RULE MAKING PROCESS. AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A VERY ROBUST PRE
RULE MAKING PROCESS BECAUSE IT
LETS US GET OUT ACROSS THE
STATE AND TALK TO A COMMUNITIES
NEARBY OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION
COMPANIES I ENGAGED IN THESE
PRACTICES REALLY EVERY MANNER
STAKEHOLDER TO GET INPUT- THEN
THE CAL JAM STAFF. ACTUALLY
TAKE THAT INPUT AND THEN DOES
ITS OWN ANALYSIS AROUND-
POTENTIAL MEASURES THE ADVOCACY
OF THOSE MEASURES AND THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THOSE
MEASURES- WE MADE CLEAR AND
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE CLEAR WE
NEED TO ACCESS. EXPERTS IN I'M
NOT ONLY THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY BUT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT MEASURES ARE
MOST APPROPRIATE- WE HAVE NOT
FORMED ANY CONCLUSIONS ON WHAT
MEASURES ARE WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE. TO INCLUDE IN THIS
RULE MAKING ON THE ROOM PICKING
NEED TO BE A TRANSPARENT
SCIENCE BASED VERY CAREFUL
PROCESS- TO UPDATE OUR
REGULATIONS AND ULTIMATELY A
NEED TO BE. A DURABLE OF TO.
I'M SO WILL BE A CAREFUL CLASS
AND WE WILL MOVE AS QUICKLY AS
WE CAN. BUT IN A MANNER YOU ARE.
OUT YEAH GEN. I MEASURES THAT
ARE BOTH IMPORT APPROPRIATE AND
ALL DEFENDABLE. AND IT HAS AS
YOU ARE WELL OF. ALLOW OF THE
OIL EXTRA ACTIVITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TAKE PLACE
AND LOW INCOME COMMITTEES OF
COLOR AND OTHER- SO CALLED AND
FARMER JUSTICE COMMUNITIES-
WHAT WHAT STEPS WILL YOU WILL
YOU BE TAKEN TO ENSURE THAT-
THERE IS ADEQUATE PARTICIPATION
AND INPUT FROM- THESE-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF- WELL
EXTRACTION ACTIVITIES. THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION SO WE'VE WE'VE
LISTENED TO LEADERS AND GROUPS
REPRESENTING MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WHO MADE VERY CLEAR
THAT- THE PRE RULE MAKING
PROCESS HAS TO BE CONDUCTED IN
A WAY THAT'S ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO THAT'S
LINGUISTICALLY ASSESSABLE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR OUR SPANISH
SPEAKING RESIDENTS. WE ALSO
NEED TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO OUR
FOLKS WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO
TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO OR TO OUR
BIG CITY SO ARE A SERIES OF
WORKSHOPS WILL. HE'S IN
CALIFORNIA- INCLUDING MANY THAT
HAVE OIL PRODUCTION RIGHT
THEY'RE BOTH SMALL AND LARGE
AND OUR COMMITMENT IS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AND ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPARENT ARE PRE RULE MAKING
PROCESS SO WE CAN. NOT REALLY
BENEFIT FROM THE INPUT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS OKAY. AND LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST YOU KNOW IN
ISSUE THAT TO. YOU AND I HAVE
HAVE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
INFORMALLY IN AND I'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
YOU KNOW IS THAT ISSUE OF THE
JUST TRANSITION THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- GIVE ME FOR MY
EXPERIENCE. THE SO THIS NOT TO
CRACK IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
FIGURE OUT A JUST TRANSITION SO
THAT WE GET. YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY ARE A- ARE- UNION
BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO. TO
TRANSITION FROM- FROM THE
FOSSIL FUEL JOBS TO- FUTURE
CLEAN ENERGY JOBS- IS- IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
CHALLENGES. AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES THAT I SEE IN
TERMS OF. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- ACHIEVING OUR OR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS ARE ARE
THERE- YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU SAID
THAT- IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A-
THOUGHTFUL NIS AND A LOT OF
TIME TO FIGURE THINGS OUT BUT
THE ARE ARE THERE ARE THEIR
OTHER. STATES THAT- THAT- CAN
PROVIDED SOME GUIDANCE IN TERMS
OF HOW- WE SHOULD BE PUT
PROCEEDING. LICENSES THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION AND
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE. YOU KNOW
THIS TRANSITION AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS IN COMING DECADES
REALLY TO ACHIEVE THE STATE
LEGALLY MANDATED EMISSION
REDUCTION TARGETS CLIMATE
NEUTRALITY- REALLY NEED TO TAKE
PLACE CAREFULLY. JUST LAST WEEK
OR THE WEEK BEFORE SOME OF OUR
AT LEADERSHIP FROM- THAT YOU'LL
HEAR. LATER AT THIS HEARING
WE'RE DOWN IN KERN COUNTY WHICH
IS- AN AREA OF THE STATE THAT
PRODUCES A LARGE PORTION OF OUR
OIL- WHERE. THERE ARE QUITE A
LOT OF MIDDLE CLASS JOBS OFFER
KERN COUNTY RESIDENTS AND A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT
COUNTY GENERAL FUND IS DERIVED
FROM REVENUES OF OIL AND GAS.
AND THEY MADE VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW ARE. NOT TRANSITION I
IMPACTS THEIR OWN ECONOMY AND
JOBS THAT ARE PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE. AND SO OUR
COMMITMENT IS TO PARTNER- WITH
KERN COUNTY WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND REALLY TALK
ABOUT- WATER POLICIES ARE. AND
WHAT THEY'RE NOT- BECAUSE
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF CONCERN
AND- AND ABOUT- SOME OF THESE
ACTIONS THAT ARE REALLY NOT
RELATED TO THAT TRANSITION- BUT
REALLY WORKING WITH THEM- TO
CONTINUE TO DIVERSIFY AND
STRENGTHEN OUR ECONOMY OF. TIME
I AM VERY EXCITED THAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE LEADERS IN
BAKERSFIELD FOR EXIT ALL HAVE A
REALLY PROACTIVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. I'M AFTER THERE
WERE ON IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT-
LEADERSHIP- BUT AGAIN WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
CONSIDER WHAT. ARE TRANSITION
SHOULD BE ARE TOWARDS OTHER
SOURCES OF ENERGY THAT WE HAVE
A VERY CLEAR PATHWAY FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE. MAKING
THEIR LIVING IN THAT INDUSTRY.
THANK THANK YOU I HAVE JUST
BEEN TO BY SENATORS JACKSON AND
NAY CO CHAIR HENRY STERN HE SO
I WILL IF IT OF THEM HAVE ANY
AND I WILL START WITH THE
SENATOR STERN. AT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THANKS FOR.
PUTTING IN THE HARD WORK
ESPECIALLY STAFF GETTING ALL
THIS STARTED IN A FEW MONTHS IN
THE MAKING HERE FRANKLY WHEN
THE- WHEN THE- SIMMER SPILL
HAPPENED. YOU KNOW WE WERE WE
WERE REALLY INTENT ON BRING YOU
GUYS IN RIGHT AWAY DIGGING IN-
ESPECIALLY AMIDST ALL THE OTHER
CHALLENGES DOG EARED BEEN
FACING LAST YEAR WE SAW A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ISSUE
ARISES. REPORTS ON DUMMY
PERMITS IT WAS A TOUGH YEAR FOR
DOGGER LAST YEAR WHICH IS WHY I
WAS ACTUALLY. EXCITED THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON STEPPED
UP AND HELPED- WITH US AND YOU.
I CLOSE THAT CHAPTER AND IT WAS
THE END OF DOG SO I'M I'M
EXCITED ABOUT TODAY AND I
REALLY JUST. ONE YOU TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR ON OUR BEHALF FOR
NOT HAVING TO GO THROUGH-
GOTCHA PROCESS AND- DO THEY DO
THIS SORT OF SONG AND DANCE
PART OF AN OVERSIGHT HEARING
BUT YOU ALL STEPPED IN
IMMEDIATELY. TOOK ON THE
CONFLICT INTERESTED ISSUE HEAD
ON I KNOW WE'RE GONNA TALK
THROUGH THE RESPONSE IN THE
SORDID HOURS AFTER SAM RICK
AND- RAPID RESPONSE THERE FROM.
WHAT IS NOW CAL JAM AND D. O.
C. BUT SINCE WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF YOU HERE MISTER
SECRETARY- I KNOW YOU'RE
STARTED TALK ABOUT SOME AS HIGH
LEVEL ISSUES AROUND. FOSSIL
FUEL DEPENDENCE AND SOME OF THE
TENSIONS IN THE STATE. WE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME WORKING ON
FRACKING FEW YEARS BACK. TODAY
WE REALIZE THAT. IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT FRACKING. AND THAT THERE
ARE COMPLEXITIES WITH STEAM.
ESPECIALLY HIGH PRESSURE STATE
THAT GOES ABOVE THE FRACTURE
GRADING LIKE WE'VE SEEN OUT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- THAT LED
TO. THIS MXC AND SO- THE
UNDERGROUND INJECTION CONTROL
PROGRAM IS SOME VERY INTERESTED
IN I JUST WANTED TO TRY TO GET
YOUR- YOUR THOUGHTS I KNOW. THE
AGENCY OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
HAS STARTED TO RECOGNIZE
THERE'S A THERE'S A CHALLENGED
THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T KNOW-
THE REPORT YOU ALL RELEASED AND
I WAS THRILLED TO SEE I THINK
THREE REPORTS ACTUALLY CAME
THROUGH IN THE LAST WEEK FROM
RESOURCES DO SEE. CAL JIM BUT-
ONE OF THEM TROUBLED ME. OUR
WHEN IT COMES TO SORT OF THE
PROJECT BY PROJECT REVIEW OF
ALL THE ACTIVE YOU I SEE GOING
ON AROUND THE STATE AND FOR ME
MEMBERS UNDERGRAD INJECTION
CONTROL IS- IS A FRAMEWORK IN
WHICH AT IT'S NOT LIMITED JUST
TO FRACKING IT'S A DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATION OF WELLS BUT
ESSENTIALLY. ARE YOU I SEE
PERMIT AS TO BE OBTAINED FOR A
LOT OF THESE LARGE STEAM
ORIENTED OPERATIONS- AND WE
HAVE ABOUT. CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG NOW. BUT I THINK WE HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY SIX
ACTIVE YOU I SEE PROJECTS THAT
HAVE. BEEN SUBJECT TO- SIR WHAT
WOULD YOU GUYS ARE ON A PROJECT
BY PROJECT REVIEW AMONG THE
THOUSAND OR SO IN THE STATE.
AND FROM WHAT WE'VE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN I THINK. LESS THAN TEN
LET'S JUST SAY I'VE HEARD THE
NUMBER NINE I'VE HEARD LESS
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN COMPLETED.
THAT MEANS WE'VE WE'VE GOT
ABOUT. NINE HUNDRED. SOME ODD
MORE TO GO TO REALLY GET
OURSELVES AHEAD OF ANY
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS IN THE
FUTURE SO THAT WE DON'T GET
CAUGHT OFF GUARD HERE. AND
FRANKLY TO HELP THE INDUSTRY TO
BE GOOD STEWARDS IN GOOD
PARTNERS RIGHT IF WE HAVE BLIND
SPOTS OUT THERE AND THEIR OTHER
GEOLOGIC CHALLENGES WE GOT TO
GET AHEAD OF THAT STUFF- SO I
JUST WANTED TO GET A SENSE FROM
YOU. TIMELINE COMPLETION
SCHEDULE JUST HOW HOW TO GO
ABOUT THAT BROADER YOU I SEE
PROGRAM IF YOU. AND WHO YEAH
WELL WHAT WE CAN EXPECT I GUESS
IN THE COMING YEAR I KNOW
THERE'S A BUDGET REQUEST AND
SOME IS WILL BE ABOUT CAPACITY
BUILDING TO WITHIN THE AGENCY
BUT- ANY. PROJECTIONS ON ON SIR
TIMELINE A MILESTONE FOR THAT
BROADER. WAY OLD EXTRACTION
PERMIT LANDSCAPE THIS YEAR YEP
SO SUPERVISOR AND TOOK WOULD.
HAVE MAYBE MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION THAN I WOULD BUT
LET ME TAKE A CRACK- WHICH IS-
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS IMPROVING
OUR REGULATIONS ON UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROL INCLUDING A
SET OF STRENGTH AND REGULATIONS
THAT. THAT WENT INTO EFFECT
LAST APRIL. BUT THE DIVISION
RECOGNIZES THAT MORE WORK IS
NEEDED. AND INITIATED ARE ASKED
FOR AND ANOTHER INDEPENDENT
REPORT THAT YOU'LL SOON BE
RECEIVING FROM THE GROUNDWATER
PROTECTION COUNCIL. WHICH IS
THE NATIONAL BODY OF EXPERTS-
FOCUSED AT IN AND OUT REPORT OF
FOCUSES ITS REVIEW ON
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROL PROGRAM. AND
WILL IDENTIFY I. A SERIES
COMMENDATIONS TO STRENGTHEN
THAT PROGRAM. THAT REPORT. WELL
IN. A VERY BROAD TASK FORCE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED THROUGH
STATUTE- TO FURTHER RECOMMEND
CHANGES TO THE UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROL PROGRAM-
THAT- TASK FORCE HAS BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY FOR THIS
REPORT. AND WHEN IT RECEIVES IT
VERY SOON- WILL BENEFIT FROM
THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY
THIS DOT NATIONAL BODY THAT'S
TAKEN A VERY FOCUSED INTENSE
REVIEW OF THE U. I. C. PROGRAM-
AND THEN AS I UNDERSTAND THAT-
STATUTORILY REQUIRED. TASK
FORCE AGAIN COMPRISED OF A
BROAD CROSS SECTION OF
STAKEHOLDERS WILL ITSELF THEN I
RECOMMEND ARE FURTHER
STRENGTHENING OF THE OF YOU I
SEE REGULATIONS- SO IS THAT
SOMETHING. WE GET DONE THIS
YEAR. WELL IT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD MAKE AND I DON'T WANNA
MAJOR QUESTION SOMETHING WE
SHOULD MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS
YEAR WHAT I'M LEARNING. ABOUT
OUR RULE MAKING PROCESS IS IT'S
VERY CAREFUL AND DELIBERATE
HAVE AND SO IN TERMS OF
GETTING. UPDATED REGULATIONS
FINISH THIS YEAR I THINK THAT'S
UNREALISTIC- BUT YOU CAN
CERTAINLY ASK OTHERS WHO WHO
FOLLOW ME OUT FOR SORT OF MORE
DETAILS STEP FORWARD A GOOD
WILL DIG IN AND I'M JUST HOPING
WE CAN HAVE SOME
PRIORITIZATION. IS THERE'S SO
MANY WELLS OUT THERE AND WE'RE
JUST I MET THE ACTIVE YOU I SEE
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
ABANDONED WELLS AND- YOU KNOW.
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
LIABILITY WE'RE LOOKING AT
THERE'S A BIT OF A NEW
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE- THANKS TO
SOME COLLEAGUES WORK HERE BUT-
LET'S TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
PRODUCTIVE PRIORITIZATION LOOKS
LIKE SO THAT. ESPECIALLY THOSE
PROJECTS HAVE A REAL PEOPLE IT
FACE. RIGHT THAT ARE CLOSEST TO.
THAT ARE FRONT LINES- THAT THEY
HAVE SOME CERTAINTY ABOUT- WHAT
THEY CAN EXPECT- YOU KNOW THIS
IS URBAN LOS ANGELES DOWN IN
THE LONG BEACH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT I BACKYARDS
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA WE ARE AN
ALL STATE. WE STILL ARE DESPITE
ALL OUR- ENERGY GOAL THEN CLUB.
RATIONS I THINK IT'S TIME WE
GET HONEST ABOUT THIS I GUESS
THAT WAS MY OTHER QUESTION IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE ALREADY.
TOUCHED ON IT SOMEWHAT BUT-
YEAH IN TERMS OF WHAT THE TIME
LINE OR PLANNING IS AROUND
FINISHING THIS CARBON
NEUTRALITY STUDY AND HOW TO
REALLY WRESTLE WITH THOSE BIG
PICTURE ISSUES THEY HAVE A
SENSE FOR US OF I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN DOING YOUR- YOUR LISTEN
NOW LISTENING TO OUR MEDICAL
SCOPING PROCESS. HE WAS KERN
COUNTY HEARING THE OTHER DAY.
ZOOMING IS PROBABLY FEW MORE
SCHEDULE BUT GIVE SAYS SORT OF
SENSE OF. HOW YOU GUYS WANT TO.
ONE WHAT TIME WHEN YOU WERE
WRESTLE WITH THE STUDY ITSELF
AND THEN. REALLY WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT YOU YOU OVERSEE NOT
JUST OIL AND GAS BUT ALL THE
NATURAL AND WORKING LATE IN THE
STATE AND- AS FRUSTRATING AS
SOME OF THE SETBACKS MAYBE I
ALSO THINK THERE'S- SOME HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE THIS
STATE A NET- ANNETTE. SEQUESTER
CARBON TO ACTUALLY TAKE SOME OF
THIS POLLUTION AND REMOVE IT
THROUGH BETTER AG MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES TO BET FORCE
MANAGEMENT- SMARTER USE A BIO
MASS OF THINGS THAT- DON'T
ACTUALLY DIRECTLY INVOLVE THE
OIL INDUSTRY BUT- HOW DOES THAT
HELP YOU HELP US PEACE ALL THAT
TOGETHER SIR WHAT WHAT DO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS LOOKING AT
HERE AND YOUR HEAD. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT COMPLETING- I
BELIEVE BOTH OF THE STUDIES
THAT I MENTIONED I THINK BEFORE
YOU CAME IN ESSENTIALLY TANDEM
STUDIES. ARE MANAGED BY OUR
SISTER AGENCY CAL CALIFORNIAN
BY MY PROTECTION AGENCY. ONE
BEING FOCUSED ON. WHAT WHAT IS
THE PATHWAY TO CLIMATE
NEUTRALITY AS IT RELATES TO
FOSSIL FUEL DEMAND AND SUPPLY.
NOW WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON AS
WE REDUCE OUR BY THE DEMAND FOR
FOSSIL FUELS HOW SHOULD THAT
INFORM OUR POLICY ON OIL AND
GAS SUPPLY IN THE STATE. THAT'S
A COMPLEX SORT OF ALMOST ON
PRESIDENT A QUESTION. I AND SO
OUR APPROACH HAS BEEN TO REALLY
BRING IN THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST
MINDS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE UC
SYSTEM. TO COMPLETE AN
INDEPENDENT REPORT OR STUDY TO
REALLY EVALUATE PATHWAYS TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS. ARE THE
TEN THIS THE COMPANION STUDY IS
MORE FOCUSED ON WHAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING TO INTENSIFY I-
LECTURE FOR CATION OF
TRANSPORTATION A REDUCTION OF
POLLUTION FROM TRANSPORTATION.
I AND AGAIN I BELIEVE WE
ANTICIPATE DROPS OF BOTH OF
THOSE REPORTS TO THIS YEAR.
OKAY RIGHT ARM AND LASTLY ALL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES AFTER
THIS- DO YOU HAVE A SENSE
WHETHER- THEY'RE GONNA BE ANY.
I KNOW THERE'S A MORATORIUM AND
IS CURRENTLY ON- ON NEW-
PROJECTS- SORT OF ABOVE A
CERTAIN FRACTURE GRADIENT ABOVE
A CERTAIN PRESSURE GRADIENT-
FOR YOU I SEE PROJECTS AROUND
THE STATE BUT- THE BROADER
ISSUE UNDERLYING IT LITERALLY
PHYSICALLY IS THE AQUA FIRST-
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF EXEMPT
AQUIFER'S IN THE STATE- THAT
OUR- IS THE- BEYOND REPAIR. BUT
WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE NOT AND
TRY TO SQUARE THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES AND ARE THOSE REALLY
LIST ON THE EXAM DOCTOR FOR
LIST SHOULD ACTUALLY BE THERE-
ANY THOUGHTS AND JUST SORT OF.
GROUNDWATER IMPACT AND WHETHER
YOU WILL ANTICIPATE EXPANDING-
AQUIFER EXEMPTIONS DO YOU
ANTICIPATE ACTUALLY- MAKING IT
A NEW REQUEST FOR AQUIFER
EXEMPTION EXPANSIONS- HOW HOW
ARE YOU FEELING THAT. SO WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
STATE WATER BOARD IN A REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARDS
WHO ARE REALLY ARE KEY PARTNER-
ON THIS QUESTION OF ENSURING
THAT ANY OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
DOESN'T HAVE IMPACTS ON
AQUIFERS THAT COULD BE EVEN
REMOTELY USED- FOR. HUMAN USE.
THAT PARTNERSHIP EXTENDS ALSO
TO THE US ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY SO THERE'S
QUITE A CAREFUL GROUP OF
TECHNICAL EXPERTS THAT ARE
ADVISING I THE DIVISION- CAL
JAM- ON THIS QUESTION AROUND
WHICH AQUIFER'S ARE PROPRIA OIL
AND GAS- WE AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE BROUGHT UP
BROUGHT ON SUPERVISOR AND TALK-
AS OUR NEW OIL AND GAS
SUPERVISOR IS HIS. HIS
TECHNICAL BACKGROUND IN
PETROLEUM ENGINEERING AND HE IS
FOCUSING ON THE ON THIS
QUESTION WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
OUR OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
DOESN'T HAVE IMPACTS ON ON
DRINKING WATER AQUIFERS- THERE
IS A STRONG REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE FOR DOING
THAT AND WE JUST NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THAT'S IMPLEMENTED TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW. BUT
DESPITE THE POINT NO PLAN ON
EXPANDING EXEMPTIONS. NO WELL
OCT. YEAH I MEAN I THINK IT'S
BEST DIRECTED FOR THE
SUPERVISOR IN PART BECAUSE THIS
THIS REQUEST FOR AQUIFER
EXEMPTIONS IS SORT OF WHEN IT
ONE OF THE MANY PERMITTING
REQUEST THAT WE GET IN THE
STATE. FINISHED AND SO THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER WE ARE
APPROVING NEW AQUIFER
EXEMPTIONS THAT I WANT TO
SUGGEST THAT THE EXPANDING BUT
I THINK HE'S BEST ANSWER.
SOUTHERN SOUNDS LIKE SENATE
JACKSON GORGEOUS CENTER BOARD
IS FOR MY CHANG KEEPING. YOU
OFFER ME I CAME IN A LITTLE BIT
LATE- THE SENATE WHEN LONGER
THAN EXPECTED. I THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE CONTENTS PLEASURE. I
KIND OF WANTED TO. CHATTEL
ABOUT. THE LAW FUND ABILITY
BECAUSE YOU TALKED ABOUT-
THERE'S A UC STUDY THAT'S
FORTHCOMING AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF SUPPLY CALCULATION- WHICH WE
ARE COMMON A MOMENT AGO THAT IN
MANY RESPECTS WE STILL AREN'T
OIL STATE OR AT LEAST
INDUSTRIES- ARE RELIANT ON THAT
TRADITIONAL FORM OF ENERGY- DO
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON WHEN WE DO
PURSUE AS A STATE A MORE
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA-
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AGENDA
SO ON SO FORTH. THAT WE'VE THAT
WE SIMULTANEOUSLY CONTEMPLATE.
THROUGH THE STUDY OR THROUGH-
INPUTS INTO LEGISLATION ARM
AWAIT UNDERSTAND. HOW EXACTLY
ARE SUPPLY CALCULATION HE IS
GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY A GIVEN
PIECE OF LEGISLATION OR A-
SHUTTING OFF THE SPIGOT SO ON
AND SO FORTH BECAUSE MY CONCERN
IS THAT AS WE PURSUE AS WE
PURSUE A CLEANER FORM- OF
ENERGY AND ALL THAT ALL THE
INSTRUMENTS THAT GO INTO THAT.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO RELY MORE HEAVILY ENGLISH
CALIFORNIA ON FOREIGN IMPORTS
SO IT'S KIND OF LIKE WERE
BLOWING THE LEAVES OFF OUR LAWN
TO OUR OUR NEIGHBORS BUT- IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC POLICY WE'RE
IMPORTING FROM DRACONIAN
REGIMES ELSEWHERE IN THE CUT IN
THE WORLD. THEY DO NOT LIKE US
NOR DO THEY HOLD OUR VALUES TO
HEART. SO I GUESS DO YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS A RECOMMENDATION
THAT HOW DO WE BALANCE. THIS
DISCUSSION IN SUCH A WAY THAT
WE APPRECIATE THE LAW OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND WE
CAN DEAL WITH THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THOSE EVENTS BUT WERE
MINDFUL OF THEM BECAUSE MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS APPRECIATIVE. OF YOUR
WEATHER BEAT THE WORK FORCE- OR
THE IDEA THAT WE'RE IMPORTING
OIL AND OTHER FORMS OF ENERGY
FROM REALLY ROUGH PARTS OF THE
WORLD THAT. ARE WORKING AGAINST
US IN MANY RESPECTS. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION I WOULD SAY. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
EXPANDING CONSUMER CHOICES TO
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL
FUELS SO FOR EXAMPLE. ARE
ELECTRIFICATION OF PASSENGER
VEHICLES YOUR ELECTRIC CARS
SOLAR ON ROOFS ESSENTIALLY
FINDING WAYS TO REDUCE OUR OUR
DEMAND FOR FOSSIL FUELS
WHEREVER THEY COME FROM-
ULTIMATELY A WEEK WE NEED TO DO
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO MEET
THIS LEGALLY MANDATED TARGET TO
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS EIGHTY
PERCENT. THAT BEING SAD IT'S A
COMPLICATED QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR THE SUPPLY IN
CALIFORNIA- RECOGNIZING THAT A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE DEPEND ON
JOBS IN THE INDUSTRY PARTS OF
THE STATE ARE ARE RELYING ON
THAT AND THERE IS THIS QUESTION
AROUND SIMPLY REPLACING IN
STATE PRODUCTION WITH FOREIGN
PRODUCTION- IF AT IT IN SOME
CONTEST IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO RECOGNIZING THIS IS
COMPLICATED TERRIBLY
COMPLICATED AN ALMOST
UNPRECEDENTED TO ASK REALLY
THIS QUESTION ABOUT WHAT HOW
ARE SUPPLY POLICY SHOULD BE
IMPACTED BY OUR BROAD CLIMB
MICHAEL'S WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
TO DO THIS YOU SEE STUDY NOT TO
GIVE US THE ANSWERS BUT TO
FRAME PATHWAYS THAT WE CAN
FURTHER. DIALOGUE ABOUT I'M
RECOGNIZING WE KNOW THIS THE
TRANSITION IN TERMS OF REDUCING
FOSSIL FUEL THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE BUT IT HAS TO TAKE PLACE
CAREFULLY TO AVOID.
CONSEQUENCES WHEN THOSE REPORTS
ARE PUBLIC. THE OBVIOUS BE A
REALLY GOOD- PRODUCT TO INFORM
YOUR THANK YOU CONSIDER A JUST
AND ARE ARE INTERACTION I AS IT
RELATES OIL AND GAS. AN
OVERSIGHT WELL THANK YOU I
THINKTHAT IS IMPORTANT AND
LOOKING AROUND HERE AND I AM
JUST DID A GLASS NIGHT DO
TUNING. GEN THERE'S A GREAT I
MAKES YOU TO SEE CALIFORNIA
IT'S GOING DOWN. ALASKA'S DOWN.
SAUDI ARABIA. HAS BEEN IN THE
UPPER TRIP STRUCTURING YEAH SO
THAT THE LAW FUND YOUR WITH
WEEK CREATE A- AND BY HERE WE
ARE STILL. PART OF A LARGER
FAMILY AND BUNCH ABILITY PLAYS
INTO. INTO THAT I THINK THAT'S
A FAIR POINT AND WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE- THAT WHETHER YOU
KNOW WE'RE GENERATING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
GAS IMPORTED FROM SAUDI ARABIA
FROM CALIFORNIA WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE CREATING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO YOUR POINT IS YOUR
POINT IS A GOOD ONE. THANK YOU
A SENATOR JACKSON'S. ALL I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP IN AFTER
FIRST I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF. THE FACT THAT
WE ARE- GRANTING THESE AQUIFER
EXEMPTIONS. SO WE HAVE STATE
AGENCIES THAT THAT ARE
CONSULTED YOU MENTION A FEW OF
THEM AND THAT ARE TO REVIEW
BEFORE RECOMMENDING THE SHOCK
OF FOR EXEMPTIONS TO THE FENCE
WELL THAT SHOULD RESULT IN GOOD
DECISION MAKING BECAUSE WE ARE
CLOSER TO THE ISSUE AND CAN NO
MORE PRECISELY WHAT OUR STATE
AGENCIES AND REGIONAL AFFAIRS
OFFICES ARE DOING. BUT RECENTLY
AND IN MY DISTRICT ALONE IN
BOTH PARTS OF MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE TWO AQUIFER EXEMPTIONS
THAT ARE PROPOSED BY CAL JAM
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY CONTENTIOUS
AND I'M SITTING NEXT TO MY
COLLEAGUE THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMON IN WHOSE DISTRICT THOSE
TWO VERY CONTENTIOUS AQUIFER
EXEMPTIONS ALSO EXIST OR AT
LEAST ONE OF THEM. IT WILL BE
THE OTHER AT SOME POINT- AND
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED THE
COMMUNITIES WHICH IRONICALLY
ARE NOT NECESSARILY WHAT YOU'D
CALL ENVIRONMENTALLY THREE HAVE
GROUPS THERE. AREAS THE
RANCHERS. AND THERE IS EVEN
MINERAL EXPLOITATION AND SOME
OF THEM BUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POPULATIONS AND THE
LOCAL PEOPLE WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
THE- TO THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
THESE EXEMPTIONS. ARE ARE.
ACTIVELY TRYING TO GET BETTER
DATA BECAUSE THERE IS A STRONG
BELIEF BASED UPON EVIDENCE THAT
HAS ARISEN THAT THESE ARE
AQUIFER'S OUT WITH OIL WASTE
WATER ARE- AN IMPACT IN A
POTENTIAL DANGER TO THE TO THE-
WATER QUALITY AND THEIR
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY BUT SO
ONE OF THEM IS IN CAT CANYON
FOR EXAMPLE. OF THE COMMUNITY
THERE IS THAT'S COME TO US AS
HAS- HAS INDICATED THEY DON'T
WANT THE EXPANSION. OF BECAUSE
THEY ARE CONCERNED- THAT IT
WILL IMPACT BOTH THEIR WATER
QUALITY IN THEIR LOCAL AIR
QUALITY TWO HUNDRED NEW WELLS
BEING DRILLED THERE- AN ACTION
DEBATE. AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME THERE'S AN ONGOING STUDY
STILL PENDING THERE- BY THE US
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S THE SAME ONE THAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING EARLIER BUT
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
QUESTION WHETHER- WASTE WATER
THAT'S CONVENIENT FOR THE OIL
COMPANIES TO STASH UNDERGROUND
IS GOING TO BECOME A DRINKING
WATER SUPPLY- THAT ARE ALREADY
FACING SIGNIFICANT WATER
POLLUTION TO WATER QUALITY.
ISSUES THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE STATE I'VE
JUST PARTICULARLY AWARE OF THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S IN MY
DEATH DISTRICT AND THINGS LIKE
HEXAVALENT CHROMIUM. I MEAN WE
KNOW THESE ARE- CONTAMINANTS WE
KNOW THEY ARE CARCINOGENIC AND
YET- THIS KIND TO ALL OF. OUR
ENTHUSIASM GRANT EXEMPTIONS A
SEEMS TO STILL EXIST WHETHER WE
CALL A DOCTOR OR CAL JAMMER
WHATEVER WE CALL IT SO I'M
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED WITH-
WHAT. ARE YOUR POLICY IS GOING
TO BE- ESPECIALLY WITH THESE
APPROVAL STILL HAPPENING WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO HOLD THE LINE
ON THIS UNTIL AT LEAST THIS.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY IS COMPLETED
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE IS A- A
MOVE TO GRANT EXEMPTIONS. UP OF
RATHER THAN TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CIRCUMSPECT ABOUT THEM AND
I GET CONCERNED WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WELL THE NEED FOR JOBS I
MEAN EITHER WE'RE GOING TO MEET
OUR GOALS. IN OUR GHG GOALS AND
IN OUR- OUR QUALITY THAT YOU
KNOW OUR OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY- GOALS OR WE'RE NOT.
AND I CHEST THIS THIS NOTION
THAT WE HAVE TO WAIT THE TWO
HAS HISTORICALLY I THINK BEEN
OF THE THUMB HAS BEEN OF FOR
THE JOBS. ISSUE RATHER THAN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES NOW I'M
NOT SAYING WE GO COLD TURKEY
BUT WE'VE RENAMED DAGR CAL JAM
WITH THE WITH THE MISSION THAT
IT BE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HEALTH ASPECTS OF OIL AND GAS
DRILLING AND YET I'M NOT
SENSING AND I HAVEN'T HEARD YOU
SAY. YET TODAY THAT THAT IS
INDEED. THE COMMITMENT IN THE
MISSION OF YOUR YOUR WORK. YEAH
WELL THANK YOU SENATOR AND HAVE
YOU MISSED THE OPENING WHEN I
WAS IDENTIFYING REALLY THE TWO
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE DRIVING OUR
OIL AND GAS OVER STATE- ONE OF
WHICH IS A STRENGTH IN
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EARLY MON TEN FIFTY SEVEN- AB
TEN FIFTY SEVEN- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TAKEN TO HEART AND WE'RE
GLAD TO- PARTNER ON THE UPDATE
OF. OF CAL GEMS MISSION- I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU ALSO HEARD ME
EXPLAIN THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN THE DIVISION'S HISTORY WE
ARE. A FOCUSING A SPECIFIC RULE
MAKING ON IMPROVING HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS- TO WITH THAT
WITH A FOCUS ON- COMMUNITIES
ADJACENT OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
SO. I'M WILL ULTIMATELY NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE DOING- TO EMBODY THE
MISSION BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE
WORK IS UNDER WAY- ON THE ISSUE
OF CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR OBVIOUSLY- LAST YEAR-
TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM ACROSS
THE STATE WERE COMMUNITIES. I
DON'T HAVE ACCESS DICK SAFE
DRINKING WATER SO INSURE THAT
THAT COMMUNITIES DO HAVE THAT
CLEAN SAFE WATER IS. A HUGE
PRIORITY I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
NEED TO I CAL JAM ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THE BEST SCIENTIFIC
INFORMATION. TO MAKE THOSE TO
SIT AROUND WHICH AQUIFER'S ARE
SAFE TO INJECT. YOU KNOW
TREATED. BOB WATER I LOOK IN
THE TO INSTANCES I BELIEVE IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY THAT YOU
REFERENCE- ONES ALSO A FILM
MORE. OKAY INVENTOR ACCOUNT
OKAY GOT IT- SO WHAT WILL WILL
FOLLOW UP I AND TAKE MORE INTO
THOSE- DIRECTLY BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THERE'S NO ENTHUSIASM
NECESSARILY- TO- ISSUE PERMITS
ARE ARE OUR APPROACH IS- FULLY
IMPLEMENTING THE- LAWS IN THE
RULES ON THE BOOKS. IN A FAIR
AND THROW AWAY AND CONTINUING
TO STRENGTH AND- OUR
REGULATIONS. WELL I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT WORKING ON IT THOUGH
MAKES ME A LITTLE NERVOUS THE
PEOPLE WHO COMMITTED FIFTY
YEARS AGO TO COMPLY WITH TITLE
NINE ARE STILL WORKING ON IT
FIFTY YEARS LATER. I HOPE THAT
ISN'T THE ISSUE HAVE TO DO WITH
YOUR AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING HERE WE WERE. STILL ON
THE FLOOR UNDERSTOOD BUT- YOU
KNOW TO ME THE PROOF OF THE
PUDDING IS ALWAYS IN IN THE IN
THE EATING AND I'LL BE VERY
INTERESTED TO SEE WHAT.
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
PRONOUNCEMENTS YOU MAKE ON ON
THIS ISSUE AND PARTICULARLY.
ARE WE GONNA BUT WE CAN TRY TO
MEET THOSE- GHG REDUCTION GOALS
WE GONNA TRY TO BECOME. MORE
ENERGY INDEPENDENT. YOU KNOW I
CAN'T. SAUDI ARABIA OF PROBABLY
THE REASONS IT'S PRODUCTION IS
GONE UP OUR MULTI PURPOSE MULTI
FOLD. HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN
ONLY DO WHAT WE CAN DO BUT IF
WE ARE REALLY GOING TO MEET AND
BE SERIOUS ABOUT THOSE GOALS
WE'VE GOT TO SEE. SOME TIME
TABLES AND SOME. ACTUAL RESULTS
INTO A LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA THANK YOU
SECRETARY CROWFOOT APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND TAKE YOUR
TIME I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE
TODAY SO I'M JUST GONNA KEEP MY
REMARKS VERY VERY SHORT BUT IN
A FEW CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
REALLY ACTUALLY OVER YOUR
POLICY OVER THE LAST YOU KNOW
FEW MONTHS I WHEN I START HERE
IN TRANSITION WHEN I WHEN THAT
WHEN I HEAR THAT WORD
TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUELS
INTO A GREENER ECONOMY COMING
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY WAS OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE. WHAT I
ACTUALLY HERE IS COST OF LIVING
ISSUES AND SO WHEN I HEAR YOU
SAY MINDFUL AND TAKE TIME LIKE
I THINK THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES DON'T ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN WE AS AN
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY WHEN WE
WERE GROWING THE CROPS AND THE
FOOD THAT OUR STATE AND QUITE
FRANKLY THE COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD CONSUME. WHEN WE GO OFF
OF THE CHEAPEST FORM OF YOU
KNOW FUEL INTO ANOTHER FORM OF
TECHNOLOGY. IF THAT. HAS BECOME.
A FINE FEASIBLE AND WE'RE NOT
THERE YET. IT DOES ONE THING TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT DRIVES UP
OUR COST OF LIVING. AS I THINK
AS E HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
I MIGHT COURAGE MEANT IS THAT
WE KEEP THIS IN MIND. BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE AND THIS IS MORE
OF A STATEMENT I WOULD LOVE
YOUR I MEAN THIS PART IS THE
QUESTION. DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION- HAVE AN
APPETITE. FOR IT AND ALL THE
ABOVE TYPE OF APPROACH.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
GOALS OUT THERE THAT WE WANT TO
MEET. BUT DECIMATING THE FOSSIL
FUEL COMMUNITY MAY NOT IN ITS
ENTIRETY MAY NOT BE A GREAT
OPTION EITHER. SO DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE AN APPETITE
FOR AND ALL OF THE ABOVE TYPE
OF APPROACH. WELL FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. YOU KNOW STATE LAW
IS CLEAR THAT WE NEED. TO
REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. EIGHTY PERCENT- BY
MID CENTURY. AND I THINK. THE
GOVERNOR'S ALSO EMBRACED- THIS
TARGET OF CLIMATE NEUTRALITY IN
THAT TIME. BOB AND SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT TRANSITION WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- NON POSSIBLE-
FUEL FORMS OF ENERGY ARE
BECOMING CHEAPER THERE ARE
EXPANDING CHOICES AND THAT'S A
GOOD THING FOR OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. AT THE SAME TIME WHAT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ON IS THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT TRANSITION. IF
APPROACHED IN A IN A NON
THOUGHTFUL WAY COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND
PART OF OUR GOALS ARE OF COURSE
YEAH AS IT RELATES TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUED ECONOMIC BY A TAB
VITALITY OF COMMUNITIES. SO WE
NEED TO DO BOTH. WE NEED TO
TRANSIT TRANSITION TO A LOW
CARBON AND ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW
CARBON ECONOMY BUT IN A MANNER
ARE PARTS OF OUR STATE BEHIND.
AND THAT'S COMPLICATED AND WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS NOW
BUT I THINK IT'S AN EVOLVING
DIALOGUE- WILL HAVE. HERE IN
THE COMING FEW YEARS AROUND
WHAT WHAT- WHAT POLICIES ARE
NEEDED TO ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THROUGH ON AT TOWARD THESE
TARGETS BUT IN WAYS THAT
MINIMIZE ECONOMIC DISRUPTION IN
IMPACTS ACROSS THE STATE. NOT I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER AND I
WOULD JUST YOU KNOW AS AS
COMING FROM THE INDUSTRY YOU
KNOW WHATEVER THE INDUSTRY IN
THE JUSTICE CONTINUE ENGAGEMENT
OF INDUSTRY TO HELP THE
GOVERNOR ME HIS GOALS I THINK
IS JUST KIND OF OUR OUR PLEA
AND ALL OF THIS. IS LIKE WE
HAVE THIS COLLABORATION THIS
THIS THIS WORKING TOGETHER THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY BENEFIT YOU
KNOW. YOUR TIDES RISE ALL SHIPS.
AND I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE EXAMPLES THAT I THINK
THERE IS A PATHWAY FORWARD IF
WE'RE WILLING TO IT TO
IDENTIFIES APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
SECRETARY IN. I THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. YEAH THANK YOU AND
I'LL JUST LASTLY SAY YOU KNOW
WE WERE REALLY FOCUSED ON
MAINTAINING A DIALOGUE WITH ALL
MANNER STAKEHOLDERS SO YOU'LL
HEAR FROM A REPRESENTATIVE OF-
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
BASED. ORGANIZATION AND A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE INDUSTRY
I THINK IF YOU ASK BOTH OF
THEM- THEY'LL TELL YOU THAT
THEY HAVE AN OPEN DIALOGUE
CERTAINLY WITH OUR AGENCY AND
THE DIVISION. BECAUSE THESE ARE
COMPLICATED TOPICS WITH
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND MULTIPLE DIMENSIONS
WE JUST HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS INPUT INTO OUR
DECISION MAKING. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SECRETARY I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE TIME
TODAY YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED I'M GONNA CALL UP
OUR NEXT PANEL. WE'RE GONNA
LOOK MORE SPECIFICALLY THE
SUMMER OILFIELD SERVICE
EXPRESSIONS ON THE OIL SPILL- I
WILL ALLOW THE PANELISTS TO
COME UP AND GIVE A VERY BRIEF.
INTRODUCTIONS YOURSELF AND JUST
FOR THE BENEFIT OF TIME. IF YOU
CAN TRY TO BE AS- A- JUDICIAL
WITH YOUR COMMENTS AS POSSIBLE-
THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC WE DO
ANOTHER PANEL AFTER YOU AND
THEN PUBLIC COMMENTS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE- DAVID ISSUE
BOSNIAN DIRECTOR DOESN'T NEED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION. SUPERVISOR AND
TALK FROM THE STATE OIL AND
GAS- SUPERVISOR FOR THE PERMIT
OF CONSERVATION. THOMAS COLIN
FROM THE OFFICE OF CIVIL
PREVENTION AND RESOURCES. AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO FINISH WITH
WILLIAM A LACK OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CHEVRON. SO I WILL
ACTUALLY ALLOW THE THREE-
AGENCY OFFICIALS TO DECIDE WHAT
ORDER YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN- I
GUESS I'LL GO FIRST- I'M DAVID
CHIU BAYESIAN I'M THAT DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND- THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY. I WAS APPOINTED
DIRECTOR IN OCTOBER AND SWAP.
AND HAD A CHANCE TO MEET WITH
SOME OF YOU- EARLY EARLY ON
THIS YEAR- HAVE MORE MEETINGS
ON MY CALENDAR SO I'M REALLY
OOKING FORWARD TO LEARNING
MORE ABOUT YOUR PRIORITIES AND
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION CAN DO TO HELP-
I'M ADMITTEDLY NOT AN OIL AND
GAS EXPERT- AS SECRETARY
GRAVERT MENTIONED- MY CAREER
HAS BEEN IN IN LAND USE
PLANNING. BOTH URBAN LAND USE
PLANNING A ROLE AND USE
PLANNING. DIRECT TRYING TO COME
UP TO SPEED VERY QUICK I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT WE JUST WANT
TO CHECK TO MAKE SURE YOUR
MICROPHONE IS ON BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T SOUND I AMPLIFIED FROM
HERE THE SERGEANTS ARE CHECKING
TO MAKE SURE THE TELEVISION IS.
STOPPING OKAY MAYBE YOU CAN
JUST MOVE A LITTLE CLOSER AS
WANT TO BE SURE THE TV PICTURE
UP. THANK YOU OKAY. NO PROBLEM.
SO I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE
TOWARD COME UP TO SPEED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- WITH-
SUPERVISOR AND TAX HELP IN MY
STAFF'S HELP AS WELL AS- DOING
FIELD VISITS AND ACTUALLY GOING
OUT TO SITES THAT SIM RICK
MIDWAY SUNSET AND- SOUTH BILL
RICH FIELDS. I TO LOOK AT
OPERATIONS AND UNDERSTAND- OIL
PRODUCTION MORE INTIMATELY- I
BECAUSE INTO THE LA OFFICE NEXT
WEEK AS WELL AS THE COST OFFICE
THE WEEK AFTER THAT. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME- AS AS A
SECRETARY GRAVERT MENTIONED-
GREW UP IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ON A FARM- WE GREW CROPS TO. TO
FEED THE DAIRIES IN OUR AREA
AROUND TURLOCK- I THEN WAS ABLE
TO- GO TO UC DAVIS TO STUDY
AGRICULTURAL MANAGER LIKE AN
OMICS. AND THEN GO BACK AND
STUDY LOCAL AND REGIONAL LAND
USE PLANNING- AND THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN LAND USE
PLANNING AND TRANSPORTATION-
AND SO MY CAREER HAS BEEN
EMPHASIZING THE LAND USE
ECONOMICS- AND- AND HOW TO
LEVERAGE THOSE FOR BETTER LAND
USE PLANNING- AND IN PARTICULAR
LOOKING ON THE URBAN SIDE
REALLY FOCUSING ON WAYS TO
REDUCE V. M. T. SO SMART GROWTH
POLICIES OF GROWING UP NOT. OUT
WHICH- INCIDENTLY THAT WORK AT
AT- SECRETARY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS THAT I WAS
FORTUNATE TO WORK ON BECAME THE
UNDERPINNING OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE SO. THAT'S ON THE
URBAN SIDE ABOUT HAFWAY
THROUGH MY CAREER I WAS ABLE TO
SWITCH GEARS AND LOOK AT
PLANNING FROM THE RURAL SIDE OF
THE EQUATION. AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW TO MANAGE OUR
RESOURCES. ARE NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR RURAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PURPOSES- AND- ALSO
TO PROVIDE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
AND SOME OF THOSE IMPORTANT
ONES THAT WERE ALREADY
MENTIONED TODAY- GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE AND CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IN PARTICULAR- SO
I REALLY HAD A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY OF. OF CONNECTING
URBAN AND RURAL- THROUGH-
THROUGH. HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- TO PROMOTE MORE OF A
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO PLANNING OUR
FUTURE- SO. LOOKING AT MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT LAND
USE PATTERNS- PROVIDING- THAT
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE NEED BUT
BALANCING THAT WITH THE
CONSERVATION OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES GOING FORWARD- AND
REALLY TO TRY TO AND. OF THE
ECONOMIC AND- OUT FOR ALL OF US.
SO WHY MY STE A LOT WITH DEPART.
PROGRAM ARE TO PLANNING FOR AN
INVESTING IN WORKING- LANDS I
AM COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
CAL JAM. IS SUCCESSFUL IN
IMPLEMENTING ITS REGULATIONS-
JUST TAKING A QUICK NOTE THAT
WHEN DOCTOR WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN. ARE THE
INITIAL FOCUS WAS ON THE
RELIABILITY OF HYDROCARBON
RECOVERY OBVIOUSLY THAT HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY AND WE ARE
NOW IF THE SIZING THE
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SAFETY AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
SUPERVISOR AND TOOK- TO HELP
HIM WITH A FURTHER IN THAT THE
PROGRESS OF THAT THAT CHANGE A
IN CAL JAM. AND SO TO MAKE
SURE. THAT HE HAS SUFFICIENT
AND WELL TRAINED STAFF WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR MORE POSITIONS A
CAL JAM. I TO CARRY OUT OUR NEW
MANDATES INCLUDING FEEL
INSPECTIONS THOROUGH PERMIT
REVIEW ENFORCEMENT DATA
MANAGEMENT AND CRITICAL HUMAN
RESOURCES TO ENSURE WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH. SAFETY
AND THE ENVIRONMENT SO I'M
GOING TO. STOP THERE SO THAT
SUPERVISOR IN TECH HAS TIME I
KNOW THAT WE'RE WE'RE RUNNING
SHORT SO I WILL JUST POTS WITH
MY COMMENTS THERE BUT I'M GLAD
TO TAKE QUESTIONS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU THINK THERE'S ANY
NEVER HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR
THE SECRETARY. NO OKAY. GET OUT
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
WOULD WALK JOE AND TOOK I'M THE
NEW STATE WILLING GAS
SUPERVISOR- OFFICIALLY THE LAST
DOG OR SUPERVISOR AND THE FIRST
CAL JIM SUPERVISOR IN THE LAST
TWO MONTHS- THE PLEASURE O BE
HERE- I BRING A UNIQUE
BACKGROUND BOTH INDUSTRY AND
GOVERNMENT- IN MY MASTER'S
DEGREE IN PETROLEUM
ENGINEERING- IT WITH THE
EMPHASIS IN SMART OIL FIELD
OPERATIONS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I ALSO
SERVED AS A FACULTY MEMBER IN
THE CHEMICAL ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENT AT LONG BEACH STATE
WHERE I DID MY UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE- AND I'M ALSO PROUD
PRODUCT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. I
STARTED MY CAREER AS A
PRODUCTION IN RESERVOIR
ENGINEERING THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY- BEFORE MOVING THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH ABOUT A DECADE AGO
MOST RECENT RECENTLY I SERVE AT
THE PATROLLING ADMINISTRATOR
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
RIGHT NOW YOU THE CHALLENGES
PRODUCING OIL GAS AND HIGHLY
URBANIZED AREAS UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITIES- THAT- OF QUITTING
BRIDGES AND SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC CONCERNS AND
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
ENVIRONMENTS HUNTER AND BEAU SO
IF CARDS. AND ENERGY NEEDS ARE
MET ADDITION I WAS TRAINED BY
VICE PRESIDENT AL GORE CLIMATE
SCIENCE AS PART OF THE ALLIANCE
FOR CLIMATE PROTECTION- I'M A
FORMER GREEN FOR ALL FOLLOW
WHERE I WORKED ON PROJECTS TO
BUILD AN INCLUSIVE GREEN
ECONOMY THE LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY- IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OR TRAVEL TO- BANGLORE
INDIA WITH THE C. FORTY ANA
INTERNATIONAL AIR QUALITY
SUMMIT. AT THE US. A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT. TO THE SEE FOR
CITY CLIMATE LEADERSHIP THAT'S
A GROUP OF NINETY CITIES FROM
AROUND THE WORLD THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON TACKLING CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND DELIVERING THE MOST
AMBITIOUS GOALS AND THE PARIS
AGREEMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. I
DO HAVE A FEW SLIDES I'LL BE
CLICKING THROUGH. AS HEAD OF
THE CAL JIM NOW I'M COMMITTED
TO CELEBRATING DEEPENING THE
REFORM EFFORTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN UNDER WAY WE ARE
FOCUSED ON STRENGTHENING OUR
REGULATORY PROGRAMS EMPHASIZING
COMPLIANCE AND SAFEGUARDING
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THROUGH FIELD
INSPECTIONS ENFORCEMENT. AND AT
THE STATE OIL GAS A PRODUCTIONS
BEEN CRYING BY NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OVER THE LAST THIRTY
FIVE YEARS WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THE OPERATOR TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SAFELY DE
COMMISSIONING- WELLS AND
ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE. OF
THE CHAIRS OF TASTE LETTER TO
US THAT TODAY ASKED THREE
SPECIFIC THINGS- ONE WHAT ARE
THE CONCRETE ACTIONS TAKEN OUT
AND PUT THE NEW INITIATIVES
FROM THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION. A TO THE ACTION
RESPONDING TO THE CEMEX
EMMERICH OIL FIELDS BUILT
ANOTHER SURFACE EXPRESSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIRDLY
THE STATUS OF THE REFORMS- AND
OPERATIONS DIVISION TO
UNDERGROUND JACKSON TO CONTROL
YOU I SEE A JACKSON PROGRAM
INITIALLY STAFF- SUGGESTED THAT
I START OFF BUT PROVIDER
PRIMER. ON CYCLIC STEAM
ENHANCE- RECOVERY METHODS AND
SURFACE EXPRESSIONS OF THE
SLIDE UP THERE DOES HAVE OUR
PRIORITIES IN AND TALKS THROUGH
A SOME OF OUR BACKGROUND. BUT
I'LL GO INTO A CYCLIC STEAM-
THERE. WHAT THIS IS THE THERE'S
THREE PARTS OF THE SLIDE THIS
IS ONE WHILE AND DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS CYCLIST IMAGE ACTION
THE THERMAL ENHANCE OVER COVER
METHOD. ARE REGULATIONS DEFINE
CYCLIC STEAM IS INJECTION WELL
ONE INJECTION WELL HEN INJECTS
STEAM INTO AN UNDERGROUND
FORMATION. AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY PRODUCES
HYDROCARBONS BOB SO. THE FIRST
STEP OF STEVEN. THE SET THERE
IS. THE IT IS PRINT FROM THE
SAME WELL YOUNG THERE'S A PUMP
UNIT AT THE SIR THIS IS A AND
PROCESS THE THEY GO SO THE
THREE OF THE FACT SEEM JACKSON
THREE STAGES FIRST STAGE
INJECTION STEAM INTO THE WELL
BORE A DURING WHICH TIME OF THE
RESERVOIR AND HEAT TRANSFER
BEGINS THE SECOND STAGE IS A
SOAK PHASE REQUIRES A WILL BE
SHUT DOWN FOR SEVERAL DAYS
HELLO UNIFORM HE TRANSFUSION.
THROUGHOUT THE OR OIL BEARING
ZONE FINALLY THE THIRD STAGE
THE HEATING OIL AND WATER IS
PRODUCED TO THE SURFACE THROUGH
THE SAME WELL BORE OF THE CYCLE
IS REPEATED OVER AND OVER YEAR
AFTER YEAR UNTIL THE NEEDS THE
MAINTENANCE OR IT'S TIME TO
REQUIRE THE WELL TO BE
ABANDONED. SERVICE EXPRESSIONS
THIS. BUS WIDER FROM THE
MIDWEST SUNSET FIELD THIS AND
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A HIGH
ENERGY INDUCED SURFACE
EXPRESSION- YOU CAN SEE OUR OUR
FORMAL DEFINITION OF CERTAIN
SPECIAL THERE BUT IT'S
BASICALLY A SURFACE EXPRESSION
IS A FORM OF THE OIL SPILL THAT
OCCURS WHEN ALL THE WATER COMES
TO THE SURFACE OF THE EARTH
OUTSIDE THE OIL AND GAS WELL
STEEL AND CEMENT LINED CASING.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THERE BOTH
NATURALLY OCCURRING AND HIGH
ENERGY OR OPERATIONALLY INDUCED
SURFACE EXPRESSIONS THE
OPERATIONAL SURFACE EXPRESSIONS
THAT WE REGULATE ARE ALWAYS
ASSOCIATED WITH HIGH PRESSURE
INJECTION OF STEAM INTO SHALLOW
OIL BEARING FORMATIONS RECENT
REGULATIONS GOVERNING YOU I
SEE- THAT WERE INITIATED BY
DOCTOR AND BECAME EFFECTIVE
APRIL FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- PROHIBIT LEE- BAND
SURF EXPRESSIONS FROM
OCCURRING. WAS PROCESS BEEN
OCCURRING FOR DECADES SECOND
STEAM OPERATIONS AT SURFERS
EXPRESSIONS CAME INTO UNIQUE
FOCUS IN THE PAST TEN YEARS- IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WEEKS
CHRISTMAS WOULD- DAVID TAYLOR
AND ALSO WORKER WHO ACTUALLY
KILLED WHILE INVESTIGATING
SURFACE SUPPRESSION AT THE MINT
SUNSET FIELD. THANKS THIS
BROUGHT INCREASED FOCUS IN THE
DIVISION TO THIS ISSUE EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
FOR DECADES- BEFORE PRIOR TO
THE NEW REGULATIONS TAKING
EFFECT THE DIVISION RELIED ON
SPECIFIC AND DIVIDE INDIVIDUAL
UP PERMIT CONDITIONS INTENT TO
ENSURE THE OPERATOR SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PREVENT SURFACE
EXPRESSIONS. THESE CONDITIONS
WERE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING THE
NUMBER EXPRESSIONS BUT THEY
WERE NOT DONE UNIFORMLY. OR
SYSTEMATICALLY. REGULAR
REGULATORY PROHIBIT PROHIBITION.
MAKES A VERY PRESS OF SURF
EXPRESS OF BY. OF REGULATE AT
THE- OF OIL AND GAS SUPERVISOR
ISSUE CIVIL PENALTIES. EVENTS
OVER THE PAST SUMMER CLEARLY
INDICATE THE MORE VALUATION OF
HEADS OVER COVER POLICIES
NECESSARY. WE DO HAVE HERE
OSCAR MISTER THOMAS CALLING
WITH US GOOGLE GREATER DETAILS
ABOUT THE INCIDENT TIME ON ITS
PROFITS FROM ALL SPUR. BUT I
LIKE TO WALK YOU THROUGH A FEW
SLIDES A GENERATED THE MOST
ATTENTION. THIS. IS THE SUM
WORKING ONE WHY- SURFACE
SUPPRESSION AREA- THIS IS A
CLUSTER SERVICE PRESS AT THE
SUMMER OIL FEEL CALLED ONE WHY.
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE THE LARGE
VISIBLE FLOW. INTO A DRY
STREAMBED- THAT EXPRESS WAS
INITIALLY REPORTED BY CHEVRON
TO CAL- YES ON MAY TENTH AS A
ONE DAY EVENT- THAT WAS
RECOVERED ABOUT A HUNDRED FIVE
BARRELS. OF WATER AND OIL.
SUBSEQUENTLY WAS REACTIVATED
AGAIN ON JUNE EIGHTH JUNE
EIGHTEENTH ANNA NEARBY EVENT ON
JUNE TWENTY THIRD. THE RELEASE
IS AFFECTED DRY SEASONAL STREAM
BEDS- BUT WERE CONTAINED IN THE
AREA WAS CLEANED THIS IS A
TIMELINE OF EVENTS. ALL THOSE
EVENTS THAT HAD BECOME ACTIVE
SINCE AUGUST FIRST- AND THE
CLEANUP OF THE SITE FOR
COMPLETED ON OCTOBER ELEVENTH.
THE TOTAL RECOVERED VOLUME OF
FLUID WAS THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN OR NINETY EIGHT BARRELS
OF WATER AND OIL- THAT WE SENT
A LETTER TO CHEVRON IN
SEPTEMBER. TENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. QUESTION EXTENSIVE
pTECHNICAL REPORTS AND DATA
RELATED TO CYCLE STEAM
OPERATION THAT THE ENTIRE STE
SOME RECOIL FEEL. OTHER PURPOSE
THAT LETTER WAS ENABLE CAL JIM
AND THE NATIONAL LABS TO
CONDUCT A FULL ASSESSMENT OF
THE FIELDS TO GAIN A HOLISTIC
VIEW AND UNDERSTANDING THE
CAUSES THESE MULTIPLE SURFACE
EXPRESSION. AND MINORITY MISTER
BRAZIER BUT I JUST. IT'S IT IS
JULY TWENTY SECOND IS THAT
THAT'S ACCURATE. HE SAID IT'S
NOT JUNE TWENTY SECOND. THAT
THE FIRST BULLET. SO IT'S JULY
ST THE UNIFIED COMMAND CAME
AFTER THE ORDER. WELL I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT YES SO THE
UNIFIED COMMAND IF THAT'S COOL
CREEK JULY TWENTY SECOND. AFTER
THE ORDER REFORMER MEDIA WORK
AT ONE ONE. WHICH IS A CLEAR IN
OUR TIMELY THE JULY ELEVENTH
THE JULY TWELFTH THE ORDER TO
REFORM THE REMEDIAL WORK
PRECEDED THE UNIFIED COMMAND
ESTABLISHMENT YES WE KNEW WE
KNEW ABOUT AND ACTIONS BEING
TAKEN BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE A
UNIFIED COMMAND ESTABLISHED
BEFORE THAT. THE IT WAS SO THAT
THE RESPOND AT THE GUN IT HAD
BEGUN BUT THAT THAT'S AN
ACCURATE TIME LINE OKAY IT'S
JUST IT'S YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT
TO ORDER MEANS- IF I COMMANDER
IF I COMMANDER THEY DIDN'T. GO
HAND IN HAND BUT THAT BUT THAT
WAS ARE AT THE RIGHT TIME. YEAH
SO GOT AND NOT TO SO ASYLUM
JUMP PM SO OCTOBER SECOND
TWENTY NINETEEN CAL JIM ORDERED
CHAIRMAN TO PAY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN CIVIL
PENALTIES CHAMBER HAS APPEAL
THE OF THAT ORDER- OR THE CIVIL
PENALTIES AND IS BEING HEARD BY
THE MINISTRY OF LAW JUDGE AT
THE OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS BUT NO RESOLUTIONS
BEEN MADE YET- IF I CAN MANIMAL
RIGHT OTHER REGULATORY AGENCIES
REFORM TO CONTAIN THE SPILL
ASSURING HUMAN HEALTH- Y. LAS
SAFETY AND CONDUCT CLEANUP. AND
THIS NEXT. YOU CAN SEE. SOME OF
THE- ACTIONS WERE TAKEN WITH
THIS IS AFTERWARDS AND OF THE
CLEAN UP- BUT THE OIL
CONTAINMENT SO WAS REMOVED AND
AKEN TO HOUSES WASTE FACILITY-
STILL POSE A SIGNIFICANT FIRST
SAFETY HAZARD TO WORKERS
CLEANING UP THE SITE FOR HELP
PER COW CHEN REGULATIONS A
PROFESSION ENGINEER WAS
REQUIRED TO EVALUATE AND
APPROVE STRUCTURAL GROUND
STABILITY BEFORE WORKERS COULD
ENTER- THE CLEANUP AREA EACH
WORKER HAD- HARNESSES WITH
ROPES ATTACHED SPECIAL
PROTECTIVE. EQUIPMENT IN CASE
OF EMERGENCY EVACUATIONS THERE
WAS HEAVY EQUIPMENT THAT MAJOR
ASSAULT COMPACTION- WAS SOLID
BEFORE PEOPLE WALKED ON ROUTE
SO THAT NO ONE WOULD FALL IN-
SO THERE WAS A NUMBER AREAS BUT
THERE THE- ACTION TAKEN TO MAKE
SURE THE SITE WAS SAFE
THROUGHOUT THE CLEANUP PROCESS.
IN THAT RECENTLY. IT IS THIS
AFTERWARDS- NOW IT'S OPPOSE
CLEAN UP WE'VE GONE THROUGH AND
ON OUR WEBSITE HAVE PUT- MAPS-
INTERACTIVE MAP LISTING OF ALL
SURFER DISCRETION SO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- THERE WAS
OTHER SURFACE PRESSON MIDWAY
SENSE TO ADVOCATE TRICK OF FOR
ADDED MEASURE OF TRANSPARENCY-
THERE'S DETAIL INFORMATION
ABOUT THESE BILLS ARE WEBSITE
IN AN ACT AMOUNTS FOR TRACKING-
THE YOU CAN SEE HERE TO G. I.
S. THAT IT HAS THE CLUSTERS OF
THE DIFFERENT- SURFACE
EXPRESSIONS FIELD OPERATOR
LOCATIONS DATES ARE ALL ON OUR
WEBSITE NOW. AND ALONG WITH A
LIST OF ORDERS OF VIOLATIONS
THAT WERE ISSUED. A SERVICE
EXPRESSES CONTINUE POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO HUMAN
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENT THEY'RE
DANGEROUS AND UNPREDICTABLE-
THE QUARTERLY CAL JIM- COURTLY
COUNTERS PLACED A MORATORIUM ON
APPROVING HIGH. PRESSURE A
SECOND SEEM OPERATIONS BEEN
REVIEW OF THE PRACTICE INCOMES
IN CONSULTATION WITH EXPERT TO
THE MARCH LIVERMORE NATIONAL
LAB. UNTIL CAL JIM IN
CONSULTATION NATIONAL LAB THAT
HAS DETERMINED. THE PROJECT
USING CYCLIST INJECTION ABOVE
FRACTURE PRESSURE CAN BE
IMPLEMENT SAFETY SAFELY NEW
PROPOSED PROJECTS USING THIS
PRACTICE WILL NOT BE APPROVED.
I'M MORE TORN REPLIES NEW
PROJECTS AND WELLS THAT INJECTS
STEAM UNDERGROUND AT OR ABOVE
FRACTURE PRESSURE. WELL
SPECIFIC CAUSES. A JEEP C. TO
SERVE EXPRESSION STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION. INJECTION A HIGH
PRESSURE IS CORRELATED WITH
SURFER EXPRESSIONS OBSERVE THE
SUMMER AND FALL AND SOME WORK
IN THE MIDWAY SUNSET FIELDS.
THIS MORE TORRENT DOES NOT
AFFECT PROPOSED PROJECT THE U.
CYCLIC STEAM AT PRESSURES THAT
ARE DEMONSTRATED IN ACCORDANCE
REGULATIONS TO TAKE PLACE BELOW
THE FRACTURE PRESSURE. THESE
OPERATIONS ARE NEEDED TO
MAINTAIN RESERVOIR PRESSURE TO
PREVENT NEW SURFACE EXPRESSIONS
FROM HAPPENING AND ALSO TO
PREVENT SERVICE LEVEL
SUBSIDENCE FROM OCCURRING.
DURING THE MOM MORE TORRENT CAL
GYMNASTS ALLOWS WILL REVIEW THE
PRACTICE OF HIGH PRESSURE CYCLE
STEAM OPERATIONS. ABOUT FRAC
PRESSURE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
CAN BE PERFORMED SAFELY AND IF
SO TO IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
CRITERIA TO COMPLY WITH RECENT
REGULATIONS. OTHER THREE REVIEW
MAY RESULT A NEW SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS REFLECT THE SAME
ABOUT FRACTURE UPGRADED
REGULATIONS. OR INDEFINITE HALT
TO THE PRACTICE. AS OF THE
REVIEW CAL JIM NATIONAL LOOKING
TO EVALUATE. UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS AT MIDWAY SUNSET
FIELDS WERE SERVICE PRESS HAVE
OCCURRED. THIS REVIEW WILL
EXAMINE RECORDS AND PHYSICAL
CONDITIONS EACH OIL FIELD- WERE
SECOND STEAM ABOUT FRAC. HAS
CAPEN. WITHOUT AND THEY ALSO
LOOK WHERE IT HAS NOT HAPPENED
A WHERE THEY HAVE A CYCLIC
STEAM ABOVE. THIS BROAD
ASSESSMENT CAN HELP TO
DETERMINE WHAT WEATHER
GEOLOGICAL AND ENGINEERING.
CONDITIONS EXIST WITH A
PRACTICE CAN BE CONDUCTED
SAFELY IN FULL COMPLIANCE OF
CAL JIM'S REGULATIONS ONCE THAT
REVIEWS COMPLETE I'M GOING TO
LAW. YOU'RE DOING FINE ALL
RIGHT WE ALREADY HAVE QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT. I DON'T I WILL WAS
THEIR- THEIR WRAP UP WHEN YOU
LIKE AND WE CAN WE CAN DIG IN
FURTHER CENTRO SO THAT SOME OF
IT IS THE ANSWER TO SOME OF THE
QUESTION GET READY THE RELEASE
CAME UP. YEAH ONCE READ
COMPLETE CALTRAIN WILL USE THE
FINES AND- PUBLICLY THE DISPLAY
THE SPOT THE FINE. OF FORM.
CONSIDERATION OF NEW MP PERM
APPLICATIONS. IF CAL JIM. LAB
THE TERM OF THE PRICE COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY. IN
CERTAIN LOCATIONS- UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS THEN YOU
PERMITS FOR OPERATING-
OPERATIONS MEANING THESE
CORRECT HERE WILL BE CLEARED
FOR THE PRACTICE. AND MONITOR
WHAT NEW PROPOSED PERMIT FOR
THIS PRACTICE IN OTHER
LOCATIONS MAY REMAIN UNDER
REVIEW AND HALTED- I THINK IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURING
THE OIL PRODUCTION IS CONDUCTED
AT. AS SAFELY AS POSSIBLE- AND
BUT WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO- AS
FAR AS YOU I SEE. YES WE DID
RELEASE A- SERIES OF REPORTS
PRIOR TO THE HEARING- WE DID-
APPROXIMATELY SIX REPORTS OUT
LAST WEEK- YOUR INVITATION
LETTER. REQUESTED DISCUSSION
REFORM UNDERGROUND. REFORMS
UNDERGROUND JACKSON CONTROL
PROGRAM YOU I SEE WE RECENTLY
PROVIDE LEGISLATURE WITH SB
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE REPORT.
PROVIDE A SERIES OF INDICATORS
ON PROGRESS TOWARD USC
IMPROVEMENT. THE BIGGEST RECENT
CHANGE. USE THAT I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED THE OVERHAUL THE U.
I. C. REGULATIONS. THAT TOOK
EFFECT THIS PAST APRIL. THE
REGULATIONS MODERNIZE CLARIFY
AND AUGMENT THE RIVER THE
EXISTING REGULATORY STANDARDS
FOR YOU I SEE OPERATIONS. OF
SECULAR THESE PROVISIONS
INCLUDE RICK RIGOROUS
MECHANICAL INTEGRITY TESTING TO
ENSURE WELLS ARE SAFE AND DO
NOT LEAK. APPROVED OVERSIGHT OF
OPERATION CONDITIONS AN
INJECTION PRESSURES. REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF PROTECTION
AND WELL DESIGNED. MORE
TRANSPARENCY ANALYSIS OF FLUIDS
FLUIDS RESERVOIRS. AND
CHEMICALS USED. A COMPREHENSIVE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SEARCH
EXPRESSIONS. OCCURRENCES OR
ABSENT AND PRIOR REGULATIONS.
OTHER BIG CHALLENGE IS AFFECTED
THE- EXECUTING IMPLEMENTING
THESE NEW REGULATIONS. AND
STATUTORY MANDATES YOU ACTUALLY
RETROACTIVE INCLUDES A NEW
PROJECT MODIFICATIONS AND
PROJECT BY PROJECT REVIEWS. A
PROTECTING GROUNDWATER FROM OIL
AND GAS ACTIVITIES WHEN CAL JOB
MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE STATE YOU
I SEE PROGRAM OF THE VEHICLE
FOR MANAGING THIS. REVIEW WITH
EXISTING PROJECTS IT'S CRITICAL
TO ENSURING THE PROJECT COMPLY.
WITH THE PROVISION OF AN
REGULATE THE- IN. ARE
TECHNICALLY INTENSIVE TANK
INCOME THEY ALSO REQUIRE
EXTENSIVE CONSULTATION WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
BOARD PURSUANT TO OUR ENERGY TO
SEE A MOVIE YOU. OF THE SIDES
SLIDES IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
RELEASE REPORTS I WON'T REPEAT
EVEN FOR TIME BUT THEY'RE
LISTED THERE. AS DIRECTOR
SHOULD BASIN MENTIONED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL- THE REASON B. C. P.
THAT WE RELEASE AS PART OF THE
BUDGET INCLUDES A WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS THAT WE'RE FALLING
BEHIND IN A FEW AREAS. A CAL
JIM STAFF ARE STRUGGLING TO
MEET THESE MANDATES AND WE DO
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- AFTER
EFFECTIVE IN SB FOURTEEN NINETY
THREE REPORT BOTH PROJECT BY
PROJECT REVIEWS AN AQUIFER
EXEMPTIONS. IMPORTANT PARTS OF
MEDIAN OUR COMPLIANCE
OBLIGATIONS HAVE- TAKEN LONGER
THAN INITIALLY TO INTENT AND
ANTICIPATED. I'M COMMITTED TO
SEE CITY OF MORE. AGGRESSIVE
PACE AND PARTS WERE PURSUING
CONTINUAL IMPROVEMENT OF THE U.
S. C. PROGRAM. AS PRODUCTION
DECLINED CALIFORNIA'S NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE OPERATION
INCREASINGLY RELIANT ON
ENHANCE- RECOVERY PROJECT
REGULATED BY YOU I SEE
REGULATIONS- WE WILL CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON ENSURING COMPLIANCE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
REGULATIONS WHILE INCREASING
OUR HEALTH SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFORTS. HERE IN
A NEW ERA CAL JIM ORGIES IS NOW
GOING THROUGH A TRANSFORMATION
TO ALIGN OUR REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT WAS STATES CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
ON CONTINUE I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THESE REFORMS OF THE
WORKSTATION AND PEAK OF BEING
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO ME OUR
ENERGY NEEDS- I WELCOME.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. AND
COMMON IN. THE FLOOR. WOW ROTH
WE'RE GONNA QUESTIONS AFTER
EVERYBODY ON BOTH SPEAKS MR
CALL I BELIEVE I'M. GOOD
EVENING MATTER FAIR. MR CULTURE
MONEY ON TOM CALLING APPOINTED
UP TO THE TWELVE BY GOVERNOR.
AS EVEN F THE OFFICE OF SPELL
PREVENT SPOT RESPONSE AND CAL
APARTMENT WILDLIFE BEFORE THAT
I HAD A THIRTY ONE YEAR CAREER
IN THE UNITED STATES COAST
COVER MY LAST ASSIGNMENT SCORES
CHIEF OF RESPONSE FOR THE
ELEVENTH COAST GUARD DISTRICT
WHICH IS ALL OF CALIFORNIA THE
ASSOCIATED FEDERAL WATERS. SO
THERE WE GO. I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY REGARDING
A RESPONSE THE SEVERANCE AND
RICK SERVICE EXPRESSION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S OFFICE BILL
PREVENTION RESPONSE ROSTER WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN. OKAY
UP. CAN ANYONE FOLLOWING THE
EXXON VALDEZ AMERICAN TRAITOR
MAJOR OIL TANKER SPILLS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL
WATERS AND ASSOCIATE NATURAL
RESOURCES FROM THE EFFECTS OF
SIMILAR SPILLS THROUGH ROBUST
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM OF
PREVENTION PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
IN THE LEGISLATURE EXPANDED
OSCARS PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PROTECT ALL
STATE SURFACE WATERS COASTAL
AND INLAND INCLUDING SEASONAL
OR EPHEMERAL DRY WASHES. OSCAR
RECEIVES MORE THAN SEVEN
THOUSAND REPORTS OF OIL SPILLS
EACH YEAR AND DISPATCHES
MEMBERS OF OUR FIELD RESPONSE
TEAMS WHICH INCLUDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILDLIFE OFFICERS
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS AN OIL
SPILL PREVENTION SPECIALS TO
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED STILL
SITES PER YEAR. ONE MAY TENTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN CALLOW
YES NOTIFIED US FOR THIS BILL
RESULTING FROM THE SURFACE
EXPRESSION IN THE IMMEDIATE
VICINITY OF. TRUMP PRODUCTION
WELL ONE WHY IN SOME RECOIL
FIELD IN THE TOWN OF MCKITTRICK
POSSIBLY THIRTY FIVE MILES WEST
OF BAKERSFIELD MR CALL I'M NOT
BE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN BUZZING
UP HERE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SLIDE. SO IT BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S GONNA BE QUESTIONS I'M
JUST GONNA STOP YOU WHILE IT'S
THERE ABSOLUTELY THERE'S NO
NUMBERS ON THERE THAT WE CAN
READ. CAN YOU PUT THIS IN A
LITTLE CONTEXT BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS SO WHEN YOU SAY
SEVEN HOW MANY SPELLS DID YOU
SAY YOUR PROXY SEVEN THOUSAND
PORTS A YEAR SO THIS IS A-
THREE YEAR PERIOD ACTIVE. YEP
TWO THOUSAND TEAM TO STOP TWO
THOUSAND. IS THE LEGEND OF
THESE OF. THAT CAME INTO THE
ABA A WARNING CENTER CALLAWAY
THAT THE SEVEN DOLLARS YOU'RE
THIS REP ABOUT TWENTY ONE. YES
MA'AM BILLS IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS AND CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
CONTACTS AS TO SIZE WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THE
REQUIREMENT TO REPORT IS ANY
OIL TO WATER SO WE DO GET
REPORTS ESPECIALLY THE MARITIME
COMMITTEE WHICH IS. MORE STATUS
NOW IN FAMILIAR WITH OUR-
REQUIREMENTS DROPS INDIVIDUAL
DROPS AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
MIGHT NOT SEND A TEAM TO THE
SCENE OF A DROP AND WE WERE NOT
GONNA FIND ANYTHING SO JUST SO
THAT WOULD TOTAL. CONTACTS YES.
WHAT'S THE RIGHT I SO I WITH
THE BOTTOM RANGE YOU GOT THE
DROPS OF WATER. THE RANGE
WHAT'S COME OF AB. OF WHAT
SEEING IN THE CPO. PROBABLY
BETWEEN TEN. AND HUNDRED. WITH
BE THE AVERAGE. MOST OF THE
REPORTS ARE ON A TANKER TRUCK.
INCENSE ON HIGHER AND ASK. ON
WE ALSO HAVE PROBLEM A BIT INTO.
FEST ARE WHAT. ON THAT MIGHT
MAKE ST OR WITH. TITLE A START
BREAK OPEN THAT AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE ALL. SO HOW MUCH OF THIS
IS YOUR DOT. INTO RELATED THAN.
A FOR. COMP MAN TRIED I'D HAVE
TO GIVE A ON. APPROXIMATE I
IT'S A OF FAIRLY LOW NUMBER
COULD. TO A LOT LOT OF THE
ROUTE. THAT WE GET. OTHERS ALL
RULES THAT WILL ALLOW. INDUSTRY
TO WHEN WE CALLED FIELD WILL.
ON THE IF IT'S WITHIN CAN. THEY
HAVE TO. IF IT'S I BELIEVE FIVE
TWO TWENTY. OR THERE'S MORE
THAN THAT IS YOU ON HERE. OUR
NUMBER COULD BE. RIGHT OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. ALI
SO WHERE WAS I WAS SO BACK TO.
INITIAL POOR OF A THIS DECEMBER
WILL HEARD WE INITIALLY.
BARRELS OR ABOUT. HUNDRED OF A
MIXTURE OF CRUDE OIL AND OPERA.
WA OSCAR DE. RESPOND SMARTBAY.
FIELD OFFICE TO THE SITE AND
THEY RE. GAVE WITH SEVERAL. DOG
AT THE TIME AND CLEAN UP CON.
IN THE US. MONTHS. THERE WAS NO
STANDING OR FOR WATER WITHIN.
AN I'M SORRY I NEVER YOU ALSO
TIME LINE ON THAT. IF YOU GIVE
US THE IN DATE TO WE GO HERE
INITIAL. SAYS WITH A MAKE. I
WATCH AS YOU USE ON THE CLEAN A
PICTURE. RESTATING THERE'S NO
STANDING WATER OR FLOWING WATER
WITHIN MILES OF THE SPILL AND
ALTHOUGH WAS IN THE VICINITY OF
ENDANGERED AND OTHER SPECIES
HABITATS THERE WERE AT THE TIME
NO OBSERVE WILDLIFE IMPACTS
NEVERTHELESS WHILE IF AVOIDANCE
MEASURES WERE PUT INTO PLACE
AND AS A RESULT OF OSCARS
INITIAL EVALUATION OF POTENTIAL
A WILDLIFE RISKS. THERE WAS NO
DANGER TO THE PUBLIC OR OTHER
STATE WATERS. THE SITE WAS
CHALLENGING GIVING SERVICE
EXPRESSION SOMETIMES ASSOCIATED
WITH VERY UNSTABLE SURROUNDING
TERRAIN INCLUDING SINKHOLES THE
PERCENT OF POTENTIALLY LIFE
THREATENING RISK. CONSEQUENTLY
A SAFETY BUFFER WAS ESTABLISHED
AROUND THE EXPRESSION THE
PROHIBITED PERSONNEL FROM
ACCESSING THIS BILL AREA.
ADDITIONALLY THERE WAS ALWAYS
THE THREAT OF EXPOSURE TO
EXTREMELY TOXIC HYDROGEN
SULFIDE GAS. ON JULY TWELFTH
KQED PUBLISHED IN THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS PICKED UP A
STORY OF THE SENATE SPILL
REPORTING EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLONS SPILLED OVER
TWO MONTHS. THIS UNDERSTANDABLY
TRIGGERED A BARRAGE OF INCREASE
FOR THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE OTHER MEDIA AND
STAKEHOLDERS. AROUND THE SAME
TIME THIS BILL WAS DEEMED SAFE
ENOUGH TO COMMENCE SPILL
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES AND OFFER
DOGGER ESTABLISHED A FORMAL
UNIFIED COMMAND WE HAVE BEEN
RESPONDING AT THIS POINT SIR
BUT NOW WE FORMALIZE IT MORE
THROUGH THE ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF
INTEREST. IN ADDITION TO
DIRECTING RESPONSE ACT ACT
ACTIONS. THE UNIFIED COMMAND
ESTABLISHED A REGULAR REPORTING
OF RESPONSE UPDATES TO THE
PRESS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SECRETARY
CROWFOOT AND MANY OTHERS VISIT
THE SITE AND SAW FIRST HAND THE
EFFORTS AND CHALLENGES OF THIS
RECOVERY OPERATION. AS PER
RESPONSE PROTOCOLS OSCAR WAS
THE STATE ON SCENE COORDINATOR
TOGETHER WITH DAUGHTER AND
PARTICIPATED IN LIAISON AND
JOINT INFORMATION CENTER
ACTIONS. OSCAR LED THE
ENVIRONMENTAL UNIT WHICH ADVICE
THE UNIFIED COMMAND REGARDING
ALL ENVIRONMENTAL MATTERS
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
MONITORING AND IT'S AN
ASSESSMENT WASTE STREAM
MANAGEMENT AND CLEANUP
STRATEGIES AND POINTS. OFFER
ALSO LET A WILDLIFE FRANCE TO
MINIMIZE AND RESPOND TO
WILDLIFE IMPACTS. WELL IF OF
ONCE MEASURES INCLUDING HAZING
SPECIFICALLY NOISE PRODUCING
ZAHN GUNS AND HIGH INTENSITY
LIGHTS. AS WELL AS EXCLUSIONARY
FENCING TO PREVENT WILDLIFE
FROM GETTING INTO THE OIL AREA.
FULL TIME BIOLOGICAL MONITORING
WAS CONDUCTED DURING THE
DAYLIGHT AND AS MANY AS
NINETEEN TRAIL CAMERAS WERE
EMPLOYED AT NIGHT TO MONITOR
NON TERM. I'M SORRY NOCTURNAL
SPECIES. THREE OIL BARN OWLS
AND ONE OIL LESSER NIGHTHAWKS
WERE CONFIRMED KILLED BY THIS
BILL. ADDITIONALLY ONE WORLD
RAVEN AND ONE OIL COTTONTAIL
RABBIT WERE CAPTURED CLEANED
AND RELEASED. HOWEVER
ANALYTICAL FUEL FOR
FINGERPRINTING DID NOT CONFIRM
THAT THE OIL IN THESE ANIMALS
WAS FROM SOME RECORD WHY.
DURING THE RESPONSE THROWN OVER
FLIGHTS RECORDED THE TRACKS OF
ONE MEDIUM SIZE MAMMAL THAT HAD
CROSSED TO THE OIL AT NIGHT BUT
THAT AND THE ANIMALS NEVER
DIRECTLY OBSERVED. ON OCTOBER
NINTH CONTRACTORS ACHIEVED
CLEAN UP AND POINTS AND THE
UNIFIED COMMAND WAS TO
ESTABLISHED SUBJECT TO
IMMEDIATE REACTIVATION IF
NEEDED. IN THE SUBSEQUENT
MONTHS THROUGH PRESENT THERE
HAVE BEEN SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
EXPRESSIONS FROM ONE WHY AND
OTHER NEARBY WELLS AN OSCAR HAS
ALWAYS RESPONDED TO VERIFY
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
AND WILDLIFE RECONNAISSANCE AND
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. OSCAR
CONTINUES TO FORGE STRONGER
PARTNERSHIP WITH A CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
ISN'T. AS WELL AS OTHER STATE
FOR ANNA INLAND REGULATORS LIKE
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL FOR
PIPELINES AND PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION FOR RAIL. OUR OILED
WILDLIFE CARE NETWORK MANAGED
BY THE WILDLIFE HEALTH CENTER
AT UC DAVIS HAS EXPANDED ITS
WILDLIFE FREE HAVE NETWORK TO
MORE THAN FORTY SENATORS WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON BRINGING NEW
INLAND FACILITIES ONLINE. I IS
THE MINISTRY TO RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR ME TO PERSONALLY
SCHEDULED VISIT SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS AND
LEGISLATORS TO FROM YOUR
FAMILIARIZE THEM WITH OSCARS
MARITIME PREVENTION. AND
STATEWIDE PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. MOST SENIOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE MATTER THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND CAL WE
**** RESPOND TO NATURAL
MANMADE. EMERGENCIES BUT THE
WAY THAT WE RESPOND BY FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW AS THE STATE'S
TRUSTEE ONE OIL SPILL
DIFFERENCE IN IMPORTANT WAYS
FROM THESE OTHER TYPES OF
RESPONSES. OIL SPILLS HAVE
DESIGNATED STATE AND FEDERAL ON
SCENE QUARTERS FOR MáS FOR IN
THE U. S. COAST GUARD USEPA
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE SPILL
OCCURS. AND DECISION MAKING
DOES NOT START AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. OSCAR CONTINUES TO WITH
YET SOME PREVIOUS SEVEN IS. TO
CLAY THESE DISTINCT. AND WORK
TO ENSURE AN EFFECTIVE IN CORE
NEED RESPONSE AND OPEN LINES
COMMUNICATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SELECT I BELIEVE YOU NEXT.
A EVENING CARE CHAIR FREED. I
GUESS. I KNOW MY OF THE JOINT
LAY COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
ARE TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE C. PREVENT OCCURRED
YEAR WHY IT HAPPENED WHAT OUR
RESPONSE. AND HOW WE ARE TO
SICK NAY TO IT FROM A- I AM
BILLY LOCKERBIE VICE. SHALL SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY BE UNIT. I
OVERSEE THE CO. THERMAL DATA
MIGHT OFFER. IN CURRENT CAN. I
WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THE SHOW
IN CHEVRON'S EFFORTS TO CLEAN
UP WHAT WE REFER TO AS THE SIM
RICK ONE WHY SEAT. I WORKED IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES INCLUDING
CAL JIM ASA PER AND THE KERN
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. ALSO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF ACCOMPANYING
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND MISTER
MARSHALL WHEN THEY VISITED THE
SAME RICK FEEL LAST JULY.
CHEVRON IS OPERATED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
WE HAVE A LONG LEGACY OF
SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE CURRENTLY EMPLOY
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN THE STATE. AS WELL AS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CONTRACTORS. OUR OPERATIONS
GENERATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EACH YEAR AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE
FOR THE COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
OPERATE. THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
AND CALIFORNIA EMPLOYS FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO EARN
AN AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. AND MANY OF THESE
WORKERS DID NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A HIGHER
EDUCATION. ALL TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA'S OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY REPRESENTS 36% OF THE
STATE'S TOTAL DAILY OIL
CONSUMPTION. AND CONTRIBUTES
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN STATE AND LOCAL TAX
REVENUE. HISTORICALLY STATEWIDE
THERMAL DATA MIGHT PRODUCTION
HAS MADE UP JUST OVER 10% OF
THE STATE'S DAILY PRODUCTION OF
OIL. CHEVRON'S THERMAL DATA
MIGHT OPERATIONS SPAN THREE
FIELDS IN CALIFORNIA IN A DRY
REMOTE PART OF KERN COUNTY
ABOUT ELEVEN MILES LONG AND TWO
MILES ACROSS. THERE'S NO SOURCE
OF DRINKING WATER IN THE FIELDS
AND THE CLOSEST TOWN IS FOUR
MILES AWAY. AS CONFIRMED BY THE
AGENCIES OVERSEEING THE CLEAN
UP LAST YEAR'S EVENT DID NOT
IMPACT PUBLIC HEALTH OR
DRINKING WATER IN ANY WAY. WE
TAKE OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
OPERATE SAFELY AND IN A MANNER
THAT PROTECTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE FULLY ACCEPT AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR ACTIONS
RELATED TO THE ONE Y. VAN. TO
THIS END WE ARE COMMITTED TO
STOPPING AND PREVENTING SEEPS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
REGULATIONS ADOPTED LAST APRIL.
AND WE ARE MAKING GOOD ON OUR
COMMITMENT. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
AND CONTINUE TO ENHANCE
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS INCLUDING
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES AND EARLY
DETECTION PROTOCOLS. TO HELP US
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL SEEPS AND TO
PREVENT THEM. WE CONSTANTLY
MONITOR GROUND MOVEMENT THROUGH
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES LIKE TILT
METERS AND SATELLITES WITH
AERIAL IMAGING. AND WE VALIDATE
GROUND STABILITY AROUND ANY
ACTIVE SEAT BEFORE ALLOWING
PERSONNEL OR EQUIPMENT TO MOVE
INTO THE AREA. TODAY AS IN
YEARS PAST WE ARE ABLE TO
PREVENT VIRTUALLY ALL SEATS AT
THE SAME RICK FIELD. THE ONE Y.
EVENT THAT OCCURRED LAST MAY
WAS A NOTABLE EXCEPTION. WE
BELIEVE IT WAS THE RESULT OF A
WELL RE ABANDONMENT. A WELL RE
ABANDONMENT IS WHEN WE DO
ADDITIONAL WORK ON A PREVIOUSLY
ABANDONED WELL IN ORDER TO
ENHANCE WELL INTEGRITY AND
ULTIMATELY REDUCE THE POTENTIAL
FOR SEAT. WE REGULARLY CONDUCT
WELL RE ABANDONMENT AND THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME AT CP AS
OCCURRED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY. SAFETY
IS FUNDAMENTAL AT CHEVRON. UPON
FIRST IDENTIFYING THIS STEEP ON
MAY TENTH WE TOOK IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. FIRST WE
ASSESSED AND CONFIRM TO SAFETY
OF OUR EMPLOYEES I CONTRACTORS
AND THE PUBLIC AND EVALUATED
HOW BEST TO CONTAIN THE SEAT.
WE DIDN'T NOTIFY THE
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCIES AND
WORK TOGETHER TO PROVIDE
REGULAR UPDATES TO LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND OTHER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND TO
DETERMINE THE BEST PATH FORWARD
FOR CLEAN UP IN RESPONSE.
WORKING IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE AGENCIES WE PUT IN A BERM
TO CONTAIN THE AFFECTED AREA
AND TO PROTECT THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT. WE ALSO TOOK STEPS
RIGHT AWAY TO PROTECT WILDLIFE.
FROM THE ONSETWE WORKED IN
CONSULTATION WITH OFFERED TO
PUT IN PLACE MULTIPLE MEASURES
TO KEEP BIRDS AND OTHER
WILDLIFE FROM ENTERING THE AREA.
DURING THE ONGOING RESPONSE WE
WORKED AS PART OF UNIFIED
COMMAND TO IMPLEMENT WILDLIFE
PROTECTION MEASURES LIKE
FENCING AND NOISE DETERRENCE.
IN ALL AREAS OF THE CLEAN UP.
AND WE HAD FULL TIME BIOLOGICAL
MONITORS WORKING ON SITE.
DESPITE THESE AGGRESSIVE
MEASURES WE REGRET THAT FOR
BIRDS DID LOSE THEIR LIVES. ON
OCTOBER ELEVENTH OF LAST YEAR
UNIFIED COMMAND CONFIRMED THAT
THE CLEAN UP WAS COMPLETE. OUR
FOCUS SINCE THEN HAS BEEN ON A
CORPORATION LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE ONE Y. ADVANCE TO
REASSESS AND ENHANCE OUR FIELD
WIDE ABANDON THE PROGRAM. THIS
INCLUDES REASSESSING ALL WELLS
INCLUDING THOSE THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ABANDONED. SO THAT
WE CAN INSURE WELL INTEGRITY
ACROSS FIELD OPERATIONS AND
PREVENT THIS TYPE OF EVENT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN. IN ADDITION TO
THE ACTIONS WE HAVE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO THE ONE Y. EVENT.
WE ALSO HAVE A TEAM OF OVER
FIFTY TECHNICAL EXPERTS WORKING
TO IMPLEMENT A HOLISTIC FIELD
WHY PLAN DESIGNED TO
PERMANENTLY STOP WHAT IS
REFERRED TO AS GS FIVE SEAT. AT
ARTS IN RICHFIELD. WE ARE WELL
UNDERWAY WITH THIS PLAN. AS
PART OF OUR COORDINATED EFFORTS
WITH CAL JIM TO STOP THE GS
FIVE SEAT SUMMARY ACTIVATIONS
ARE RELEASES HAVE OCCURRED AND
MIGHT STILL OCCUR. OUR
COMMITMENT TO PERMANENTLY STOP
THIS SEAT OUTWEIGHS THE
POSSIBLE RISK OF A SHORT TERM
STEEP ACTIVATION. THE DAY GS
FIVE IS THE ONLY ACTIVE SEAT AT
OUR SIMMERING FEEL. WE
RECOGNIZE TO THAT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF ACTIONS
INTENDED TO ENHANCE OVERSIGHT
OF CYCLIC STEAMING AND THERMAL
DATA MIGHT. INCLUDING
IMPLEMENTATION OF A MORATORIUM
ON NEW WELLS AND AN INDEPENDENT
STUDY TO ASSESS THE SAFETY OF
EXISTING WELL. WE FULLY SUPPORT
TAKING A SCIENCE AND DATA BASED
APPROACH. TO EVALUATING
INDUSTRY OPERATIONS AND BEST
PRACTICES. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE IN THIS
PROCESS INCLUDING SHARING DATA
AND INFORMATION. FOR LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE LAB. I'D CHEVRON WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF CALIFORNIA OTHER
GOVERNMENTS AND THE PUBLIC
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
RISK OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
CONTINUING TO DELIVER THE
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE EVER
CLEANER ENERGY THAT BENEFITS
CALIFORNIANS AND CONSUMERS
AROUND THE WORLD. GEN RUN IS
TAKING ACTION TO MANAGE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
LOWERING THE COMPANY'S CARBON
EMISSIONS INTENSITY. INCREASING
OUR USE OF RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
INVESTING IN FUTURE IN A IN THE
FUTURE TO TARGET BREAKTHROUGH
TECHNOLOGIES. AS A COMPANY WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IN
A WIDE RANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING EXPANDING EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURES
IMPROVING BATTERY TECHNOLOGY
AND ADVANCING CARBON CAPTURE.
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY IS
A GLOBAL ISSUE AND WE ENCOURAGE
THE STATE TO THINK BROADLY WHEN
SETTING A CARBON NEUTRALITY
POLICY AND DESIGNING PROGRAMS
TO ACHIEVE EMISSIONS GOALS. WE
ARE COMMITTED TO BEING AT THE
TABLE TO HELP FIND AND BE PART
OF THE SOLUTIONS. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD CHEVRON WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FORTHCOMING AND
RESPONSIVE TO ALL LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
OUR REGULATORS TO ADDRESS ANY
ISSUES- IN OUR THERMAL DATA MY
FIELDS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK TO
ALL OF YOU- BECAUSE MR STERN
AND I ARE TAG TEAMING THIS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO NOW. IS WE'RE
GOING TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS FOR
THE AGENCY MEMBERS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO ASK MR LOOK KOBE
SOME QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
LET THEM ASK QUESTIONS- SO I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR THE
AGENCY MEMBERS AND I'LL LEAVE
IT TO YOU. AS TO WHO ANSWERS I
THINK I THINK ONE OF THE LEAST
SPECIFIC TO MR COLUMN. OF FIRST
HOW MANY WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU ARE ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT
ARE USING HIGH PRESSURE STEAM
TO BREAK UP OIL FORMATIONS
BELOW THE GROUND. AND COMMUTERS
ARE CLARIFY ALSO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE BREAKING THE OIL
FORMATIONS WITH HIGH PRESSURE
STEAM DIFFERENT FROM HYDRAULIC
FRACKING. AND SHOULD OPERATORS
BE REQUIRED TO ALSO COMPLY WITH
WELL STIMULATION REQUIREMENTS.
THAT'S THE FIRST CLASS ONE
QUESTION. RABBITS THREE
QUESTIONS UP IN ONE QUESTION.
RIGHT SO LET ME. THE IS A- GOOD
WALK TO A INTO THE BUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. A DRUG
FRACTURING CYCLIC STEAM. UP SO
THIS IS. THERE BOTH. YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER ENHANCE COVER
STIMULATE TECHNI WITH.
HYDRAULIC FOR YOU HAVE HYPER.
OR PROP OR SEEN. THAT'S
INJECTED INTO A WELL BOARD I
ITS PURPOSE CREATING NEW FLOW
CHAIR INTO THE- USUALLY IT'S
FOR- ROCK DOESN'T HAVE THE
PROBABILITY OR THE ABILITY FOR
FLUID TO FLOW THROUGH IT THERE
IS SOME OF THE DIANA MIGHT-
GEOLOGY OUT THERE IF YOU
DRILLED A WELL LIKED. TO DEAL
WATER WELL YOU COULD DRILL IN
THE WATER WOULD COME OUT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY FOR THE FLU THE FLOW
WITHOUT. A CRACK IN THE ROCK-
HIGH PRESSURE CYCLIC STEAMER
CYCLIC STEAM HAVE A SHOW DOES
NOT HAVE ANY PROP INTO THE
HONEY. KIM IN IT IT A STEAM SO
IT'S VAPORIZED WA THAT GOES IN
THE GROUND A IT CREATES IT
HEATS. THE FOR MAKE. AND SO
IT'S A IT'S A STIMULATION
TECHNIQUE OF HE MIGHT THINK OF
CHANGING. IT'S CALLED THE SCOTT
CITY MOLASSE TO. THE WAY THE
FOR THE BILL OF MOLASSE TO FLOW.
ARE HONEY TO FLOW VERY SLOW BUT
HE'D UP IT CHANGE BUT SCOTT
HERE IN A GOES DOWN. IN CAN
FLOW MORE LIKE WATER THE SO
ACTUALLY THE- NOW IT NOT IT A
GOOD THROUGH JOB JUST TO WALK
GOES INTO A SPONGE. THE STATE
GOING TO A AND THE POOR. AND
THE SUBS INTERVAL AND HELLO
HOUSE FOR THE FOOD HELLO TO THE
WOBBLE. IT'S A TO THE AMICK
PROCESS CHANGE SECONDS. THAT
FORMATION PER. A HEATER FOR
HOTTER FOR THE HYDROCARBONS THE
FLOW TO THE WELL BORE- IN THREE
OF THE SO IT'S- IT'S IT IS.
MANY WITH FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT PROCESS IT IS NOT
COVERED UNDER ITS BEFORE AS A-
WELL STIMULATION TECHNIQUE- IT
IT'S NOT REGULATED THAT WAY DO
YOU HAVE TO KEEP. INJECTING THE
STEAM TO CONTINUE THAT PROCESS
ORDERS IT CAN THERE IS A
CONTINUE BY ITSELF NATURALLY
ONCE THE STIMULATION HAPPENS.
IT SO IT THE SO THE CYCLIC
STEAM SOMETIME CALL HUFF AND
PUFF- HAS THE PART PARTS TO A
IF YOU DIDN'T THE STEAM IN
THEIR YOU. HAVE NATURAL TO FLOW
BACK INTO THE WHILE- IN IT WAS
A NATURAL ENERGY THERE'S NO
PUMP THERE'S NO SECTION- IT
JUST YOU OPEN THE VALVE THE TOP
OF THE FOOD COMES OUT. AND SO
IN SOME WAYS IF YOU DIDN'T PUT
THE STEVEN THERE IT WOULDN'T
REACT THAT WAY I WOULD ONE DAY
IN THE CURRENT IN. THIS HOW
LONG HAVE HOPE I'M WONDERING IF
IT CHANGES THE ABILITY FOR THE-
MATERIAL TO SORT OF WANT TO
REACH THE SURFACE PERMANENTLY
OR FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME.
I'M NOT IN A- YEAH NOT AN OIL
ENGINEERS YOU HAVE TO. KNOW I.
MEAN IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
I NOT HEARD. BEFORE OF THE
ABOUT THAT WAY BUT IT. I MEAN
THAT YOU PUT. HAVE US. ISSUES
THAT IF THE POOR SPACES NOT. A
REFILL THAT YOU'RE CREATING
VOIDS ARE EMPTY SPACE THAT CAN.
WITH THAT THE OVER. OF THE
PRESS OF THE CROWN ABOVE IT.
SLOUGHED NOT AS PA THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHEN THE
QUESTION CAME UP LIKE WHY NOT
LOW PRESSURE CYCLIC STEAM.
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN TO THESE WHEN
HE TO PROTECT. OF THEIR- HOW.
IN A RELATIVE HOT
41005100 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT. A
TEMPERATURES THE SUBSURFACE.
THEY TAKE DECADES- TO COOL DOWN
AND SO. MUCH OF THE RESERVOIRS
ALREADY HOT AND SO IF YOU JUST
STOPPED. EVERYTHING WHOLESALE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE. TRIGGER
POTENTIALLY SERVICE
EXPRESSIONS- YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
SUBSIDENCE OF CRACKS AT THE
SURFACE- AREAS- THAT WOULD
CONCAVE AND- IT. IT IT IT IT
WOULD BE WAS CALLED BAD
RESERVOIR MANAGEMENT. CRAYONS
CONDITIONS. POTENTIAL TRIGGER
ADDITIONAL SIR. PRESS THAT WE
DON'T TO DO. SO PER. IS INTENSE
ENOUGH THAT IT IS CHANGE. THE
LOCAL MAKE. UP OF THE FORMATION
BELOW. FOR DE. IT THROUGH THE
HE IN. AND THEN THE FLU MOVE.
SO FLUID AND BUT IT'S A- SOME
LIKE ALL MACHINE. THAT YOU KNOW
YOU EVERY TIME YOU INJECT THE
STEAM THE GROUND IT GOES A
DIFFERENT FLOW IN. DIFFER PART
OF THE JOB IS NOT A YOU.
ADJUSTER AND- OF FINGERING OR
DIRECT. SO EVERY TIME YOU DO IT
YOU YOU YOU STEAM HIT THE PART
OF THE UNDERGROUND. AND SO IT'S
THIS ENTERED OF PROCESS- BUT IT
IT IT CHANGES BY THE NATURE THE
FLUID COMING OUT GROUND IS THE
IS THE PHYSICAL CHANGE. FOR ME
AS THE SOME OTHER RECENTLY.
MADE SERVICE EXPRESSIONS HE
LEGAL HOW MANY SERVICE
EXPRESSIONS OF WE HAVE. FROM
THE BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TELL NOW. TWO
THOUSAND. TRY NOW. I THINK I
HAVE. SO IN ADDITION TO THE ONE
Y. THERE'S A SERVER CLUSTER.
THERE'S ALSO AIR COMIC MCPHEE
THIRTY SIX AREA- THEIR TOTAL
EIGHT VANCE IN THE IN THAT IN
THE SURFACE EXPRESSION AREA
OTHER ON OUR WEBSITE. OTHER
THIRD CLUSTER AROUND CASE
STATING FIVE- WHICH OF TWO TWO
EVENTS. THE SPECIFIC NUMBER.
LOOKS LOOKS ABOUT ON THE TWENTY.
SERVER EXPRESSION RANGE SO
GIVEN THAT THAT THIS IS IT
MAYBE LEGAL BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO HAPPEN. ARE THE
PENALTIES FOR THAT ACTION
SUFFICIENT- GIVING THAT THE
SERVICE EXPRESSIONS ARE STILL
CONTINUING. YEAH AND YOU YOU
HAVE DIFFERENT- TYPES NATURE TO
SURFACE WITH RUSSIAN SOME CAN
BE MEDICATED SAFELY WHERE
THERE'S A BERMAN ISOLATED A YOU
CAN- DO WHAT'S CALLED A VACUUM
TRUCKER BACKTRACKED THE SUCK UP
THE FLUIDS WHERE IT'S IN A VERY
SMALL AREA- WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO CIVIL PENALTIES
IT'S AT THE DISCRETION OF STATE
SUPERVISOR- OUR LARGEST- A
SERVER EXPRESSION THAT WAS- AT.
THE SUMMER WAS THE LARGEST
CIVIL PENALTY THAT WE'VE ISSUED
FOR SERVICE RIGHT I GUESS I'M
ASKING IT'S CONTINUING DO YOU
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
STRONGER PENALTIES. I THINK
PENALTY IS ONE BUT ALSO IS
FIRST TIME REQUIRED TO DO ABOUT.
REPORT BACK TO IT WERE INCLUDED
IN OUR FIELD INSPECTIONS. WE
HAVEN'T HAD THE CAPACITY TO
RESPOND IN THE PAST- WE ALSO
ARE- HAVE HAD OUR RULES IN AND
PROVED TO DO CIVIL PENALTIES A
STRONGER ENFORCEMENT WE DO HAVE
AN ENFORCEMENT UNIT- WE DO HAVE
MORE ATTORNEYS OR AND WORK IN
OUR OFFICE IT GOT IT. THE DAY
WEREN'T THERE THREE FOUR YEARS
AGO. THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU.
MISTER CALL MY A QUESTION FOR
YOU TO QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS
WHAT ARE THEIR ENDANGERED
ANIMALS WITH THE NEAR THIS
PARTICULAR FIELD. YES MA'AM.
WHAT ARE THOSE. MORE EFFECT MY
CALL GREG BACK THERE COULD.
GIVE A SHOT I GREG. BOX KIT FOX
RIGHT THERE'S WAY. BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR YOU OKAY. THERE
THERE ARE WE'RE WHERE AG JUST
NEED TO DO ANY AT THIS FOR THE
WHILE PLAY. HALL WHERE LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THE PICK THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN RARE TIME
WORLD AND THE AND A AND EVERY
DAY THAT WE OUT THE- ON. LIKE
THIS MAY WE'RE WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT THE DEBATE PATTERN
WORKING WITH OUR ARE IN WHEN WE
OF THOUGHT WELL THINK YOU. TO
LEARN ABOUT THIS AND- I THINK.
BY VIRTUE THE LOWER NUMBER
WHICH I SURPRISED OF US OF A
THE DOOR IF AND THEY WERE. THE
BIRDS AND WE AND FEW MAMMAL. ON
I WOULD I THINK THE IT'S SAFE
TO SAY THAT'S OF THE BROWN
TECTUM LIKE THE ON GUNS IN THE
FENCE. GIVEN THE SAME CONCERNS
WITH OUSTER THE CRY. ON WORKED.
IT'S COMMON TO SEE WILDLIFE AND
WE HAVE A OF A CHEMICAL
LABORATORY- IN- RITUAL HEARD
OVER WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
FRANTICALLY THE OIL YOU KNOW
FROM THE- FROM YOU THE OTHER
CARCASS OR THAT THE LIVE
ANIMAL. AND TRY TO CHEMICALLY
FINGERPRINT MATCH IT TOO AND IN
THE CASE OF THE TWO I MENTIONED
IT WAS NOT CONCLUSIVE TO POINT
BACK TO THIS PARTICULAR
EXPRESSION SO DOES THAT GIVE
OFFICIAL WHILE BY A FOR ANY
OTHER AGENCY PAUSE THAT IT'S-
COMMON TO SEE. BOILED AND DYING
ANIMALS OR DEAD ANIMALS OF
COURSE. MMHM AND IS I MEAN TO
YOU WHAT MEASURES TO TAKE TO
TRY TO PREVENT THAT. HALL WELL
AGAIN AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND- AN EXAMPLE BE SOME OF
THE ON THE PONDS THAT THE MAJOR
OIL COMPANIES ARE. OUT MIGHT
HAVE THEY'LL THEY'LL PUT
NETTING OVER THE TOP TWO OF OCT
TO TRY TO KEEP BIRDS FROM GOING
AND I WOULD SING THAT SHINING
SURFACE AND COMING IN TO LAND
FIGURE MIGHT BE WATER. ON A AND
OCCASIONALLY- THERE MIGHT BE A
TEAR IN THE NET OR SOMETHING IN
THEIR IN THEIR BE BIRDS OF THE
WHAT WE CONSIDER AN ILLEGAL
TAKE AND WILL- TAKE YOU KNOW.
START INVESTIGATION ACTUALLY
TAKE CIVIL ACTION AGAINST TOM A
COMPANY THAT THAT THAT'S
EXAMPLE OF WHAT OF WHAT WE
WOULD DO. I'M THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LET'S WALK THROUGH. LET'S
START LET'S START FOCUSED ON
SAM RECKON WILL ASSUME OUT A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE I'VE BIGGER
QUESTION ABOUT THE OVERALL
PERMITTING FRAMEWORK BUT- ONLY
BACK TO THE TIMELINE. THIS IS
PART OF WHAT. RECORD THE NEED
FOR THIS HEARING IN THE FIRST
PLACE IS THAT- IT WAS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME THAT WE NEEDED.
THE NEWSPAPERS TO MAKE AN ISSUE
OUT OF THIS IN ORDER FOR IT TO
ACTUALLY TRIGGER UNIFIED
COMMAND YOU SAID. YOURSELF A
MISTER COLIN I BELIEVE YOUR
WORDS WERE. YET THE THAT THAT
THE NEED TO. BUT SAY. NO NO I
KNOW THE TIMING I'M JUST I'M
JUST TRYING TO REMEMBER LIKE
YOU WERE SAYING THE ACTUAL NEED
FOR UNIFIED COMMAND WAS TO DEAL
WITH THE MEDIA FIRE STORM NOT
WITH THE INCIDENT ITSELF WELL
CENTER THAT'S WEIRD SOUNDS BUT
TO REASSURE YOU ON THE
FORMATION THE UNIFIED COMMAND
IN JULY DID IN NO WAY SPEED UP
THE RESPONSIBLE FREE OF OIL FOR
THE MONITORING OF WILDLIFE WE
STARTED MAY TENTH WITH THE
INITIAL REPORT AND SEEING THAT
THERE WERE AT THE TIME WAS THE
TWELVE HUNDRED GALLONS OR SO IN
THE ENVIRONMENT. TAKING
RESPONSE ACTIONS VERIFYING THAT
CHEVRON AND THEY'RE CLEANING
CONTRACTORS WERE ON TASK AND
DOING THE THINGS THEY NEED TO
NOW- BEING WHERE IT WAS AND
pTHAT THERE WAS NO WATER AND AT
THE TIME I CAN USUALLY NO
WILDLIFE IN AND MINIMAL OF
CONCERNS YOUNG AT THE BEGINNING
WITH SMALLER VOLUME. ROM YEAH
WE DIDN'T THE NEED TO MOBILIZE
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE DOWN THERE-
YOKE ON THIS. BUT WHEN IT HIT
THE MEDIA IN WITH THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION WITH LOTS OF
QUESTIONS ON WHAT'S GOING ON
DOWN THERE- WE NEEDED THE THAT
ONE ELEMENT OF THE UNIFIED
COMMAND TO THE LIAISON. TO
REACH OUT TO- PO TO ALL LOCAL
CONCERNS SALE NGOS AND SO
FORTH. AND THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION SIDE TO REPORT. ON
WHAT WE ALREADY HAD BEEN DOING
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO DO. BUT
IF THE MEDIA HAD REPORTED ON
THIS. IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
THERE MAY HAVE NEVER BEEN ANY
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF THIS BILL
OR THE RESPONSE. I WOULDN'T SAY
IT WAS A OP WE WERE HOLDING
BACK ON THE- BUT YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED UNDER LAW TO PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE- THAT THAT KIND OF
CONTACT LIKE AYE. AYE MR LACK
BE MENTIONED THAT THEY
CONTACTED CALLOW YES THAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER LAW FOR CERTAIN
TYPE TO SIR FIX EXPRESSIONS YES
SIR BUT THEN IN RESPONSE. ASPER
OR CALORIE AS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO MAKE ANY PUBLIC DISCLOSURES
UNDER UNDER CURRENT LAW NO THE
ONLY JOB REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE
IF THE YACHT THAT WAS PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS A SHELTER IN
PLACE- QUALITY ON THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS YOU KNOW- OTHER
AGENCIES BESIDES US FOR YOUR
WOULD DEAL WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASPECTS. OF IT NO
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT- I'D
HAVE TO LOOK BACK ON. WE DON'T
HOLD BACK AS MY AFFECT WE VERY
PROUDLY. PUT OUT AND SOCIAL
MEDIA FACEBOOK TWITTER
INSTAGRAM SO FORTH. ON MOST OF
OUR RESPONSES SO I. WOULD NOT
BE AT ALL SURPRISED IF. IN THAT
PERIOD BETWEEN MAY AND JULY IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT WE PUT
OUT THERE. WE CERTAINLY WEREN'T
AWARE OF IT IF YOU DID PUT IT
OUT THERE AND- IT'S SIX I MEAN.
IN THE ABSENCE OF DISCLOSURE
QUESTIONS ABOUT. SO I WOULD AYE
AYE I WONDER GOING FORWARD-
EVEN IF YOU ARE DOING A SOLID
JOB OF RECOVERING EVEN IF THERE
IS ADEQUATE DISCLOSURE- TO
CALLOW YES- THE ABSENCE OF
THAT. TO THE PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION- IT SEEMS LIKE AN
ISSUE THAT WE AFTER RESOLVE
HERE- IF I MAKE SENATOR ON
THESE I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
YOUR POINT ARMED. I THINK ONE
OF THE MAJOR TRIGGERS FOR US IS
CERTAINLY- ANY TYPE OF OIL
WATER SURFACE WATER
INTERACTION- AFFECT AND OF
COURSE SOME AFFECT WILDLIFE. OF
WELL THIS IS WHAT IS CONSIDERED
A BLUE LINE JUST BY THE
NATURAL. ON A CARVE OF THE
TERRAIN IT IS CONSIDERABLE LINE
MEANING THAT AT SOME POINT IN
THE FUTURE AND YOU KNOW IN MAY
IN JULY. IN MCKITTRICK THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE THE DISTANT
FUTURE THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
WATER FLOWING THROUGH THERE. ON
THEIR WHAT'S IN THE PERCEPTION
THAT ON THAT THERE NEED TO BE A
BLAST OUT THAT YOU KNOW HERE'S
THIS BIG SPILL ON BEGAN BECAUSE
WE'RE MORE CONCERNED WITH WATER
WE DIDN'T. SLOW DOWN- MAKE IT A
LOWER PRIORITY TO RESPOND ONLY
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I GUESS I'M
TRYING TO GET AT. TRYING TO
BUILD SOME KIND OF TRUST SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH- SUCH A HUGE EXERCISE
EVERY TIME I'D SAY BOTH FOR.
THIS CASE THIS IS WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
PROBABLY HAS IN THEIR INTEREST
AND I WOULD SAY PROBABLY
INDUSTRY IN THE ADMINISTRATION
TO BE. AS FORTHCOMING AS
POSSIBLE AND IF THERE IS
DISCRETION TO MAKE THOSE
DISCLOSURES- IT SEEMS- PRUDENT
BUT IF THEY NEED IT YOU HAVE WE
NEED TO SORT OF LOOK AT.
REQUIRING ANY THAT DISCLOSURE
WE'RE HAPPY TO UNDERTAKE THAT
EFFORT AT EIGHT I WANTED TO. IN
ADDITION TO THAT THAT TIMELINE
I DID I DID WANT TO ASK CAL JIM
THOUGH- THIS OF THE PERMIT
SURFACE EXPRESSION BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- A
REQUEST FOR AN AQUIFER
EXEMPTION IN THIS EXACT FIELD
WAS GRANTED BY CAL CHEN- MINUTE
LEAST ON IN PART IN PART OF THE
BASES THAT. OF MISTER COLIN
NOTED THAT THE INJECTED FLUID
WOULD. IN IN YOUR ESTIMATION
ROOM REMAIN QUOTE IN THE
AQUIFER OR PORTION THE AQUIFER
THAT WOULD BE EXEMPTED. SO. IN
TERMS OF. FURTHER REQUEST UNDER
WAY SO- WE KNOW GS FIVE YOU
MENTION IS ON GOING. HOW MUCH
OIL DO WE THINK HAS EITHER
SPILLED OR LEAKING- BEEN
PRODUCE PRODUCE FROM THESE
AUTHORIZED SURFACE EXPRESSIONS-
OVER THE PREVIOUS YEARS OTHER
ESTIMATES I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
ASKING THE RIGHT AGENCY MAYBE
OSPREY MAYBE CAL GYM BUT YOU
HAVE AN ESTIMATE. OF HOW MUCH
WAS ACTUALLY HAS BEEN SPILLED
LEAGUE PRODUCED- THROUGH
SERVICE EXPRESSIONS OF PASTORS
REGARDS WEATHER TOUCHES WATER
WILDLIFE OR NOT I KNOW YOU WENT
THROUGH THE- SORT OF. TOTAL
NUMBER YEAH I'M I'M TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT GALLONS HERE OR
BARRELS WHAT. I CAN GIVE YOU A
SECOND THAT ONE IF YOU WANTED
IF YOU WANT TO CONSULT CAN ALSO
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE
EIGHT EIGHT YOU KNOW THE LONGER
TERM- GS FIVE. BILLY PROBABLY
COULD ACT ANSWER HOW MUCH HAS
COME OUT OF THERE BUT I GUESS
I'M SAYING THAT. OVERALL STATE
WANT WHY. FROM YELLOW TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT OKAY WE
DON'T HAVE AND THEN THE OTHER
SORT OF STATEWIDE QUESTION WAS
HOW MANY. HOW MANY DRILLING
PERMITS IS CAL JAM ISSUED SINCE
SAY- TWENTY EIGHTEEN. TO PICK A
DATE I GOT THAT. DRILLING
PERMITS SENSE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO YES. DRILLING PERTH REALLY
PERMITS. SAYS LIKE NEW DRILLING
RIG DRILLING RE WORK. WELL AT
LEAST YEAH I GUESS UNDERNEATH
THAT YEAH I MEAN HOW MANY FOR
WELL STEM OR A. K. A. FRACKING
AND HOW MANY FOR NEW CYCLIC
STEAM BUT THE BIG NUMBERS THE
ONE I WAS MOST INTERESTED IN.
FOR CHECK DON'T HAVE A BROKEN
OUT THAT WAY. I DO NOT ALTER
THEM REELING PERMITS- I HAVE IT
LOWER. CURRENTLY BUT NOT FOR
THE TWO YEARS CAN COMPARE BOTH
FOR EACH CATEGORY I CAN GET
THOSE TO YOU THOUGH OKAY. ENDS.
DO WE KNOW HOW MANY PERMITS FOR
INJECTION. JUST WITH AN
INJECTION CONTACTS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED YES. I HAVE WELL
STIMULATION PERMIT TOTALS.
DEBBIE THE YEAH MORE THE
FRACKING CONTEXT I'M SAYING.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE U.
I. C. STAFF IS SAYING FIVE FIVE
NEW PRO TO OKAY LAST FRIDAY FOR
SURVIVOR MEANT. IT'S NOT IT'S
KIND OF CHEATING YOU YOU YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION. BUT
THAT'S YEAH EXACTLY BUT THAT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET AT THE
INDIVIDUAL PERMITS THEMSELVES.
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF
THE SCOPE OF ACTIVITY THAT IS
UNDER WAY A CAL JIM. THE
QUANTITY OF. OIL THAT'S BEEN
EMERGING FROM SURFACE
EXPRESSIONS WRIT LARGE YEAH BUT
BUT AT LEAST- OF NEW DRILLS-
AND THE LAST PRESS FOR YEAR AND
A HALF IS BEEN. ABOUT
1-600-100-0500 NINETY A TOTAL
NEW DRILLS OKAY- STATEWIDE WITH
THAT ARE VARIETY OF AREAS
INJECTORS- WASTEWATER DISPOSAL-
STEAM STEAM FLOOD. BUT THERE
AND I DON'T HAVE CATEGORIZED BY
WORK OVER. GOT OR BUT- YEAH
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED YOU SAID
SIXTEEN HUNDRED OR SO FIFTEEN
NINETY FIFTEEN NINETY. AND AM I
ASKING THE RIGHT PERSON IS A
YOU ARE MISTER CALLING ON THE
WHO WILL GET BACK TO US ON
THIS- THIS SORT OF OVERALL
SERVICE EXPRESSION HOW MUCH HAS
BEEN SPILLED IN CALIFORNIA
GALLON TWICE. WE WILL CERTAINLY
WORK WITH A WITH CAL GERMAN
THAT CENTER ON ONE POINT POINT
THAT WELL I'M GONNA COME BACK
IF I MAKE LEAST LIKELY YEAH
PREVIOUS QUESTION YEAH ALL OF
THESE REPORTS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CATS ARE ABLE GET AVAILABLE OF
COURSE ON THE WEBSITE. YOU
KNOW- SO WOULD BE THERE'S NONE
OF THIS IS THE OLD BEHIND ANY
TYPE OF FIELD FENCE OR
WHATEVER. THERE'S A ON ANOTHER
POINT THAT LIKE CAR OFFSHORE
WATERS I ESPECIALLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YEAH ON THE INLAND
ALSO HAS NATURAL SEEPAGE AND-
AND MY COLLEAGUE FOR CHEVRON-
DIS TOLD ME THAT JUST IN THE-
THE CATCHER KARI ALONE THERE'S
TEN NATURAL SEEPS SO. ON THE-
WILDLIFE FEEL THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE THE CUT RABBIT. ON STATES
THAT HAS SOME SOME OIL ON IT
COULD HAVE COME FROM SHORT ONE
WAS THAT AND WE KNOW IT WE KNOW
THERE'S ALL WE'VE SEEN THE
BEVERLY HILLBILLIES LIKE I
SAID. YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
OIL IN THIS STATE BUT BUT HOW
MUCH FROM NON NATURAL I MEAN
THAT'S TAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT HERE TOO
AND THE CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT
EVEN THE LOW ENERGY TRIGGERED
SURFACE EXPRESSIONS THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY COME FROM THAT HIGH
PRESSURE CYCLIC STEAMING. HOW
MUCH ARE WE NOT. GETTING AT
RIGHT NOW AND THAT MAYBE THIS
IS WHERE MISTER LACKEY BE MIGHT
HAVE SOME INSIGHT- BUT I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE LIMITED. TO
CHEVRON AND I'M TRYING TO GET
SORT OF. THE BROADER. SCOPE OF
THE ISSUE HERE. RESHAPE THAT
ANALYSIS BROUGHT BACK TO WORK
COMMITTEES BECAUSE I THINK. WE
WANT TO SCOPE THE PROBLEM. WE
DON'T WANNA CHASE- YOU KNOW
ISSUES THAT AREN'T THERE ARE
RISKS THAT DON'T EXIST BUT- THE
FACT IS IN THIS CASE WE GOT A
LITTLE BIT LUCKY. RIGHT WE
WEREN'T NEAR- AN AQUIFER-
MINIMAL WILDLIFE AND COMMUNITY
IMPACTS BUT- I GUESS I WANTED
TO KNOW FROM. A THE R.
PETROLEUM ENGINEER SEEMS LIKE
THE BEST PERSON ASK BUT-
MITCHELL I COULD BE MENTION.
CONCERN ABOUT THIS WELL RE
ABANDONMENT POTENTIALLY BEING.
WHAT I FOR BETTER LIKE BETTER
TERM A ROUTE COSTS- THAT BEING
THEIR SORT OF CURRENT
CONJECTURE DO YOU DO YOU SHARE
THAT THAT OPINION AT THIS POINT.
NO WE DON'T KNOW YET WE ARE
EVALUATING AND STILL- AS ONE OF
THE AREAS WORKING WITH THE
NATIONAL LABS UNDERSTAND
COMPLEXITY- AYE AYE I'VE NOT
SEEN DOCUMENTATION FOR
CERTAINTY THAT WHAT THE CAUSE
OF THIS BILL. AND SO WITHOUT
PREJUDICING THAT ANALYSIS THAN.
IT IS THERE IS THERE A CONCERN
ABOUT SERVICE EXPRESSIONIST
VICTIM THE OVERALL FIELD
INTEGRITY HERE IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS
THE IMPACT AND I AND I TAKE
THAT TO MISTER LOCKE B. AS WELL
BUT- YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT. IF
IT'S JUST SIMPLE WELL
REVETMENTS ONE THING. BUT IF
THIS SURFACE EXPRESSION ISSUE
IS SORT OF PRODUCT PART OF A
BROADER TREND THAT AFFECT
OVERALL FIELD INTEGRITY- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT WHEN
YOU'RE- DOING YOUR ANALYSIS.
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE
ARE WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THE
NATIONAL LABS DURING THE MORE
TORRENT HERE IT IS WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING WEARS A HALFPENNY.
WHERE IS IT NOT HAPPENING AND
WHY- SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
INFORMED REGULATORY DECISIONS
OKAY- BUT WE ARE ALSO WORKING
TOGETHER ON A REMEDIATION PLAN.
TO BRING TEMPERATURE DOWN AT-SOME WRECK- THAT WERE- CHEVRONS
INJECTING IS APPROVED BY CAL
JIM TO INJECT LOWER TEMPERATURE
WATER. TO LOWER THE TEMPERATURE
THE RESERVOIR- THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING FOR ABOUT THE LAST
SEVEN WEEKS. VERY SEEN ABOUT A
70 DEGREES TEMPERATURE DECREASE
I WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE A AND ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATE SURFACE EXTRACTION
OKAY. AND THEN- MY LAST A
QUESTION WAS WHAT I HAD TO
SECTOR CROWE FOR ABOUT. JUST
THE PAY OF OVERALL YOU I SEE.
PROJECT BY PROJECT INSPECTION
ARE YOU ALL ARE YOU SATISFIED
AT THIS POINT WITH THE PACE THE
WORK. NO AND YOU WERE ACCURATE
WAS NINE- IT IS HOLE IS WILLIAM
ATTIC INADEQUATE AND- I AM-
COMMITTED TO AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUING IT- MAKING SURE WE PUT
THE RESOURCES ON THAT- ONE OF
THE KEY THING FOR US TO THE
BUDGET. JEFF BCP OF TRYING TO
GET NEW POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES- BECAUSE WE HAVE
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE WORKING TWO
OR THREE JOBS. I WE HAVE A LOT
OF VACANCIES RIGHT NOW THAT
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO FILL BECAUSE
OF OUR HIRING FREEZE. OF THE
WE'RE SPENDING OUR- WHAT THE
LEASE OUR SAVINGS ON OUR
NATIONAL LAB STUDIES. IN THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AND SO WE-
WE'RE WE'RE VERY CONSTRAINED
AND WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE- BUT
WE NEED DISSONANCE RESOURCES
WHY. I INTEND TO. ACT ASSIST IN
THAT EFFORT THROUGH BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT I DO WANT TO
GET A SENSE I HAVE REVIEWED THE
B. C. P. AND I KNOW THERE'S NOT
A BUDGET HEARING BUT- TIMELINE
TO I'D ASK THE SECRETARY THAT
BUT- IN YOUR- IN YOUR IDEAL
WORLD. YOUR B. C. P. IS BEEN
PROPOSED SAY THE LEGISLATURE
GRANTED. WHAT WHAT CAN WE TELL
THE PUBLIC WHAT IT WHICH OF THE
EXPECTATIONS BE IN TERMS OF
JUST A TIME LINE FOR. REVIEW
AND MAYBE A PRIORITIZATION
METHOD THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN MIND
AT THIS POINT. YEAH THIS IS
THIS IS THE AREA THATSEVERAL
CURRENT TECHNICAL VACANCIES
AND- IN THE B. C. P. IT'S A
THREE YEAR PHASE IN. A HALF IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND ANOTHER KIND
OF QUARTER QUARTER THE SECOND
AND THIRD YEAR. OF COURSE AN
IDEAL SCENARIO WE LOVE IT ALL
YOUR ONE- BUT WE REALIZE THAT
WE WORK IN- THE PUBLIC SECTOR
AND- AND HAVE TO. USE YOUR
RESOURCES WHETHER AGENCIES- BUT
IT'S A IT IS A- EFFORT- THAT
I'M FOCUSED ON- IN THE LAST.
FEW WEEKS. I'VE BEEN VERY
VIGOROUS VIGOROUSLY PUSHING TO
GET SOME OF THESE BACKLOG
REPORTS OUT- SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE ON THE NEXT
LEVEL. OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
IMPLEMENTING THEM WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND- AND- I MEAN I GUESS.
I DON'T FORCE YOU TO. DRILL
DOWN PARDON THE PUN BUT TO
DEEPLY. ON A ON A SUPER SUPER
PRECISE TIMELINE BUT MEAN WE
LOOKED AT FOR INSTANCE THE CCSD
REPORT THAT RECOMMENDED SET
BACKS- FOR- EXTRACTION NEAR
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES. I'D
THERE'S TALK OF FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FEET TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FEET
BUT AT LEAST FOR THE U. I. C.
INSPECTION PROCESS CAN YOU GET
CAN YOU TACKLE THAT CHUNK OF
PROJECTS WITHIN THE YEAR WITH
ADEQUATE FUNDING. AND I'D LIKE
H	A AND WE ASK WHAT IS THAT
UNIVERSE OF YOU I SEE WITHIN
RANGE OF COMMUNITIES I KNOW
THAT MAY BE OUTSIDE OF THE
SCOPE OF THE SIM RICK
CONVERSATION BUT- WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT. WHAT WHAT'S A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION FOR THIS
YEAR ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE FOLKS
WHO LITERALLY LIVE NEXT ORDER
WE HAVE A LIST ALREADY OUT THE
PUBLIC- THINGS ABOUT FIFTEEN
PROJECTS SAID- WE COULD MOVE
ON. THAT ARE VARIOUS LEGAL AND
TECHNICAL STATES- THERE ALSO
ARE- ONES TO HAVE TO HAVE
PUBLIC HEARINGS THOSE WHO HAVE
HAD PUBLIC HEARINGS AND
VARIOUS- STAGES OF THE PROCESS-
AND SO- MORE NEW REVIEW OR FOR
EXISTING. LISTING OKAY YEAH AND
IT I THINK YOU'LL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO PUT A NUMBER ON
FOR THIS YEAR TIMELINE ON IT
THE HOW MUCH HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE TO DO. THIS ONE PROJECT
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S A TAKING HE
SAID HEARING THIS PROCESS. WHAT
WHAT'S A TAKING YOU ALL RIGHT
NOW ON AVERAGE DIVA SENSE MRS
MATTER MONTHS. AYE AYES A
MATTER OF A DEAR PER PROJECT IF
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE- STAFF
I THINK MATTER MONTHS THIS
PURPOSE RAJA PROJECT AND IN
THEORY YOU COULD GO IN PARALLEL
THEN WHICH WITH A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS GOING TO ONCE INSERTED
DIFFERENT. CAL JAM EMPLOYEES
RIGHT. OKAY HOW WOULD WE ALSO
HAVE THE HIGHER GEOTECHNICAL
PROFESSIONAL GASSED IN THIS AT
THAT WILL COME INTO THE STATE
WITH THE- LOWER. POST PEPPER OF
RETIREMENT YEAH. WITH THIS
SOBERING- SIZE OF A TASK SO
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
I REALLY. I WANT TO TRY TO BE
HONEST WITH PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT
THEY CAN EXPECT TO LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES- I KNOW IF
HELP IS NOT ON THE WAY AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WITH THE PROJECT
YOUR VIEW THEY SHOULD KNOW THAT
TOO- I. THAT THAT WAS THE MAIN
OF MY QUESTIONS AT THIS.
ALTHOUGH I GUESS. IN ORDER ON
THAT SET BACK QUESTION TO ME IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT THEY CAL
JIM HAS BEEN LOOKING AT- I
KNOWS IN RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THAT CCSD REPORT. IS THAT WHAT
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUR YOU
SAID A HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROCEEDING I'M SORRY I THINK
WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH CARE HEALTH
REAL MAKING US RIGHT TO IS
THAT. IS THAT WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF THAT PROCEEDING IN TERMS OF
ANALYZING. WHERE THERE MAY NOT
BE A- RESPONSIBLE OPERATOR HAVE
YOU KNOW THE IMPACT IN RISK AND
COMMUTER I. SPENT MOST OF THE
LAST TWO YEARS OF WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE INTIMATELY IN LOS
ANGELES YEAH- THERE'S MULTIPLE
WAYS THAT YOU CAN DO- A
POTENTIAL SET BACK- WE ARE
COMING IN WITH NO PRECONCEIVED
NOTION OF HOW TO IMPLEMENT
SUCH. OR A SET BACK AT ALL BUT
IN OUR- OR REVIEW AN OUT REACH
NO LAST MONTH- WITH MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN- NGO GROUPS- THAT IS
OVERWHELMING THE REQUEST THE
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE INCLUDED. AND
I ANTICIPATE WILL BE INCLUDED
THROUGH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH. OF
PRE RULE MAKING A FORMAL RULE
MAKING PROCESS- I GOT A- COUPLE
QUESTION MISTER LUCKY BUT I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS IF THEY
WANNA. FAVORITE INDULGENCE-
I'LL ASK MR LOCKERBIE A FEW
QUESTIONS AND TURN IT BACK TO
YOU TO ASK MISTER WALKER IS A
QUESTIONS AND THEN TO MISS LOAN
TASK. ANYBODY'S QUESTIONS THAT
YOU ONCE. AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THE LONGER WE TAKE THE
MORE MEMBERS LEAVE. SO REALLY
THE MORE OR LESS QUESTIONS YOU
END UP WITH SO THERE'S SOME YOU
KNOW SORT OF A GOOD NEWS BAD
NEWS KIND OF THING- SO I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
YOU- FIRST OF ALL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HOLD WITH THE
APPROVAL OF PERMITS- USING HIGH
PRESSURE STEAM. AS WE'VE HEARD
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- HOW MANY
OF CHEVRON'S TO QUICK STATE
WELLS. EMMERICH USE HIGH
PRESSURE STEAM TO BREAK
FORMATION. SO THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR WE HAD. TO HUNDRED
AND TWO. ACTIVE IN THE- X. THAT
WOULD HAVE QUALIFIED FOR CYCLIC
STEAMING- ALSO THOUGH AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR WE HAD
NO ACTIVE- STEAM INJECTION
ONGOING IN THE FIELD AT ALL. AS
SUPERVISOR- LOCK- SPOKE TO.
WE'RE TRYING TO COOL THE
RESERVOIR DOWN RIGHT NOW. AND
SO WE'RE INTRODUCING WATER INTO
IT- TO COOL DOWN THE RESERVOIR
AND NOT STEAM RIGHT AND DID THE
WELL THAT YOU WERE ABANDONING
GO THROUGH ANY FORMATION THAT
HAS HAD HIGH PRESSURE STEAM
INJECTED INTO IT. THE WELL- YES
THE WELL THAT WE WERE DOING THE
REAL BAND IN THE JOB THAT WE
WERE LATE THE- THE SEAT TO- AT
SOME POINT IN TIME IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN ON CYCLIC STEAM.
RIGHT SO I GUESS THE BIG
QUESTION THAT STILL HAS TO BE
ANSWERED IS HOW MUCH DID THE
HIGH PRESSURE STEAM CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE SERVICE EXPRESSION AND
THAT'S STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION THAT STILL WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING INTO CORRECT AND
WORKING WITH AGENCIES ON THAT
PARTICULAR- TOPIC. DOES THE
STEAMER YOU INJECT HAVE ANY
CHEMICAL ADDITIVES OR IS IT
JUST STEAM. NO TYPICALLY THE
STAIN THAT WE'RE GOING TO PREP
TO INJECT- YOU NEED PURIFIED
WATER IF IT'S NOT PURIFIED AND
AT THAT POINT IF FORM SCALES
AND WHAT HAVE YOU SO IT'S
TYPICALLY PURE WATER THAT WERE
FORMED A STEAM WITH- AND THEN
MY LAST QUESTION FOR YOU SEE
HOW EASY. MY LAST QUESTION IS-
I WAS JUST CURIOUS BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU WERE
CURRENTLY APPEALING THE
PENALTIES THE CIVIL PENALTIES
AND I'M JUST WONDERING- GIVEN
THAT. YOU KNOW YOU. DID SAY
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING
RESPONSIBILITY. ON WHAT GROUNDS
ARE YOU APPEALING AND ALTES SO
THERE'S- A COUPLE OF THINGS
FOR ONE THE TIME PERIOD THAT WE
HAVE- I'M TWO. GUS YOU KNOW
WHAT. IN THE ORDER IS VERY
LIMITED SO IF YOU WANTED TO US
THAT. AND I THINK THE TEN DAYS
YOU HAVE RISK. AT THAT POINT
YOU HAVE TO APPEAL. TO OUR
LEGAL WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE THEM
CONCERN WITH- IS THE WAY THE
ART OF WAS WRITTEN THAT IT SAID
THAT WE HAD- PRESENTED AND I'M
GONNA PAIR FACE HERE-
SIGNIFICANT- THREAT. TO HUMAN
HEALTH OR TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO IT'S NOT THE FINANCIAL
AMOUNT THEN THAT IS UNDER- YOU
KNOW DISPUTE ON YOUR MIND IT'S
MORE OF THE FINDINGS OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE WAY THAT
IS WRITTEN. AND AGAIN I WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AS WELL
TO POINT OUT EVEN THOUGH WE
APPEALED AT NO POINT THAT WE
STOP WORKING YOU KNOW IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE AGENCIES.
YOU KNOW FOR THE RESPONSE FOR
THE CLEAN UP AND TO STOP GS
FIVE YEAH I WAS JUST I'M
CURIOUS BECAUSE YOU KNOW. THERE
IS A CIVIL PENALTY AND IT'S IT.
IT IT SOUNDED LIKE THE APPEAL
WAS ABOUT THE CIVIL PENALTY-
AND BUT YOU'RE SAYING IT'S MORE
ABOUT THE- THE FINDINGS ABOUT
THE- THE IMPACT ON PUBLIC WORLD
AND WHAT THAT MIGHT LEAD TO
LATER ON AND- THAT MAKES SENSE.
TO ME. A YOU WERE ABLE TO SELL
OIL THAT WAS EXTRACTED FROM THE
SPILL CORRECT. SO THE ACTUAL.
AT ONE WHY- THE WAY WE PROCESS
THAT OIL THAT WAS REMOVED-
THERE FROM THE DRY STREAMBED IS
IT EVENTUALLY MADE IT THROUGH
OUR PROCESS FACILITY. RIGHT AND
IS THAT- AMOUNT OF. PROFIT OR
REVENUE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
THE PENALTIES ARE ASSESSED. I
DON'T KNOW HOW WAS ASSESSED I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WE SPENT- MORE THAN
NINE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
SO FAR AND IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THE REVENUE THAT WOULD BE
GENERATED- BY THINK IT'S SIXTY-
SIX THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
BARRELS THAT WAS ASSOCIATED
THEIR OF OIL. WE TAKE A LOOK
THE REVENUE THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT IT PALES IN
COMPARISON TO THE NINE POINT
TWO MILLION WE SPENT ON THE
RESPONSE I'M DEFINITELY NOT
SUGGESTING THAT YOU ARE HAPPY
THAT YOU HAD THE SERVICE
EXPRESSION DON'T GET ME WRONG.
I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE SO THE NEXUS
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF THE
PENALTY AND- A KIND OF- FUTURE-
JUST YOU KNOW. OF
DISCOURAGEMENT FOR YOU KNOW
SERVICE EXPRESSIONS AND YOU
KNOW AT I THINK ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS BESIDES THE
PHYSICAL LOCATION THAT WERE.
GLAD THAT IT HAPPENED IN THIS
PARTICULAR LOCATION IS THAT IT
WAS CHEVRON TO AN OPERATOR THAT
HAS THE WHERE WITH ALL IN THE
ABILITY TO DO A REALLY GOOD JOB
WITH CONTAINMENT AND CLEANUP
SO. I'M NOT AT ALL- DISPUTING
ANY OF THAT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
CHARGES STERN THANKS- SO ALL
THE ALL THE OF TAIL ON THE
QUESTION I POSED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. REGARDING WELL
REMAIN IN MINT VERSES- SIR
GEOLOGICAL INTEGRITY SO YOU'RE
SAYING YOU THINK IT'S AT THIS
POINT SHOULD BE ABLE TO WELL RE
ABANDONMENT BUT- EXPLAIN IS WHY
YOU DON'T THINK. THAT THE
SERVICE EXPRESSION WOULD LEAD
TO A LOSS OF SAY GEOLOGIC
INTEGRITY FOR THE FIELD OVERALL
LIKE WHAT WHAT GIVES YOU SO IN
THIS PARTICULAR EXAMPLE- WE
BELIEVE THAT ONCE AGAIN YOU
KNOW IT WAS THE RE ABANDONMENT
THAT- THERE WAS A COMPROMISE
PORTION OF THE WELL BORE THAT
WE WERE WORKING ON WITH THE RE
ABANDONMENT AND THAT CREATED A
PATHWAY TO THE SURFACE THAT IN
THE COMING OUT IN THE DRY
STREAMBED. DUE TO ITS VICINITY
TO THE SURFACE IT'S M<c.cyan></c>
SHALLOW AND WHICH IS KIND OF
THE PATH OF REACH LEASE
RESISTANCE- YOU REFER TO YOU
KNOW THE ENTIRE FIELD- AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW THIS IS ONE VERY
SMALL PINPOINTED PORTION OF THE
FIELD- MATTER OF FACT WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PICTURES
THAT WERE SHOWN EARLIER- BE
IMPACTED SOIL IS ABOUT ONE ACRE
IN- IN A FIELD THAT IS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND ACRES. SO YOU
KNOW IT IT'S QUITE A BIT OF
DIFFERENCE THERE AS FAR AS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS ONE EVENT
COMPARED TO THE SCALE OF THE
ENTIRE FIELD. AND SO WHEN
YOU'RE SAYING ONE EVENT IT'S
THE IT'S THE EVENT I GUESS ITS
REPORT NINETEEN THIRTY FORTY
ACCORDING THAT TIME LINE AS THE
MATE WHEN IT WAS REPORT ON MAY
TENTH YET THAT'S CORRECT. AND
THEN SO THE OTHER REPORT THOUGH
ON JUNE EIGHTH THERE WAS THE-
RE. ON EIGHTEENTH IN ADDITIONAL
EVENT REPORT ON JUNE TWENTY
THIRD- USING THAT'S ON IN YOUR
ESTIMATION UNRELATED TO THE TO
THE MAIN EVENT WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE ALL RELATED THAT
THEY'RE ALL RELATED TO. A AT
THE SIMILAR SEAT- INITIATION IF
YOU WILL IT'S JUST DIFFERENT
FLOW LOCATIONS THAT THEY ARE
FLOWING OUT OF. BUT THE LET'S
CALL THE JUNE EVENT FOR LACK OF
A BETTER TERM IT'S NINETEEN
THREE SIX SIX EIGHT BUT- THAT.
YOU'RE TREATING THAT TO WILL RE
ABANDONMENT AS WELL CORRECT SO
ONCE AGAIN AS THAT PATH STARTED
MIGRATING UP TO THE SURFACE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT BRANCHED OFF
INTO SOME OTHER AREAS THAT IT
CAN'T MOVING TO POINTS OF LEAST
RESISTANCE. BECAUSE THE
ORIGINAL FLOW SITE A RECENT
POINT WERE EQUIPPED FLOWING AND
THEN YOU HAD OTHER FLOW SITES
THAT HAD STARTED. SO WE THINK
THE FLOW ITSELF WAS STILL ABOUT
THE SAME IS JUST COMING OUT OF
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS. SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IT I MEAN DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THE NEED TO DO
CONTINUOUS FLUID INJECTION OF
SOME SORT REGARDLESS OF THE
EFFORTS TO COOL THE FIELD OFF
RIGHT NOW BUT IN TOWARD IN. IN
ORDER MAINTAIN SOME GEOLOGIC
INTEGRITY TO THIS THERMAL DATA
MIGHT DO YOU THINK THERE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE A SORT OF.
CONTINUOUS EFFORT FOR. FLOODING
STEAMING SOME KIND OF- SOME
KIND OF ON GOING WORK NO THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION I THINK THE
PRIMARY GOAL IS GOING TO BE THE
JUST A MASS BALANCE OF WHATEVER
IT IS THAT YOU'RE TAKING OUT
YOU HAVE TO REPLACE IT IN
THEIR- SO. AGAIN IF YOU'RE
GOING TO EXTRACT- OIL AND
RESERVOIR FLEW IT THEN IT'S
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE THERE TO
REPLACE IT WHEN YOU'RE DOING
THE- CYCLIC STEAMING- YOU HAVE
THE STEAM THAT'S GOING AND
THEY'RE COLLECTING AND
REPLACING THE FLUIDS THAT
YOU'RE REMOVING. IF YOU GET TO
A POINT WHERE YOU SAY I DON'T
WANT TO STEAM ANYMORE AND
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO COOL THE
RESERVOIR OFF LIKE WE'RE DOING
NOW. BEEN IN THAT POINT WERE
INTRODUCING WATER- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE BALANCING THAT. WE
ARE MONITORING TO FEEL VERY
CAREFULLY FOR ANY SORT OF
GROUND MOVEMENT AND WE DO THIS
WITH TILT METERS THAT ARE
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE. AS WELL AS
THE- SATELLITE IMAGERY
TECHNOLOGY- THAT ALSO MEASURES
IT ANYTIME WE SEE ANY SORT OF
SUBSIDENCE THEN ONCE AGAIN WAT
WE DO IS GO AND ALTER THE
INJECTION RATE SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
GET. OUT OF HAND OR OUTSIDE OF
THE PARAMETERS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP IF WE START SEEING
UP LIVE. LIKEWISE WE MOUNTED WE
START TO MODIFY THE INJECTION
AND WE CAN ALSO MODIFY THE
WITHDRAWAL RATE AS WELL IN CAN
YOU. LACK OF FOR LAYMAN'S TERMS
CAN YOU. YOU CATCH UP FAST
ENOUGH IF YOUR TILT METERS ARE
SAYING HEY THERE'S A PROBLEM.
ARE YOU I MEAN WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE FEROCITY IN THE
INJECTION RATES BUT I MEAN CAN
YOU CATCH UP QUICKLY ENOUGH TO
ACTUALLY. PREVENT MASSIVE
SUBSIDENCE IN TIME- MORE. SO
THE PARAMETERS THAT WE LIKE TO
STAY WITHIN OR LESS THAN TWO
INCHES OF SUBSIDENCE PER YEAR
SO IT'S NOT A LOT OF MOVEMENT
AND THESE ARE EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE AND WE CAN. NOT CATCH
UP BUT WE CAN- MONITOR AND
MAINTAIN TO WHERE WE MINIMIZE
THE GROUND MOVEMENT- THAT'S
VERY POSSIBLE- WE'VE HAD SOME
CHALLENGES- WHEN THIS SEEPS
TOOK PLACE THERE WERE STEAM
BLOCKS THAT WERE PUT. AROUND
THE ACTUAL STEEP SITES. THAT
ARE THERE CALL WHAT STEAM
BLOCKS. STEAM BUT IT'S A RADIUS
AT WHICH YOU ARE NO LONGER CAN
INJECT- OR OR CONDUCT THE
CYCLIC STEAMING OPERATIONS AT
ONCE AGAIN THAT PRESENTS SOME
CHALLENGES THAT ON THAT MASS
BALANCE. I ISN'T THAT BECAUSE
OF A OF A THAT'S A G. A LOT
THERE'S JUST BLOCK BECAUSE OF
IT. THE KARACHI ISSUE OR THE
STAINED BLOCKS ARE A
THEORETICAL WE WOULD LIKE TO
DRAW A THEORETICAL RADIUS
AROUND A PARTICULAR SITE IN
THIS ONE WAS THE- ACTIVE SEEPS
AT THAT TIME- AND IT WAS
WORKING WITH CAL JAM THAT SAID
HEY WE WANT AND EFFECTIVE STEAM
BLOCK IN THIS AREA. IT'S NOT A
WALL THAT WE BUILD A REGULAR
ROWNTREE YEAH UNDERSTOOD IT'S
MORE REGULATORY NOT GEOLOGIC
CORRECT. OKAY IT'S A
THEORETICAL BUT AND WITHIN THAT
YOU CAN NO LONGER- AGAIN
CONDUCT THE CYCLIC STEAMING
OPERATIONS AND SO THAT LIMITS
YOUR ABILITIES TO AFFECT THE
SUBSIDENCE  TO OFFSET THAT
IN THE BACK I'M GONNA ASK I
**** BEFORE BUT I'M STILL
UNCLEAR AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT IT'S GAME BECAUSE I'M NOT
AN ENGINEER- HOW LONG IS THIS
INSTABILITY LAST I MEAN DO YOU
KNOW IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S
NO MATTER WHAT AS YOU TRY TO
CALL THIS FIELD ARE WE LOOKING
TO TEN YEARS OF THIS TWENTY
YEARS OR DO WE NOT KNOW OR ANY
YEAR EVERYTHING'S FINE YOU CAN
WALK AROUND THERE'S NO DANGER
THERE'S NO TILTING. I MEAN HOW
LONG THIS IS INSTABILITY THIS
FEEL GOING TO. SELL AND BE WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO MANAGE
THE SUBSIDENCE AND THE UP LIVE
TILL IT STOPS YOU KNOW UNTIL WE
REACH SOME POINT I SAID HOW
LONG DO WE KNOW HOW LONG
THAT'S- GOING TO AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT- I I'M NOT SURE. YOU
KNOW EXACTLY- WHAT THAT TIME
WOULD LOOK LIKE BUT ONCE AGAIN
YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE THE COOLING
PROCESS IS GOING TO TAKE SOME
TIME NOW- AND IS THIS WITH WHEN
YOU SAY SOMETIMES SO IS THAT. A
YEAR TEN YEARS MORE THAN A
YEAR- BUT I DON'T KNOW PAST
THAT POINT AND IS THIS KIND OF
INSTABILITY COMMON WITH ALL OF
THE FIELDS THAT YOU CYCLIC
STEAMING. NO THIS IS VERY
UNIQUE TO- THERMAL DATA MIGHT
AND THERMAL DATA MY THAT IS
NEAR THE SURFACE SO IF IT WERE
DEEP ENOUGH DOWN THEN YOU WOULD
HAVE ENOUGH OVER BURDEN OVER
THE TOP OF IT THAT THIS MAY NOT
BE AN ISSUE. IF IT WERE NOT
DYNAMITE- ONCE AGAIN THIS MAY
NOT POSE AN ISSUE IF IT WERE
MORE COMPETENT ROCK AS FOR
SANDSTONE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. IN OTHER. SO WHAT PER. OF
IT WHAT. HAVE WHAT CHEVRON.
FALLS WITHIN THIS CATEGORY OF
THERMAL DYNAMITE. SO BECAUSE IT
THIS IS ONLY UNIQUE TO THIS.
TYPE THEN WHAT PERCENT I MEAN
IS THIS- THERMAL DATA MY RIGHT
NOW REPRESENTS A LITTLE OVER
10% OF THE STATE'S CURRENT
PRODUCTION WHAT ABOUT CHEVRON'S
PRODUCTION- FOR US- PRIOR TO
THIS IT WAS PRIOR TO THE EVENT-
WE READ ABOUT TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND BARRELS- OUT OF ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
SO. REPORTER 20% OF PRODUCTION
YEAH LESS THAN A QUARTER YEAH
BORN CORD. OKAY. THE RESUME OUT
THEN FOR A SECOND OKAY I KNOW
YOU OVERSEE MOSTLY SAN JOAQUIN
THE BUSINESS SIDE OPERATIONS I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS THE KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF
REALITY CLIMATE CHANGE. EN
THAT'S A BIG FIRST STEP WITH
OUR OIL MAJORS ARE IT HAS BEEN
UP TO THIS POINT. BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT RISK AND
FOSSIL FUELS ROLE IN
EXACERBATING THAT RISK. TRYING
TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT. I THE
CALIFORNIA SCALE COMMITMENTS
ARE OR SHOULD MORE GLOBAL
COMPANY WIDE COMMITMENTS ARE IN
THIS AREA I APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE TURN ANECDOTAL EXAMPLES
RENEWABLE ENERGY WE KNOW
CHEVRONS ACTUALLY VERY LARGE-
ENERGY EFFICIENCY CONTRACTOR
AND DOES ALL KINDS OF WORK IN
THE ENERGY SPACE BUT- COULDN'T
HELP BUT BE STRUCK WHEN REP
SOLD THE SPANISH OIL. MAJOR
ANNOUNCED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
GO CARBON NEUTRAL AS AN OIL
COMPANIES CHEVRON LOOKING AT
THOSE KINDS OF- COMMITMENTS
THEMSELVES AND- YEAH SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL- CORPORATE WIDE-
COMMITMENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND LET ME SHARE WITH YOU A
COUPLE OF THEM IN AND I'LL GIVE
YOU SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH IN CALIFORNIA-
FIRST- WE HAVE- TARGETS FOR
METHANE AND FLARING EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND THESE OR
INTENSITY BASED. FOR METHANE WE
PLAN TO REDUCE THAT FROM TWENTY
TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT- WHEN
YOU COMPARE TWENTY SIXTEEN
NUMBERS TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
SO WE ARE WELL UNDER WAY TO TRY
AND ACCOMPLISH THAT FLARING
WE'RE GONNA REDUCE BY TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY PERCENT- AND THE
SAME COMPARISON BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. ON AN UPSTREAM- SIDE OF
IT WHICH MEANS YOU'RE PRODUCING
ARM NOT THE REFINING SIDE- WE
ALSO HAVE INTENT THE
COMMITMENTS WHERE WE ARE GOING
TO REDUCE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH ALL
PRODUCTION BY FIVE TO TEN
PERCENT- AND ALSO BE A NATURAL
GAS PORTION OF THAT- IN THE
GREENHOUSE GASSES ASSOCIATED
WITH WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE THAT
DENSITY BY. FIVE PERCENT. AND
AGAIN IT IS COMPARING TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN NUMBERS TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE NUMBERS
COOPERATE VERY CURIOUS ABOUT
THIS AND THAT IT WAS APPROVED
BY THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
IT WILL AFFECT COMPENSATE FOR
THE IMPORT BY THE IF THOSE-
GOALS ARE MET OR NOT MET. AND
DO YOU ACTUALLY IN A GREAT A
PRICE ON CARBON INTO YOUR
INTERNAL MATERIAL RISK METRICS-
WE DO- AGAIN EVERY BUSINESS
UNIT UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE- COST
OF CARBON- WILL BE- ESPECIALLY
IF THERE'S CAP AND TRADE IN
PLACE- AND THAT IS FIGURE IN
TO- BUSINESS PLANS AS WE
PLANNED FOR FUTURE WORK AND
BUDGET YOU HAVE A NUMBER DO YOU
HAVE A- COMPANY WIDE NUMBER
THAT YOU ASSUME FOR PASTA. WHEN
YOU'RE DOING THAT ANALYSIS.
ARIES BUT BY REGION OTHERS
REGION BY A- YEAH SO I I'D
CHAIRED I TO SHARE WITH YOU AS
WELL SO THE THINGS WERE WITH
CAL. A TWENTY NINETEEN WE FORM
A JOY VENTURE CALLED BY GAS
THIS IS WHERE WE TAKE- DIE
JESTERS TO DERRY FORMS- THOSE
DI DI JESTERS COME ONLINE TO
DIGEST THE MEN WHO WERE AND
PRODUCE RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
AND THEN THAT NATURAL GAS IS
SHARED IN TO THE- EXISTING
NATURAL GAS PIPELINE
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO THAT IT CAN
DISPLACE- YOU KNOW THE
TRADITIONAL NATURAL GAS- GOING
TO A DIFFERENT SOURCES.
LIKEWISE WE ALSO HAVE AT OUR
LOSS HEELS- FIELD A SOLO
PROJECT THAT'S GOING TO COME
ONLINE- HERE IN THE FIRST
QUARTER OF THIS YEAR- AND THIS
IS GOING TO PRODUCE-
ELECTRICITY THAT IS GOING TO
POWER THAT LAW SEALS- FIELD FOR
US- AND WE BELIEVE OVER THE
NEXT TWENTY YEARS THAT IT'S
PROJECTED THAT IT'S GOING TO
ELIMINATE- ONE MILLION METRIC
TONS OF- OF EMISSIONS OF.
CARBON DIOXIDE EMISSIONS. I
GUESS THAT THE HIGH. THE
HIGHEST LEVEL THOUGH FOR. UNDER
THE OLD EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH
STILL IN PLACE I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S SUFFICIENT. I HAVE FRANKLY
THING MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT-
DO YOU THINK CHEVRON CAN MEET-
THE CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WELL WITHIN ITS
OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. I
THINK THAT THAT IS A
CHALLENGING TASK FORCE I WANT
TO SAY THAT WE CAN'T I'M SAYING
THAT THE PATH ON EXACTLY HOW WE
WOULD ARRIVE THERE IS NOT A
PARENT IF WE OPEN THE APERTURE
AND WE SAY WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
SOMETHING MORE ON A GLOBAL
BASIS AND NOT JUST WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES. OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OPENS UP MANY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO ACHIEVE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO THE
LAST QUESTION IS REALLY ABOUT.
YOUR YOUR OUR OIL MAJOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT. AB
T. R. C. IS THE ONLY YOU KNOW
CLOSE WE'RE THE ONLY INTEGRATED
I BELIEVE THAT'S IT TRYING TO
GET THERE THAT'S IT. AND SO. WE
NEED TO PUT MORE PRESSURE AN
ONUS I BELIEVE ON YOU TO STEP
UP AND DO THINGS THAT ARE TRULY
INNOVATIVE- AND RECOGNIZE ANY
OF OPERATIONS ALL OVER THE
WORLD. YEAH THAT THIS TURNING
THE PAGE THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
FROM CAL JAM I THINK WE ALSO
WANT TO SEE WHAT THOSE GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS ARE FROM CHEVRON
AS WELL- AND I APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE ISSUES
IMAGINE BUT I WILL SAY I'M I'M
SOMEWHAT TROUBLED BY WHAT
YOU'RE FRIEDMAN BROUGHT UP IN
TERMS OF CHALLENGING PENALTY
AMOUNTS AND THEIR STAND THERE'S-A LAWYER WITH THE TECHNICAL
BASIS IS WORRIED ABOUT IT- BUT
WHEN THE PUBLIC HEARS THAT
YOU'RE CHALLENGING A- BILL TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PENALTY FOR THIS ISSUE. THEY
SAY WELL YOU KNOW THEY'VE GOT
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF REVENUE WHY
CHALLENGE HERE. LIKEWISE THIS
WEEKEND IN THE LA TIMES. I HAVE
TO BRING IT UP AND I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S WITHIN YOUR PURVIEW BUT-
THIS OVERALL SORT OF
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE NGO
COMMUNITY AND WITH ADVOCATES-
ANSWER WHAT KIND A CONVERSATION
WE WANT TO HAVE ABOUT. OUR KIND
OF FUTURE HERE WITH YOU IN
CALIFORNIA. TROUBLED TO LEARN
ABOUT THE SUBPOENA PROCESS
THAT'S UNDER WAY AGAINST ONE OF
THESE NGOS CONSUMER WATCHDOG-
AND SO WHAT WE DON'T. WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE IS THE- IT WE WANT
TO COOPERATIVE SPIRIT AND
SOMEWHAT SO. THE CHALLENGING A
PENALTY OR THE SUBPOENAING OF A
OF AN NGOAGAIN I'M SURE THERE
ARE PLENTY OF LAWYERS AND HOUSE
HAVE MANY FOLKS YOU HIRE
OUTSIDE OF YOUR YOUR HOUSE WHO
HAVE PLENTY OF GOOD LEGAL
REASONS TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO. BUT FROM THE
PUBLIC PERSPECTIVE. IT IT IT IT
STRIKES ONE AS EITHER TURN
OVERWHELMING AGENCY THAT'S
ALREADY UNDERSTAFFED OR IN THIS
NGO CASES ARE THE BIG GUY
BEATING UP ON THE LITTLE GUY.
IN YOU COMMENT AT ALL ON THE
SUBPOENA REQUEST UNDER WAY AND
IF YOU EVER ON STILL COMMITTED
TO FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THAT.
THAT KIND OF PRACTICE IN IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF HOW IT
INTERACTS WITH THE NGO
COMMUNITY JERRY STERN I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE ON THE SUBPOENA THAT
SO- AGAIN I'M JUST- NOT NOT
AWARE OF IT SO I COULD NOT
COMMENT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER. IF
YOU DON'T MIND TAKING THAT BACK
TO HEADQUARTERS- THAT SOMEONE
WE LOVE. SOME KIND OF RESPONSE
ON- WE KNOW THE NEWSPAPERS ARE
GONNA BE ASKING TOO. BUT WE
WANT TO KNOW HOW FAR YOU GUYS
WANT TO GO WITH THIS. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT. GOT
A FIGHT SOMETIMES THE
COURTROOM. BUT IF WE REALLY ARE
GOING TO TURN THE PAGE HERE- I
AM CONCERNED THAT. WE CAN SAY
ONE THING ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY.
AND THEN GO. PEOPLE UP ON THE
SIDELINES WHEN. NO ONE'S
WATCHING NOW NOW FOLKS ARE
WATCHING SO- ANYHOW- LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR FEEDBACK ON
THAT POINT. AND IF THERE'S SOME
WAY TO GIVE A ACTUAL TECHNICAL
RESPONSE ON THE CARBON
NEUTRALITY QUESTION I THINK
THAT WOULD BE. ILLUMINATING FOR
US FOR THESE COMMITTEES BECAUSE-
YOU HAVE A LOT OF IN HOUSE
KNOWLEDGE I MEAN NO ONE
PROBABLY UNDERSTANDS. ENERGY AS
WELL IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS YOUR COMPANY SO WE CAN FIND
A NATIONAL LAB REPORT OR TRY A
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO. YOU KNOW.
GET CAL JIM GOING INTO THEIR
ANALYSIS BUT THEY'RE TRYING TO
WALK AND CHEW GUM AND PERMIT OR
NOT PERMIT OR ANALYZE IT ALL
THE SAME TIME SO. TO EXTEND
YOUR FOLKS CAN START TO DO SOME
THAT TECHNICAL ANNOUNCE I THINK
YOU REALLY HEALTHY FRANKLY FOR
HAVING AN HONEST ENERGY
CONVERSATION AND- LIKE I SAID I
KNOW WE'RE IN ALL STATE- BUT
HOW DO WE- HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING INNOVATIVE HERE.
THAT'S NOT GONNA FEEL LIKE
BUSINESS AS USUAL I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER ON
THIS ALL RIGHT- WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN WAY TOO PATIENT-
CONSIDERING THE AMOUNT OF STUFF
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN. YOUR
DISTRICT OVER THE YEARS IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YEAH THANK YOU KNOW AND
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONING I
THINK THAT WERE ALL AT LEAST
THOSE OF US LEFT ON THE DíAS
ARE. ALIGNING AND THINKING THE
SAME SO YOU ASK SOME QUESTIONS
BUT I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
AND I START WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- YOU HAVE MEANT
IN A COUPLE TIMES THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING BUT IT.
REQUESTED THAT YOU CAN HIRE-
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BUT ASIDE
FROM HIRING MORE ENFORCEMENT
OFF. WERE OTHER DREADED. I IS
YOU KNOW ARE WE AS A STATE NOW
IMPLEMENTING ARE LOOKING AT- TO
INCREASE ENFORCEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT. YEAH I THINK THE BUT
IS IT IS A BIG OF THAT NOW HAVE
RECENTLY CREATED A AND
ENFORCEMENT UNIT- THAT'S A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
ENGINEERS AND ATTORNEYS WORKING
TOGETHER- AND THAT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS. WE HAVE- AND CAN DO
SOME ADDITIONAL VALUATION O
LOOK AT A POTENTIAL LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS- LOOK IT ADDITIONAL%
WAYS TO- INCREASE OUR FORCE
MEANT WE RECENTLY MET WITH US
FOR AND TALKED ABOUT THE WAY
THEY DO ENFORCEMENT IS
DIFFERENT THAN HOW WE DO
ENFORCEMENT THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO CHANGE OUR- PENALTY
CALCULATIONS- THAT WILL STAND
UP UNDER A- LEGAL REVIEW IN AND
DURABILITY- SO THAT WAS A
CONVERSATION WE RECENTLY HAD. A
IN THE LAST MONTH- BUT THERE'S
A THERE'S A NUMBER WHAT THINGS
WE CAN STILL DO- FOREIGN FORCE
MEN AND THINKING ABOUT- IT
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO GET
THERE IS IT IS IT BIG PENALTIES
IS THAT- BOND TEAM IS IT
SOMETHING ELSE OF THEIR THEIR I
THINK A LARGER CONVERSATION
COULD BE HAD ABOUT THAT- WE
COULD DO SOME RESEARCH ABOUT
THIS- BY DIFFERENT INSURANCE
AGENCY TO SEE WHAT IS OUR SKIN
WITH THE BEST WITH THE MANAGER-
IN ITS- NEW. RISK MITIGATION
TOOLS I MEAN WE COULD I THINK
THE IDYLLWILD PROGRAM. THERE
WERE MORE WELL ABANDONED AS WE
ISSUE OVER EIGHT. PER AND
TWENTY. AND THEY WERE. WELL A
BAND PERMITS AND REALLY PER.
AND PART OF THAT- IS THE OF
MOVING TO TAKE CARE OF A LEGACY
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT WE'RE ALSO
THE VITAL WELL FEES WE'RE
BUILDING UP FOR A RESERVE TO BE
ABLE TO START. A BAND IN
WORKING TOWARDS SOME THE
LIABILITY BUT- HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WHILE PEOPLE IN
OPERATIONS THAT THEY ARE.
MAKING TO TAKING CARE OF THEIR
THEIR ASSETS AND NOT LEAVE A
TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK SO THERE
SOME SOME THINGS WE CAN DO
INTERNALLY BUT THE BIGGER-
ITEMS THAT STILL ARE
UNADDRESSED BY A RECENT REPORT.
YOU KNOW THAT HAS LIABILITY
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
NINE BILLION- THAT'S OUT THERE
AND THERE IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT. YOU KNOW LEASE WE HAVE A
POINT. YOU KNOW OF SOME
SCENARIOS LOOK AT BUT NOW THE
NEXT STEP IS WHAT WE DO TO
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS. AND I'M
GLAD THAT THAT'S BEING LOOKED
AT. YOU KNOW IN PART BECAUSE
THEY- OF THE FACT THAT WE'RE
HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF ONE IDLE
WHILE- AND THERE ARE OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND THAT HAVE NOT.
BEEN USED IN FIFTEEN YEARS OR
MORE IN THE STATE. I AND THIS
IS ONE AND THIS ONE HAS CAUSED
FOR A LOT OF GREAT DISCUSSION
AND SO- WHEN I HEAR- THAT IT'S
COSTS TO IT. SO FAR NINE POINT
TWO MILLION- SO TO CLEAN UP-
DO WONDER WHAT HAPPENS WHEN. WE
NOW ONE MORE THAN ON- GOES-
YOU KNOW IT CAUSES THIS LEVEL
OF PROBLEM AND THE- COMPANY
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE- AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
ORPHAN WELLS. RIGHT TO HAVE
IDLE AND ORPHANED SO A THINK
THAT THERE'S A LOT FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT. AND I AM GLAD TO
HEAR. THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT-
APPROACH IS BEING CONSIDERED-
IN TERMS OF WHAT E CAN DO TO
ENSURE THAT THE TAXPAYERS ON
THE HOOK FOR THIS. SO IT IT
STRETCHING OVER I'M A JUST WANT
TO ASK. MISTER LIKE COULD BE IF
YOU CAN JUST- TALK YOU MENTION
A COST NINE POINT TWO MILLION
TO CLEAN UP THAT'S- AND THAT
THIS WAS BILL WAS OVER ONE ACRE
pOF THAT TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES AND THAT YOU HAVE AND
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE BUT WHAT
A CHEVRON AND DOING DIFFERENTLY
NOW TO THINK ABOUT THIS THAT IS
A LOT OF MONEY TO CLEAN UP ONE
ACRE WHEN YOU HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND. AND THIS IS ONE
IDYLLWILD WHAT'S BEEN DONE
DIFFERENTLY SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS TO PREVENT THIS
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN THAT
THAT'S THE- PRIMARY OBJECTIVE
THERE AND SO WHAT WE DOING TO
DRIVE THAT WE ARE MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH REGARDS TO THE
REVIEWS THAT WE'RE DOING ON ALL
OF OUR WELLS- WE HAVE NOW
REVIEWED- ELEVEN. ELEVEN
HUNDRED- IDA WELLS INCLUDING
SOME THAT HAVE BEEN ABANDONED
ALREADY AND OUR STUDY IN THOSE
VERY CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS- NO CHANCE FOR A
NOTHER LEAGUE PATH TO GET TO
THE SURFACE OF THE OF THIS
ANALYSIS- WE ARE MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH REGARDS TO THE-
MONITORING OF THE FIELD I
DESCRIBED TO YOU BEFORE ON THE
GROUND- MOVEMENT MONITORING.
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE- WE ARE
CONTINUING TO TIGHTEN UP THE
FREQUENCY AT WHICH WE DO THAT
THE EVALUATION TIME- HOW WE
PROCESS THE DATA SO THAT WE ARE
MORE RESPONSIVE ON
UNDERSTANDING EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS MONITOR EXACTLY WHEN
WE CAN. AT A L. IT'S IN TECH SO
THAT ONCE AGAIN WE CAN A IN AND
IT A BAN THAT RIGHT AWAY SO
DOES NOT BECOME A LEAGUE. AND
OR LEAD TO A SEAT. OKAY THANK
YOU AND- THE YOU KNOW I THINK
IT'S BEEN RECOGNIZED. BY MY
COLLEAGUES THAT- ONE OF THE
REASON THAT WE'RE HERE IN PART
IS BECAUSE THIS IS CHEVRON AND
YOU'RE ONE OF THE BIGGEST-
COMPANIES HERE IN OUR STATE-
BUT IT ALSO MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
A CAPACITY TO DO SOME THINGS
THAT. OTHER COMPANIES DON'T
HAVE- THE CAPACITY TO DO SO
WHEN WE HEAR THAT- THAT EVEN A
COMPANY AS BIG AS YOU THAT HAS
I MEAN PERSON NOW THE HAS
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCED STUDIES AND
RESEARCH- YOU HAVE THE A BIT.
EVEN YOUR STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP
WITH- ONE WELL THAT YOU KNOW
HAS LEAKED. HOW I MEAN HOW DO
WE ALIGN THAT WITH WITH THE
IDEA THAT WE I MEAN WE STILL
HAVE CONCERNS- YOU'RE A BIG
COMPANY YOU CAN DO IT SOME
WOULD SAY THAT IF CHEVRON CAN'T
DO IT THEN THAT MEANS WE REALLY
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
EVERYBODY ELSE AS WELL. I MEAN.
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THAT HOW
DO YOU HOW CAN YOU HELP US
THINK ABOUT THIS THIS ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH. WE
CAN OPERATE THIS SAFELY WE HAVE
BEEN DOING SO FOR MANY YEARS
AND WE CAN DO SO FOR MANY YEARS
TO COME IT'S A MATTER OF ONCE
AGAIN- STAYING- CONSISTENT
WITH- SOLID- PRACTICES TAKEN
LESSONS LEARNED FROM. EVENTS
LIKE WHAT WE JUST HAD AN
IMPROVING WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
GOING FORWARD IN THE FUTURE. SO
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU JUST HAVE
TO STAY CONSISTENT WITH THAT
PIECE OF IT AND ONCE AGAIN-
MITIGATE- THOSE THINGS OUT
THERE THAT CAN LEAD TO
POSSIBILITIES- OF SEEPS- AND
OUR OTHER- FAILURES. SO WHEN
WE- ARE LOOKING AT PARTICULAR
AT THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION-
THERE WAS. A IN ANNOUNCEMENT ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS THAT THE
RELEASE WAS STOPPED- ONLY TO
SEE IT RESTART- OVER AND THAT.
WE START TO. KIND OF LOSE
CONFIDENCE AND SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT IS HAPPENING FROM. YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE IS HAPPENING TO
ENSURE THAT IT WHEN WE GET AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IT STOPPED
THE RELEASE A STOP TO- THAT WE
DON'T SEE IT- CONTINUE. TO
RESTORE OVER AND OVER SURE NO
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND-
WHAT YOU WERE SEEING AT THAT
PARTICULAR POINT WAS THE- AT
THAT POINT WE WERE NOT AT
EQUILIBRIUM IN THAT WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO MANAGE THE SUBSIDENCE
BECAUSE WE HAD A STEAM BLOCK
THAT WAS IN PLACE. SO I STILL
HAVE MY SAME CONDITIONS DOWN
HOLE I DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MANAGE MY SUBSIDENCE- BUT
BECAUSE OF THE STEAM BLOCK
THAT'S THERE I CAN'T INJECT
ANYTHING INTO IT- AND SO
THERE'S A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
THAT GOES WHERE YOU'RE STILL
CONTINUE AND SEE THE
SUBSIDENCE. AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
SQUEEZING A BALLOON OR THROUGH
THE TOOTHPASTE- YOU'RE SINKING
DOWN RIGHT HERE YOU'RE MOVING-
FLUIDS- TO THE OUTSIDES OF IT
WHICH LED TO ADDITIONAL SEEPS
SITES. AND THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
DEALING WITH- WAY SOON AS WE
HAD THE ABILITY TO START
INTRODUCING WATER AS OPPOSED TO
STEAM- WHERE THE WHERE WE WERE
ABLE TO START REPLACING THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO MANAGE THE
SUBSIDENCE- AND ONCE AGAIN WE
SAW MORE EQUILIBRIUM TAKE PLACE
AND THAT THESE ADDITIONAL SEEPS
SITES STOPPED. TO THE POINT
THAT RIGHT NOW WE ONLY HAVE ONE
THAT IS ACTIVE AND THE ONE Y.
HAS NOT HAD ANY SLEEP SITES FOR
SOME MONTHS NOW. OKAY THANK YOU
AT A YOU KNOW OVERALL I THINK
THAT THIS IS BEEN. VERY
INFORMATIONAL AND I AND I DO
HOPE THAT WE- CONTINUE TO ASK
THESE QUESTIONS I FEEL LIKE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND- WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE- THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
NUMBER OF IDLE AND OR PHÃN.
WELLS IS SO GREAT THAT I JUST
KEEP THINKING WHAT HAPPENS IF
THERE ARE MULTIPLE- WELLS THAT
REQUIRED THIS MUCH INTENSITY
THAT RIGHT BACK. YOU KNOW
RELEASE AT SERVICE EXPRESS TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY- I DO KNOW
WHY WE GO THE RE AND HAPPENS
PARTICULARLY WITH THE- USERS OF
DIFFERENT SIZES- THIS IS
CHEVRON BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PRODUCERS DIFFERENT SIZES WITH
DIFFERENT- CAPACITIES I HAD TO
DO PERHAPS NOT IDEAL OR NOT NOT
THE SAME- BUT A DIFFERENT
AMOUNT. OF YOU KNOW OF
INTERVENTION TO TRY TO. REMEDY
THE PROBLEM- SO I HOPE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THAT- I A DEFINITELY IT'S- A
BIG CONCERN FOR ME- THAT HAS-
THAT CONVERSATION CONTINUES
AND- I AM. YOU KNOW HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT WERE ALSO- GOING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT. ON AND YOU
KNOW- IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITIES
AND- I THINK I'VE HEARD BY BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND- CHEVRON
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCIENCE SCIENCE AND DATA AND I
HOPE THAT WE ACCEPT THE SCIENCE
AND DATA- OF ALLYOU KNOW ALL
THAT IS OUT THERE I THINK THE
C. C. S. T. SUMMARY IS. PRETTY
DATA AND RICH- AND THAT TELLS A
LOT OF WHAT'S LEFT TO DO SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBER UNLESS THERE'S ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. WE APPRECIATE
YOU ALL COMING TO TESTIFY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANEL
BEFORE TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT.
SHE HAD IT THANK YOU- SO NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO CALL UP. MISS
CATHERINE RIOS BOARD WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATIONAS WELL AS INGRID
BROS FROM WHO I BELIEVE IS WITH
THE CENTER FOR- THE COMMITTED
OUT THERE. YEAH SO. ASK YOU FOR
SOME OPENING COMMENTS AND I'M
SURE WE'LL HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
FOR YOU I DO APPRECIATE IT-
MYSTERIES BUT ONCE YOU START
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES. JERRY
STERN CHAIR FRIEDMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT REMAIN WITH
US. OUR CATTERY AS BOYD
PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION ON IS
WHAT'S BY. I'M SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN OUR INDUSTRY WHO SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHERE THE OLD STRAIGHT
ASSOCIATION IN THE UNITED
STATES AND WE REPRESENT BOTH
OIL PRODUCERS AND REFINERS ON
THE WEST COAST- AND WE- WORK TO
ENSURE A RELIABLE. ACCESS TO
PATROLMAN PETROLEUM PRODUCTS
THROUGH POLICIES THAT ARE
SOCIALLY ENVIRONMENTALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY RESPONSIBLE. WE
THINK IT'S REALLY ANSWER
ESSENTIAL THAT THE ABUNDANT
SUPPLIES OF AFFORDABLE
PETROLEUM BASED TRANSPORTATION
FUELS AND OTHER VITAL PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS WHICH WE ALL ENJOY
WOULD BE SITTING HERE WITHOUT
THEM THAT THEY REMAIN AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC AS WE CONTINUE
THESE DISCUSSIONS AND I'LL GET
INTO A LITTLE BIT OF THE
DETAILS AS TO WHAT. THE
LIVELIHOODS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AND THE ECONOMIC WELL
BEINGS OF MILLIONS MORE REALLY
DEPEND ON A VIABLE AND GAS
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE. FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE AS WE- GO
FORWARD WHERE STATE LEADERS AND
UTILITY PROVIDERS AT TIMES
WRESTLE WITH POWER IN
SECURITIES OIL AND NATURAL GAS
REMAIN A FOUNDATION ENERGY
RESOURCE FOR THE STATE. THAT WE
CAN RELY ON WHEN THE
ELECTRICITY GRID GOES BACK DARK
AND AIDS AND OBVIOUSLY
EMERGENCY AND VITAL SERVICES
FOR CALIFORNIA. WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF COLLABORATION.
AND WE STRIVE TO MEET THE A BIT
BUT VICIOUS GOALS OF THE STATE.
I WANT TO POINT TO A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF THAT ONE BEING SB
THREE NINETY EIGHT OBVIOUSLY
THE CAPITA RATE PROGRAM WHICH
WE SUPPORTED.ITS COMPANION
BILL SB SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH I
THINK IS ONE OF THE MOST
REMARKABLE THINGS THAT THE
STATE OF DONE TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES. AS BEFORE WHICH IS
OF COURSE THE WELL STIMULATION-
REGULATION SB EIGHTY THREE
WHICH IS THE U. I. C.
REGULATION SB EIGHTY THREE ALL
BLOG TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW. AND
I'VE BEEN HONORED AND APPOINTED
BY THE STATE TO SERVE ON MANY
OF THESE BROAD AND DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THAT WORK
TOGETHER TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDES. SB
EIGHTY THREE AND A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN. AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE RESOURCES AGENCY AND
CAL JAM ON NOT ONLY ALL THE AYE
ITEMS IDENTIFIED IN THE PRESS
RELEASE BUT ALSO MANY OF THE
OTHER EFFORTS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN CONTINUAL
IMPROVEMENT. ALSO IF YOU SIZE
IN THEM IN A MOMENT BUT THERE
IS REALLY NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT TO US I THINK AS
YOU'VE HEARD IS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE WOMEN AND MEN OF OUR
INDUSTRY WORK. AND LIVE AND
RAISE THEIR FAMILIES SO WE'RE
PROUD TO BE GOOD NEIGHBORS WERE
PROUD TO SUPPORT OUR STATE'S
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE. AND WE
PRODUCE PROBABLY THE MOST
CLEANEST. OF AFFORDABLE ENERGY.
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND YOU
ARE ALL LEADERS IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN. CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS DO
LEAD THE WORLD AND THE FURTHER
STUDY OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
BEST SCIENCE REAL DATA ABOUT
PRODUCTION PRACTICES IN OUR
STATE WILL REALLY ONLY
RECONFIRM THIS LEADERSHIP THAT
YOU ALL HAVE AND WE'LL HAVE YOU
HEARD SECRETARY CROWFOOT
MENTION THE IMPORTANCE OF
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. SCIENCE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AN ECONOMY WE
SUPPORT THOSE GOALS AS WELL.
BUT WE CAN'T IGNORE THE FRAME
WORK WHICH WE ALL LIVE IN I
KNOW YOU DON'T IGNORE THE
FRAMEWORK IN WHICH WE ALL LIVE
SO WHY WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ALL THESE PERMANENT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY. ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIAS STILL STRUGGLE TO
AFFORD NECESSITIES. THE AVERAGE
FAMILY TO WORKING PARENTS SPENT
25% OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
AND UTILITIES THE AVERAGE TWO
BEDROOM IS 55% HIGHER IN
CALIFORNIA THAN THE NATION AND
ENERGY COSTS ARE A MAJOR FACTOR
OF THAT. SO AT THE SAME TIME-
THE OIL INDUSTRY IS IN A
POSITION. IN A AND FRANKLY A
DIRE POSITION BECAUSE THE
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY AROUND
ISSUING PERMITS OF COURSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS. AND
THESE POLICY CHANGES AND THE
OIL INDUSTRY'S.REACTION TO
THEM AND THE DELAYS IN
SACRAMENTO DO LEAD TO REAL LIFE
IN PACKS AFFORDABILITY LOST
JOBS. LOCAL TAX BENEFITS ENDING.
I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
WE PRODUCE IN THE TOUGHEST
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
INCLUDING LABOR HEALTH SAFETY
STANDARDS IN THE WORLD IN
CALIFORNIA BARNUM. SO EFFORTS
TO LIMIT ELIMINATE OR
DRAMATICALLY KERR PRODUCTION.
DOES NOTHING TO ELIMINATE
DEMAND. AND ONLY HURTS OUR
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DECREASES
OUR ENERGY INDEPENDENCE BY
ENCOURAGING MORE IMPORTS FROM
AREAS WITH LESS STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL RAKES. SO JUST
PUT UP ONE QUICK SLIDE HERE. SO
THE ENERGY DEMANDS OF THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
AS YOU ALL KNOW CONTINUE TO
GROW WE ARE THE THIRD LARGEST
CONSUMER OF TRANSPORTATION
FUELS ON THE PLANET. AS A STATE.
WITH ONLY CHINA AND THE U. S.
IN FRONT OF US NINETY PART 6%
OF ALL TRANSPORTATION FUELS IN
THE STATE COMES FROM PATROLLING.
I ONLY KNOW THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS THE CONTEXT IN WHICH WERE
HAVING THE CONVERSATION OF
WHERE WE GO IN THE FUTURE.
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE. SOON TO
BE FIFTEEN PEOPLE NOT TO NEARLY
FOR FUTURE DRIVE THIRTY MILLION
VEHICLES. EVERY DAY. NOW IT'S
GREAT WE HAVE ALMOST SEVEN HER
THOUSAND LECTURED VEHICLES
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FAILED GET INTO
DETAILS ON OUR COMPANIES
INVESTING AND- MANY ELEMENTS OF
THEM. AND WE HAVE AGGRESSIVE
GOALS OF FIVE MILLION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BY TWENTY THIRTY. BUT
FIVE MILLION LIKE TRICKLES WE
HAVE THIRTY MILLION TURNER
PROFESSION ENGINES IT'S A BIT
OF A GAP IT'S GOING TO TAKE
AWHILE. SO ONE THING WELL KNOWN
I SAY THIS OFTEN IS EVERYDAY.
WE'LL WAKE UP HOPEFULLY. WE
EXPECT THREE THINGS WE TURN OUR
LIGHTS ON WE HEAT AND COOL OUR
HOMES AND WE DRIVE FROM A TO B.
THAT'S EVERYDAY THAT'S A BIG
TASK. WHILE WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SOME OF THESE
AGGRESSIVE GOALS. AND HOW THE
STATE GOES ABOUT THAT IS SUPER
IMPORTANT I DON'T NEED TO TELL
YOU THAT. BUT GOVERNOR NEWSOME
STATED ALSO AND I THINK YOU
HEARD FROM SECRETARY CROWFOOT.
THE TRANSITION CANNOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT IT MUST ADVANCE IN A
DELIBERATE WAY. TO PROTECT
PEOPLE ARE VARMINT AND OUR
ECONOMY. SO THE THIRD ONE IS WE
CONSUME DAILY JUST PUT IN A
CONTEXT AGAIN FORTY TWO MILLION
GALLONS OF GASOLINE EIGHT POINT
FOUR MILLION GALLONS OF DIESEL.
CORD WITH JET FUEL- AND
CALIFORNIA DRIVE THREE HUNDRED
BILLION MILES HERE. AND THAT TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS OUR
HIGHEST LEVEL CONSUMPTION BUT
HISTORICALLY CONSUMPTION
INCREASES WITH IMPROVED ECONOMY.
I'LL GET INTO A LITTLE BIT OF.
WEEK WEEK AS CALIFORNIANS
CONSUME ALL THE OIL WE PRODUCE
IN THE STATE SALADA GALLONS A
DAY PROCESS BY CALIFORNIA
REFINERS SO WE CONSUME EVERY
BIT OF IT. BUT IT'S ONLY 30% OF
WHAT WE MAKE. AND WE KNOW AND
YOU'VE HEARD 70% OF IT COMES
FROM. OTHER PLACES TO MEET OUR
ENERGY TO MASS NOW I'D LIKE TO
FLIP THOSE NUMBERS. I'D REALLY
LIKE TO PRODUCE 70% HERE AND
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON OIL ON
FOREIGN ORAL. SO BUT THIS IS
THE NUMBERS WE HAVE TODAY. SO
TO YOUR POINT YOUR QUESTION
EARLIER WHERE DO THESE SOURCES
OF CRUDE OIL COME FROM THERE'S
A CHART SO THESE FOREIGN
COUNTRIES SAUDI ARABIA ECUADOR
COLOMBIA A ROCK. AS YOU ALL
KNOW THAT DON'T POLITE THEY
DON'T APPLY CALIFORNIA SAFETY
HUMAN RIGHTS LABOR ENVIRONMENT
RAKES. WE HEARD EARLIER WE ARE
PART OF THE BIGGER PICTURE AND
THIS DOES NEED TO BE PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION AS WE GO
FORWARD. HERE'S JUST SOME OF
THE IMPACTS ON WHAT IS THE WHAT
ANY KIND OF STATEWIDE BAN WOULD
DO. AND IT REALLY HAPPENS
WHETHER IT'S BàN OR NOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT ISSUED
PERMITS IT REALLY ACTS AS A
BAND. SO IT WOULD BE A LOSS OF
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION TAX
REVENUES TO SCHOOLS PUBLIC
SAFETY LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AS YOU
HEARD FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND. JOBS
NOT JUST JOBS CAREERS. THESE
ARE THESE ARE HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS THAT YOU HAVE YOU
HEARD PREVIOUSLY. AND THERE
DIVERSE CAREERS FROM ALL
SPECTRUMS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATIONS ALL THE
WAY UP. TO OBVIOUSLY MASTER'S
PROGRAMS WITH BENEFITS
RETIREMENT PLANS THAT NOT ONLY
ARE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
OUR INDUSTRY BUT ALSO FOR.
THEIR FUTURE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
I'M HAPPY AS PROVIDE TO THE
COMMITEE A REPORT CAPITAL
MATRIX JUST COMPLETED EXCUSE ME.
IT'S LIKE. AND WE CAN GIVE YOU
THIS REPORT IT'S THE IMPACT OF
STATEWIDE OIL PRODUCTION BAN ON
DOWNSTREAM PATROL PETROLEUM
MARKETS AND IT ESTIMATED-
DEPENDING ON THE TIME PERIOD
WE'R TALKING ABOUT INCREASED
GAS PRICES FROM SIXTY CENTS TO
TWO DOLLARS AND THIRTY THREE
CENTS A GALLON. SO PROPONENTS
OF BANDS WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
100% DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN
SOURCES AND I WANT TO NOTE THAT
EVEN. THAT ENVIRONMENTALLY
COSTLY APPROACH IF WE WERE TO
DO IT WOULD NOT WORK. SORRY THE
REASON BEING THAT OUR STATE IS
AN ENERGY ISLAND I THINK YOU
KNOW WE HAVE NO PIPELINES TO
BRING CRUDE OIL INTO THE STATE
SO IT ALL COMES IN BY MARIN
TANKER. WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPORT CAPACITY
TO EVEN BEGIN TO IMPORT A 100%
OF OUR ENERGY AS WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. SO SINCE THE BAN
WON'T REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S
DEMAND FOR ENERGY WITHOUT A
MASSIVE INCREASE IN IMPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE IT WOULD LIMIT
COMMUTE. CONSUMER ACCESS TO
FUEL AND IT REALLY RESULT IN
HIGHER ENERGY COSTS. WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE TODAY
HERE'S YOUR TYPICAL GAS PUMP.
BEEN IN NO WAY ARE WE
SUGGESTING THAT THESE PROGRAMS
AREN'T MERITORIOUS. I'M ONLY
SUGGESTING THEY HAVE COST AND
AFFORDABILITY IMPACTS ON
CONSUMERS. CERTAINLY THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM YOU'RE SEEING
THESE ARE TRACKED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION-
IS EIGHTEEN POINT FOUR CENTS A
GALLON YOU SEE LOW CARBON FUEL
CENTER CREEPING UP OVER TIME.
AT EIGHTEEN POINT THREE CENT OF
COURSE THE HIGHEST- STATE TAXES
ON THE TOP AND FEDERAL TAXES
AND THEN OTHER- OTHER STATE AND
LOCAL SALES TAXES AND THEN THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
BECAUSE SO BEFORE WE EVEN. GET
ANY CRUDE OIL AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH IT TO
MAKE IT INTO A VALUABLE
PRODUCT. WHERE THE BUCK EIGHT.
SO THAT TELLS YOU. JUST
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT AS WE
GO FORWARD IN THESE PROGRAMS
FROM AFFORDABILITY STANDPOINT.
THERE ARE. IMPLICATIONS TO
CONSUMERS FROM THAT AND WE JUST
NEED TO KEEP THAT IN MIND. SO
IN CLOSING- I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT WE REMAIN COMMITTED
TO THE PROGRESS THAT COMES WITH
COLLABORATION INNOVATION AND
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS THIRTY SIX
YEARS NOW. I HAVE BEEN AROUND
SINCE NINETEEN OH SEVEN WHEN WE
STARTED BUT I'VE BEEN DOING IT
THIRTY SIX YEARS- AND I'VE GOT
TO TELL YOU THE IS THE MOST
INNOVATIVE. AMAZING CREATIVE
PEOPLE I HAVE EVER HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING FOR. IT'S
A VERY EXCITING TIME BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN AT ALL. THEY'RE IN
OF COURSE MAKING TRADITIONAL
CONVENTIONAL FEEL BETTER
CLEANER MORE EFFICIENT EVERYDAY
CLEANEST BURNING GASOLINE ON
THE PLANET I WAS BACK WHEN WE
REMOVE SO FRIDAY DIESEL SO BUT
OUR OUR- OUR WORLD UP TRICKLING
BURN CLEANER BURNING GASOLINE
RANKS WITH THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD. BUT THEY'RE IN AT ALL
THEY'RE IN IT FOR BIO FUELS YOU
HEARD IT WHEN THE SOLAR BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY. AND I ALWAYS SAY IF
NOT US THAN WHO. YOU CALLED ON
US TO BE INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE WE PLAN TO DO EXACTLY
THAT. BECAUSE IT'S ALL OF THE
ABOVE AND WERE IN AT ALL.
INCLUDING WHAT WE DO EACH AND
EVERY DAY TO KEEP THE STATE
MOVING WHILE WE FIGURE THIS ALL
OUT. AND CAN YOU IMAGINE
PRODUCING CRUDE OIL AND A
CARBON NEGATIVE WAY. BECAUSE WE
CAN. WE CAN IMAGINE IT. WE LOOK
TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE AND
THINGS LIKE CCS I THINK WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CCS
PREVIOUSLY VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS- ON THURSDAY OF THIS WEEK
LARGE LVER NATIONAL LABS WILL
BE. DOING A PRESS CONFERENCE IN
THE CAPITOL ON THEIR REPORT ON
CC YES AND THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA GIVEN ITS WONDERFUL
GEOLOGY TO DO THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND IF THEY WILL ALSO KNOWN IN
THIS REPORT WE'VE HEARD IT
BEFORE FROM THEM IN PREVIOUS
REPORTS THAT WE CANNOT MEET OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS EVEN
WITH EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING
WITHOUT CCS PERIOD. I'M GONNA
DO. SO WE'RE ANXIOUS TO GET ON
WITH THAT CONVERSATION WHEN I
WAS FOR THE FIRST TIME A WHEN
GETS TRADE ASSOCIATION WAS ABLE
TO VISIT MADRID FOR COP TWENTY
FIVE SO I WAS PRIVILEGED TO DO
THAT. SPOKEN THREE PANELS ONE
OF THEM WAS CCS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO BRING THE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION TOGETHER IN MADRID
WITH EXPERTS TO TALK ABOUT
THAT. SO WE HAD SECRETARY
CROWFOOT SECRETARY CHAIRED
BLUMENFELD AND COMMISSIONER-
ANDREW MCALLISTER FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
DO FOR CCS I JUST WANNA PUT A-
CCS PLUG IN THERE BECAUSE I
KNOW THE INVITATION ASKED US TO
LOOK AT CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS
THIS IS GOING TO BE REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL. AND WHAT A
GREAT THING WE CAN ALL DO
TOGETHER AND WORK ON SOMETHING
CONSTRUCTIVE. SO WE UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF BALANCING THE
ENVIRONMENT THE ECONOMY. SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND THE RIGHT ENERGY
MIX. IT IS MY ASSERTION THAT NO
POLICY CAN BE SUSTAINABLE
WITHOUT ALL FOR. CAN'T HAVE ONE
OR TWO OR THREE YOU NEED ALL
FOUR SETS SO I LOOK AT POLICIES
AND JUDGE THEM. AND YOU KNOW IN
GOOD AND I HAVE HAD THE BENEFIT
OF- TESTIFYING TOGETHER BEFORE
AND I THINK- AT KERN COUNTY IS
HEARING I GOT TO GO AFTER ANGER
NOT SHE GETS GO AFTER ME SO.
WORSE FOR FLIP IN. BUT EVEN AT
THAT HEARING WE- THERE'S THINGS
WERE NOT GOING TO BRING ON. BUT
THERE'S ALSO THINGS WE ARE
GOING TO VERY ON AND I THINK
THOSE FOR TENANTS ARE PART OF
THAT. AND THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
A STRONG ECONOMY AND A STRONG
ENVIRONMENT AND DEAL WITH OUR-
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES AND AGAIN
SIX SEVENTEENS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM. AND THEN WHAT IS THAT
ENERGY MIX REALLY LOOK LIKE AS
WE AS WE GO FORWARD SO. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE EVERYONE
DESERVES A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
AND WE MAY NOT SIR WE MAY NOT
SHARE SOMETIMES THE SAME
POLITICS BUT WE DO SHARE THE
SAME FUTURE. AND I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT OUR PLANET OUR
PEOPLE ARE PROSPERITY AND
FRANKLY OUR PROGRESS TOWARDS A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE DEPENDS ON
ALL FOUR OF THOSE. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME A SEAT
AT YOUR TABLE THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE ENDURANCE
EFFORT HERE TO. THIS PRESSURE.
YES THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
HERE THIS OF COURSE IS A
IMPORTANT TOPIC IN AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC FOR MY ORGANIZATION WHICH
IS THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY
THE ENVIRONMENT A WE ARE BASED
IN KERN COUNTY- AND YOU CAN'T
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF OIL AND GAS WITHOUT
ALSO BEING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
CURRENT I WE WORK DIRECTLY WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES ON AND WE'RE-
GETTING OUR DIRECTIVES FROM
THEM- SO IT IS THE RESIDENT OF
KERN COUNTY WHO LIVE IN THE
MIDST OF OIL AND GAS DRILLING-
WHO ARE SAYING THAT THIS IS A
PROBLEM. ON THAT THESE HAVE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND THIS IS WHAT
OUR ORGANIZATION NEEDS TO
PRIORITIZE AND THAT'S WHY I'M
SITTING HERE TODAY I'M I ALSO
HAVE A POWER POINT WHICH I WILL.
SHARE WITH YOU SO THE- THIS IS
A AT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PERSPECTIVE. ON TRANSITIONING
THE WORK FORCE ENVIRONMENT AND
ECONOMY. IN KERN COUNTY AND SO
I DO WANT TO START WITH SAYING
YES WE HAVE SHARED GOALS-
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LABOR FORCE
ON IN KERN COUNTY- WE WANT A
THRIVING A PROSPEROUS LOCAL
ECONOMY WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
KERN COUNTY DECIMATED. WE WANT
GOOD WELL PAYING AND SAFE JOBS.
ARE WE ALSO WANT HEALTHY PLACES
TO LIVE WORK PLAY AND PRAY. WE
WANT INVESTED AN INCREASE
INVESTMENT IN KERN COUNTY WHICH
HAS BEEN LEFT BEHIND AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS I'M AND
AGAIN I THINK YOU TALK TO OIL
AND GAS WORKERS THEY WOULD SAY
THE SAME THING SO WE ARE COMING
FROM A PLACE OF SHARED GOALS-
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE PROBABLY
DIFFERENT DIFFERENCE OF
OPINIONS ON HOW TO.GET THERE.
ARM ONE THING ONE PROMISE THAT
I'D LIKE TO START WITH. ARM IS
THAT AS WE FIGHT NOW TO PROTECT
THE STATUS SOME SECTORS ARE
FIGHTING TO PROTECT THE STATUS
QUO. AND KERN COUNTY- I WOULD
ARGUE AND SUBMIT THAT THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH-
KERN COUNTY IS A- FAIRLY NON
DIVERSE ECONOMY IT IS. VERY
DEPENDENT ON BOTH OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION ON AND CONVENTIONAL
AGRICULTURE. ON THIS AS YOU
KNOW DESPITE THE WEALTH OF
THESE RESOURCES IN KERN COUNTY-
YOU DO SEE VERY HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES- EVEN THOUGH
THE IT HAS BEEN REDUCE IT IS
STILL. ON THE NOT QUITE DOUBLE-
THE STATE AVERAGE. ARE YOU HAVE
HIGH RATES OF POVERTY- TWENTY
TWO PER. POINT 6% VERSUS THE
CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN PERCENT- AND
WE WOULD SUBMIT THAT- BECAUSE
THE ECONOMY IS SO HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON A NATURALLY
DECLINE IN OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY- THESE- THESE
STATUSES. CAN ONLY ARE AT RISK
OF GETTING MUCH WORSE AND WE
CAN ONLY. LOOK BACK TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHEN THE OIL AND GAS.
OIL PRICES DROPPED- AND WE SAW
A VERY LARGE IMPACTS TO THE
LOCAL ECONOMY- SO IT IS.
VULNERABLE TO THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY THE FUNCTION. THEIR.
SO THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING ARE
IN CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE SEEN A
56% DECLINE IN OIL GAS
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S IS ONLY EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE- I THINK THE
PROJECTIONS ARE ANOTHER 26% IN
THE NEXT DECADE. AND THESE
PROJECTIONS I BASED ON CURRENT
CONDITIONS THIS IS NOT ACCOUNT
FOR ANY REGULATORY OR
UNEXPECTED MARKET CHANGES SO WE
KNOW OF REGARDLESS OF THAT KERN
COUNTY AND CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO BE DECLINING IN ITS
PRODUCTION AND THAT HOUSE
IMPACTS ON ECONOMIES AND
WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS REGARDLESS. SO. WHY IS
THE OIL FILL OR PRODUCTION
DECLINING. FRANKLY THE FIELDS
ARE OLD AND THE OIL IS HEAVY.
I'M SO WHILE THERE'S A SHALE
OIL BOOMS IN OTHER PLACES LIKE
TEXAS LIKE NORTH DAKOTA-
CALIFORNIA COULD IS MORE
EXPENSIVE TO EXTRACT ACCRUED
WEIGHTS ARE COMPARABLE TO THE
TAR SANDS IN CANADA. SO IN
TERMS OF GETTING UP OUT OF THE
WATER WE DO NEED TO HAVE A
STEAM INJECTIONS IN ORDER TO
EAT IT UP OTHERWISE THE
CONSISTENCY IS MORE LIKE PEANUT
BUTTER ON SO WHEN YOU COMPARE
THAT TO OTHER AREAS ARE THERE
IS A RELATIVE DISINCENTIVE I'M
AND LESS PROFITABILITY FOR THE
OIL AND GAS COMPANIES. TO DRILL
HERE. IT ALSO MEANS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CREEK CALIFORNIA'S
CRUDE IS SOME OF THE MOST
HIGHLY IMPACTFUL TO CLIMATE UP
COMPARED TO UP FEELS FOUND
OTHER OTHER PLACES. SO KERN IS
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
PRODUCTION DECLINED REGARDLESS
OF ANY OTHER FACTORS THERE'S NO
CHANGING THE AGE OF THE FIELDS
AND THERE'S NO CHANGING THE
QUALITY OF OUR CREATED. SO WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN FOR KERN'S WORK
FORCE. WELL HERE THIS IS THAT
THESE ARE NUMBERS TO FROM A
RECENT WITH BY REPORT ON.
SHOWING THE ACTUAL AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTION JOBS BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
HAVE SOME SHARED UNDERSTANDINGS
OF THE JOBS THAT ARE AT STAKE
AND I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
ELEVATED FIGURES. ARE COMING
OUT AND SO I DECIDED TO TAKE
WAS WAS NUMBERS- I THINK
THERE'S PROBABLY EVEN SOME MORE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THESE NUMBERS.
ALSO HERE AGAIN WE SEE WHAT THE
NATURAL DECLINE IN OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION WE ARE GOING TO SEE.
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF JOBS
AVAILABLE. ON SO THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING. I'M I WILL SAY THAT
A LOT OF THE JOBS FIGURES THAT
WE SEE ON A COMING FOR THE OIL
GAS INDUSTRY ACCOUNT FOR RETAIL
GESTATION JOBS- AND I THINK AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
DIFFERENT REGULATORY PROCESSES.
WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MANAGE DECLINE. TOM SO WE
ALREADY NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS SOME LEVEL OF JOB
REPLACEMENT FOR KERN COUNTY
AGAIN REGARDLESS OF ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL FACTORS. SO THIS IS
THE OF COMPASS A GRAPH OF A
COMPOSITION OF THE AGE AND I
THINK THIS IS REALLY TELLING ON
THIS ACTUALLY FOUR COLUMNS
HERE. THE FIRST COLUMN IS A
TINY BLUE FLAVOR WHICH
REPRESENTS WORK- WORKERS JUST
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE. AT
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO. SO
WECAN SEE THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING NEW YOUNG WORKERS
ENTERING INTO THE FIELD- AND
CONVERSELY WE CAN SEE THAT OVER
77% OF THE WORK FORCE IS OVER
THIRTY FIVE AND OVER QUARTER IS
OVER FIFTY FIVE SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY VERY GOOD NEWS FOR
KERN COUNTY- AS- A SIZEABLE
PERCENT OF THE WORK FORCE-
WILL. THE SORRY THE WORKFORCE I
TRANSITION NEEDS CAN BE OFFSET
BY THE OLDER WORKERS LEAVING
THE WORK FORCE OVERTIME. THIS
IS JUST ANOTHER GRAPH SHOWING
THE SAME THING BUT SHOWING THAT
THIS TRAJECTORY. HAS HAS BEEN
INCREASING OVER THE TIME SO AS
THE YEARS GO BY WE HAVE FEWER
AND FEWER YOUNG PERSON PEOPLE
ENTERING THE FIELD AND WE SEE
HIGHER AND HIGHER PERCENTAGES
OF OLDER WORKERS SO IN TERMS OF
THE ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE. WE AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE GOOD JOBS-
HOWEVER- IN TERMS OF HOW
PAINFUL THAT IS GOING TO BE FOR
CURRENT I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE SOME DISAGREEMENTS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT. THE COST OF
LOSING OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
WE NEED TO COMPARE THAT TO THE
HEALTH COSTS THAT WE HAVE NOW
WITH THE CURRENT PRODUCTION
RATES ARE SO HERE'S JUST A
QUICK. A GRAPH ON THIS JUST
SHOWS OF THE DIFFERENCE IN
CHRONIC LOWER RESPIRATORY
DISEASE DEATH IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE CAN SEE KERN COUNTY JUST
ASTRONOMICALLY ABOVE ANY OTHER
COUNTY OF THESE ILLNESSES
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE OUT SOME
THERE IS A AMAZING STATISTIC
THAT ONE OUT OF EVERY THIRTY
SEVEN PEOPLE IN CURRENT DIED
FROM CHRONIC RESPIRATORY
DISEASE BETWEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN. THIS IS
TWELVE TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
REST OF THE STATE- ASTHMA COSTS
KERN COUNTY NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND HEALTH CARE COSTS
AND LOST PRODUCTIVITY EVERY
YEAR AND RECENTLY WE JUST SAW
ANOTHER STUDY THAT CAME OUT
SHOWING THAT DIRTY AIR. COST
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY SO WE
NEED TO HAVE A HOLISTIC-
PICTURE OF THE COST OF OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION. I'M HERE SOME
QUICK FLY JUST SHOWING THE
RELATIVE- CONTRIBUTION OF OIL
AND GAS SO EVERYTHING YOU SEE
THERE A WITH THE RED STRIPES
THAT'S OIL AND GAS-
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS IS A
MEASUREMENT OF. A TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS OF OIL AND GAS
ACTIVITIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
BETWEEN THIRTY AND 60% OF TACK
EMISSIONS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. NOT THAT THAT LARGE ONE
IS FROM ALL THE HIDE FOR
EXAMPLE. OIL AND GAS FACILITIES
ARE ALSO THE LARGEST STATIONARY
SOURCES OF DIRECT PM TWO POINT
FIVE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
JUST FOR CORPORATIONS CHEVRON
AIR ENERGY BERRY PETROLEUM AND
PLANES. EXPLORATION ACCOUNT FOR
HALF. OF ALL PM TWO POINT FIVE
EMISSIONS FROM LARGE STATIONARY
SOURCES IN THE VALLEY. OF FOR
COMPARISON THIS IS MORE DIRECT
PM TWO POINT FIVE THAN IT IS
PRODUCED BY ALL PASSENGER
VEHICLES AND LIGHT AND MEDIUM
DUTY TRUCKS COMBINED. WE ALSO
NEED TO CONSIDER COST TO WATER.
ON THE IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
STATE WATER BOARD FOUND THAT
WATER SUPPLY WELLS IN KERN HAVE.
OIL INDUSTRY POLLUTANTS- IN
THEM. THERE'S ALSO BEEN RECENT
STUDIES SHOWING INCREASED
SALINITY. I DID A PRODUCED OUT
WASTEWATER DISPOSAL AND KERN
OIL FIELDS. IN ADDITION TO THE
WATER CONTAMINATION WE ALSO
HAVE- THE HIVE WATER USE- IN
CALIFORNIA. UP STUDIES DO LINK
APPROXIMATE OIL AND GAS WELLS
TO HOST OF HEALTH IMPACTS
INCLUDING INCREASE WITH OF
ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES PREMATURE DEATHS HIGH
RISK PREGNANCY AND CANCER- THE
CLOSER PEOPLE LIVE TO OIL AND
GAS WELLS THE MORE LIKELY THEY
WILL BE EXPOSED TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS LIKE WE JUST
DISCUSSED. ON AND THE MORE
ELEVATED THE RISK ASSOCIATED
HEALTH EFFECTS AND OF COURSE
CHILDREN- ARE THE MOST
SENSITIVE POPULATIONS I TO
THESE OIL AND GAS WELLS. SO WE
NEED A JUST TRANSITION. ARM WE
NEED THIS JUST TRANSITION TO BE
LED BY WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED. WE NEED
TO DO OF WHAT WORKERS NEED TO
FEEL WHOLE. ARM AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT BENEFITS ACCRUE
TO THE COMMUNITY SO I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF. MISTAKES
MISTAKES MADE IN TERMS OF THE
OF THE JUST TRANSITION
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WORKERS
HAVE NOT BEEN ENOUGH AT THE
TABLE MOM AND I THINK IT'S
GOTTEN A BAD RAP FRANKLY AT
THIS POINT AND SO I THINK WE
NEED TO RE BRAND JUST
TRANSITION AND DO IT RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE NEED TO
START IN KERN COUNTY- AND I
THINK THAT STARTS WITH LET'S
TALK TO LABOR AND THAT HAVE THE
BE CENTRAL AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THERE IN
TERMS OF WHAT DO THEY NEED. TO
FEEL LIKE THEY ARE OKAY-
TRANSITIONING TO A NEW JOB AND
A AND A- THE NEW ECONOMY. I IN
KERN COUNTY THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE ON THE
HORIZON FOR ONE WE SEE A
YOUNGER DEMOGRAPHIC AS- HOUSING
PRICES RISE ACROSS THE STATE
WERE SEEN YOUNG PEOPLE RETURN
AFTER COLLEGE WHICH WASN'T
DIDN'T USED TO BE THE CASE SO
HAVING MORE YOUNG AT COLLEGE
EDUCATED OF PEOPLE MOVING IN WE
SING A REVITALIZATION OF
DOWNTOWN WE'RE SEEING HOTEL
GROWTH- OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY A BIT WISE
IS A FLEDGLING TECH COMPANY-
THERE'S ONE IN FRESNO NOW
THERE'S ONE IN BAKERSFIELD- SO
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN KERN COUNTY- WE ALSO
HAVE WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
ABANDONED. AND ORPHANED WELLS
THERE IS A BIG OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SOIL REMEDIATION AND CLEAN
UP WELL ABANDONMENT AND
PLUGGING ON AS WELL AS- WE NEED
TO LOOK AT PROPERTY TAXES ON
NEWLY EMERGING SECTORS. SO JUST
TO. UP FINISH UP WE NEED TO
CREATE A JUST TRANSITION AND
KERN COUNTY. AND WE NEED TO
DEDICATE SIGNIFICANT STATE
FUNDS- TO HELP RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES- AND WE NEED TO
DO AN ANALYSIS. OF THE ASSETS
IN OPPORTUNITIES TO DIVERSIFY
THE ECONOMY- THE TAKE AWAY AS
THE TRANSITION AWAY FROM OIL
AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA IS
INEVITABLE. AND IF WE DON'T
PLAN FOR IT AND IT'S NOT
MANAGED KERN COUNTY IS GOING TO
BE LEFT BEHIND AND THE ECONOMY
IS GOING TO BE DECIMATED- RIGHT
NOW I THINK KERN COUNTY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH THE
STATE TO BRING IT TO BRING IN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT ON AND
REALLY OPEN THE DOORS TO A
BETTER FUTURE FOR CAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS RESTAURANT.
MR WITH A COUPLE QUESTION ALL
RIGHT. SHE THE WORK YOU'VE BEEN
DOING OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND.
YEAH THE GRAVITY OF THE HEALTH
CHALLENGE AND- SO BRING
INFORMATION LIKE WISE ON. OUR
PATROLLING ADDICTION. I ALWAYS
USE YET THIRD LARGEST CONSUMER
OF PETROLEUM IN THE WORLD
ALTHOUGH. I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE MIGHT BE
DISPENSED TERMS OF
JURISDICTIONS OF. BUT WERE.
WE'RE WE'RE VERY DEEPLY.
EMBEDDED IN THIS PROBLEM- I
GUESS I HAD HAD LESS KIND OF
GLOBAL QUESTIONS FOR YOU BOTH
AND MUCH MORE SPECIFIC SO I
GUESS I'D START WITH MISS RIOS
BOYD MAIN. IN TERMS OF JUST.
MAKING CAL GEM A JAM TRULY
FUNCTIONAL AGENCY. SOME OF THE
BACKLOG ISSUES WE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY THEY GOT SIX REPORTS OUT
THIS LAST WEEK BUT. JUST HOW TO
ACTUALLY BUILD TRUST IN THE
COMMUNITY RIGHT AND- ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE SORT OF. WHEN IT GETS
REALLY INTIMATE. ARE YOU HAVE
YOU ALL LOOKED AT THEIR THEIR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL- AND
EFFORTS TO BEEF UP THE AGENCIES
SORT OF STAFFING CAPACITY AND-
YEAH HAVE YOU HAVE YOU TAKEN A
LOOK AT IT ARE YOU SUPPORTIVE
OF IT. HERE IS TO GET YOUR TAKE
ON- HOW TO GET YOU KNOW BEYOND
DOGGER AND REALLY GET THAT
AGENCY FUNCTIONAL WHICH SEEMS
BEYOND THIS SORT OF LARGER
QUESTION OF HOW THE FOSSIL FUEL
FUTURE GOES. INTO THERE'S
PRETTY COMMON INTEREST IN
HAVING A FUNCTIONAL AGENCY
THERE SO. COMMENTS ON THAT
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION YEAH-
AND YES WE CERTAINLY AND HAVE I
THINK YOU CAN LOOK IN OUR
HISTORY THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO INCREASE
RESOURCES CORRECT- AT THAT
APARTMENT SO I THINK WE DON'T
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT MAKING
SURE THAT THE AGENCY HAS THE
RESOURCES IT NEEDS. TO RE
ESTABLISH ITS CREDIBILITY AND
TO CONTINUE THIS ENERGY PATHWAY
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE FOR
THE PRODUCTION OF OUR CRUDE OIL
HERE LOCALLY. AND OUR ABILITY
TO REFINE IT SO- I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY ONE POINT THAT I THINK
WE PROBABLY DISAGREE ON. AND
THAT WOULD BE THAT IT IS
INEVITABLE THAT THE PRODUCTION
IN THE STATE IS DECLINING AND
SHOULD CONTINUE AND SHOULD GO
AWAY. THAT IS THE FARTHEST FROM
THE TRUTH WE ARE A VERY THE
RESERVES AND CURRENT COUNTY ARE
STILL AMONG THIS IS RESERVES IN
THE GROUND AND YOU CAN TALK TO
THE KERN COUNTY TAX ASSESSOR
WHO ASSESSES US ON. RESERVES IN
THE GROUND- IS THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION IT REMAINS TO BE. IF
YOU THIS PRODUCTION THE STATE
WERE IT IT RESPONDS REALLY WELL
TO INVESTMENT AND SO THE MORE
INVESTMENT THAT'S MADE IF YOU
CAN MAKE AN ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT. THE MORE OR WILL BE
PRODUCED IN THAT GRAPH WILL
TURN AROUND FROM WHAT IT
SHOWING. SO IT'S NOT THAT IT'S
A NATURAL DECLINE IS DECLINING
FOR SEVERAL REASONS ONE OF
WHICH IS IF YOU CAN'T INVEST
ECONOMICALLY. IT WILL CONTINUE
TO APPLY BUT IF YOU CAN IT
RESPONSE QUITE WELL TO IT AND
HAS FOR YOU KNOW A HUNDRED
YEARS. CUT BUT I DO. THAT YOU
SEE AND HAVE SEEN CONTINUAL
SUPPORT BY THIS INDUSTRY IN ALL
FACETS OF ALL THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT AND- LIKE I SAID
IM PERSONALLY INVESTED IN THE
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM- WHICH
AGAIN. HAVING COMMUNITIES STEP
TO THE PLATE AND TAKE
LEADERSHIP AS THEY HAVE IS JUST
AMAZING. AND TO HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO USE SCIENCE. TO PUT
MONITORS IN COMMUNITIES FIGURE
OUT WHERE THINGS ARE COMING
FROM AND THEN WHAT MITIGATION
PLANS WERE GOING TO DO TO
REDUCE SOME. THAT'S REMARKABLE.
ON AND- FOR THAT SO FOR THIS
TACK NUMBERS SHE GAVE IN THE PM
TWO POINT FIVE ANY DISPUTE WITH
THOSE NUMBER I COULD PUT UP AS
MANY SHOT SLIDE SHOWING THE
ABSOLUTE IMPROVEMENTS IN ALL OF
THOSE THAT THIS INDUSTRY IS
MADE OVER TIME IN THE GRASS
WOULD BE GOING. THIS WAY. SO I
GET OUT WE CAN HAVE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON THAT I THINK YOU
WOULD SEE- THE OTHER ONE IS THE
KERN COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE PROGRAM THAT THAT
THE THAT COUNTY PUT IN PLACE.
TO MITIGATE ALL MEASURES UP
FRONT FOR TWENTY YEARS OF
PRODUCTION. UNBELIEVABLE
REMARKABLE PROGRAM THAT KERN
COUNTY INITIATED WITH THE-
COOPERATION OF THE INDUSTRY-
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE'VE
DEMONSTRATED. IS COOPERATION IN
ALL OF THESE ASPECTS. LIKE I
SAID SB EIGHTY THREE IS WRITING
A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR REQUIRED BY A SPEEDY
THREE. BROAD BASED STAKEHOLDER
GROUP CLEAN WATER WATCH ENERGY
SEE EVERYBODY MYSELF- WRITING A
REPORT ON UNDERGROUND JUNCTION
CONTROL ARE THERE ANY GAPS ARE
WE MISSING ANYTHING. BECAUSE IF
WE ARE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO TO
PLUG THE- SAME KIND OF A THING
WITH THE OR FOR NOT A WELL
ISSUE. I CAN SINCE I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME I
CAN REMEMBER WHEN YOU ALL ASKED
US TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE ON
OR FOR NOT A WELL BILL. BILL
WHERE WE HAD WE DIDN'T HAVE WE
DIDN'T HAVE A FUND. AND WE
STEPPED UP PLACE TO PUT I THINK
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE COLLECTIVELY TO. HAVE
THAT FUND NOW WE NEED TO GROW
IT AND DEAL WITH ISSUE AND ALL
WERE REVIEWING THE CCS SUPPORT
IF YOU ALL ARE I HAVEN'T. CAN'T
SEPARATE YET BUT I WILL- AND SO
I THINK WHAT I'M TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE IS THAT THIS
INDUSTRY. WHAT STEP THE PLATE
ON ALL THESE ISSUES. HE AS YOU
VAST TO COME ON THE- TO. GOAL
WE REAL A- THERE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT I
THINK YOU HEARD FROM OUR MEMBER
IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL THAT.
WERE WERE ALL ABOUT STEPPING UP
THE PLATE FIGURING IT OUT AND I
WOULD SAY ON A WORK FORCE-
WE'RE VERY EXCITED OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE WITH
PEOPLE LIKE THE BUILDING TRADES
WHO WILL TAKE PEOPLE WITH VERY
LITTLE- TRAINING AND EDUCATION
PUT THEM THROUGH AN
APPRENTICESHIP. PROGRAM TRAIN
THEM AND PAY THEM THROUGH THAT
TRAINING AND WE'RE ABLE TO
OFFER JOBS WHEN THEY COME OUT
OF THAT APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM-
IMMEDIATELY SO. I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF EXCITING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES I WOULD SAY
AS FAR AS THE YOUNGER
GENERATION- WE HAVE A GROUP
CALLED THE YOUNG PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS INDUSTRY
I'VE HIRED RECENTLY. HI I'M I'M
THINK A QUARTER OF MY STEPS
MILLENNIALS NOW WHO ARE IN
COMMUNICATIONS WHO ARE IN
TECHNICAL ISSUES WHO ARE IN YOU
KNOW REGULATORY ISSUES WHO HAVE
EXPERTISE AND ENVIRONMENTAL. SO
I THINK THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO OFFER BROAD OPPORTUNITIES OF
EMPLOYMENT AS WE GO FORWARD AND
AS I'VE SAID WE DON'T NEED A
TRANSITION JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
TRANSITIONING RELATIVE TO THE
ENERGY MIX BECAUSE WERE ALREADY
IN IT. AND ALREADY USE IN OUR
WORK FORCE ON IT SO. I THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD JUST. BUT BUT IN
TERMS OF. THAT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY. MANTRA I GET
THAT. IT MAY IT MAY BE BETTER
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN IN YOUR
VIEW BUT NO NO. ACTUAL DISPUTE
ABOUT. STATIONARY SOURCE PM TWO
POINT FIVE CONTRIBUTION OR THE
TACK FRONT SO I MEAN THAT'S NO
I'M NOT I'M NOT HERE THAT FOR
YOU BUT- BUT IN TERMS OF THE
HEALTH COSTS. OF I'VE HEARD YOU
BRING UP SIX SEVENTEEN. SO
WORST WE'RE STRUGGLING STILL
WITH FUNDING THERE FRANKLY AND
WE'VE SEEN. POULTRY PROGRESS IN
MY VIEW- KERN COUNTY YES BUT- I
TO STATE WHY WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING AND EVERYONE HAS TO.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GET LUCKY TO
GET THE GRANTS AND HOPEFULLY
YOU GET SOME SENSE OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON YOUR NOSE
SO. MAYES INDUSTRY LOOKING AT
ANY CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO.
BEYOND EVEN OFFSETTING THE NET
HEALTH COSTS ACTUALLY JUST
HELPING US GET- A FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE THAT'S GONNA BE. FUNDED
AND DURABLE- I MEAN WE CAN KEEP
GOING BACK TO TAXPAYERS ARE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
BUT- IT'S FRUSTRATING HAVE TO
EVERY YEAR FIGHT FOR THAT POT I
MEAN ANY ANY THOUGHTS ON WELL
OTHER THAN WE CONTRIBUTE
MAJORLY TO THE GREENHOUSE SURE
YOU. RIGHT RIGHT LIKE A PART IN
IT ENDS UP GOING OTHER THINGS
AND THEY WERE AND WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON MITIGATION NOT JUST
STRICTLY MONITORING AND THERE
IT'S A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THERE'S TOO MANY REQUESTS
FOR RIGHT RIGHT SO I THINK
PRIORITIZING. HOW YOU SPEND
THAT MONEY I WOULD CHALLENGE US
ALL TO LOOK FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR SIX SEVENTEEN WHO
DID TEND COMMUNITIES LAST YEAR
WE'RE ONLY GONNA HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO DO THREE THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE YEAH SO ANGRY THAT
I MADE MY GREW WITH YOU. SO I
DO THINK WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD
ON THAT PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE FRANKLY WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE
ONLY DONE TEN. RIGHT RIGHT BUT
WHAT WAS WHAT WAS BRILLIANT IN
MY MIND ABOUT THAT PROGRAM IN
ALL OF YOU PASSING IT WAS THAT
IT REALLY IS A FOUNDATION OF
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING THIS
WHOLE HEARING WHICH IS. LET
SIGN DICTATE THE ANSWER RIGHT
WE ALL WE'RE ALL GOING INTO
THIS WITH WHAT WE IT MAY BE US
IT MIGHT NOT BE A- BUT IF IT IS
A STEP TO PLAY FOR TO DEAL WITH.
RIGHTS PUT THAT SIGN SIMPLE
MAKE COMMENTS WHAT WE DO SO
CANNOT HEALTH ISSUES THAT
COMMUNITIES ABOUT BILL. SO WE
KNOW WE WERE ABOUT AT NIGHT
DAMAGE THAT CONTINUED THE.
FIRST REMAIN AM. I WAS SIX
SEVEN IS JUST ONE TINY PIECE OF.
THE MORAL TO DEAL THIS GRAY
RIGHT BUT AT I AM AND FROM YOUR-
YOUR FOCUS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT- I MEAN IS THERE
PROGRESS WE CAN BE MAKING THIS
YEAR ON THAT MONITORING FRONT
DOOR ON ON DEALING WITH. NOT
HAVING IT IS A TAX THE GDR F.
ME HAVE YOU GUYS GIVEN ANY
THOUGHT TO WHAT. ACTUALLY HE
GETTING OUR COMMUNITIES
ADEQUATELY. YEAH MONITORS AT
THIS POINT WE YOU KNOW
MONITORING IS NOT THE ANSWER I
MEAN TIME TO COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES NO. YOU KNOW THEY
WANT TO SEE THEY WANT TO SEE
REDUCTIONS ARE- AND SO THE
OVERLY OVERLY FOCUS EMPHASIS ON
ON MODERATE MONITORING- WHEN
YOU KNOW YOU'RE JUST ADDING TO
THE POLLUTION BURDENS ISN'T
GOOD ENOUGH. ON AND SO WITHOUT
HAVING MANDATED REDUCTIONS I'M
A IN COMMUNITIES IT IT IT IT
IT'S REALLY TOO LITTLE TOO
LATE- SO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION WAS YOUR
ESTIMATE OF HEALTH CARE COSTS
WITHIN KERN COUNTY I THINK THAT
WAS A STUDY THAT YEAH AND THEN
YOU'D- THINK YOU GIVE TWENTY.
BILLION FOR AIR POLLUTION WRIT
LARGE WHICH IS ALSO MOBILE
SOURCES I'M SURE IF IT WAS THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION RELATED TO.
I OIL INDUSTRY OPERATIONS SO
THAT WAS FOUR MEASURE INTERNET.
HEALTH COSTS ON THE HEIRS HAYES
AND- YEAH WELL THAT WAS A THAT
WAS THE ESTIMATE FOR KERN
COUNTY- FOR THE AIR POLLUTION
BURDEN- I THINK WE WOULD SUBMIT
THAT OIL AND GAS. MAKES UP A
SIZEABLE PERCENT OF THAT BUT OF
COURSE YOUR HONOR THE ISSUES
WITH KERN COUNTY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. IS THERE'S A LOT OF
POLLUTION BURDENS CRACKED SO.
YEAH I WOULD LOVE TO SEE I
GUESS IN IN SUBSEQUENT MONTHS
IN IF WE CAN DO THE ANALYSIS ON
ON AND MAYBE IT ALREADY EXISTS
BUT THE ATTRIBUTION OF THAT
COST THAT HEALTH CARE COSTS ON
THE OIL SIDE AND WHAT DO YOU
RESPONSE REALLY REALLY LOOKS
LIKE AND- MAYBE PART OF ITS
MONITORING ANDPART OF ITS
MITIGATING AND- HOW THAT LOOKS.
TRY TO CHIP AWAY AT THAT SORT
OF WITH THE SCATTER SHOT
APPROACH. THAT SYMBOLIZED
ENCOURAGES TO INCLUDE
EVERYTHING IN THEM YEAH YOU
KNOW OF COURSE LIKE I MEAN HEY
WE'RE HESITANCY SHOES YOUR
NGUYEN HAS ITS ISSUES OF
COURSE. HOW LITHIUM IS DRYING
OR ELECTRIC VEHICLE- NAY MATTER
HE SAYS THERE ISSUES YEAH SO
IT'S NOT JUST. YOU KNOW ALL
ENERGY SOURCES HAVE THINGS TO
DEAL WITH IT'S A COMPLEX
PROBLEM SO LET'S JUST LOOK AT
IT IN ITS IN ITS ENTIRETY. B.
YES. THOUGHTS ON THE CARBON YOU
TRILOGY CONVERSATION IS BRUSH
FROM THAT BE MY LAST QUESTION
TO YOU HOW DO YOU LOOK AT THE
THAT STUDY THE AYE AYE POP UP I
MEAN I TUNE INTO SOME OF THE
HEARING BUT. LIKE YOU'RE SORT
OF UNSATISFIED WITH MONITORING
THIS CARBON NEUTRALITY DO YOU
SEEM LIKE THE RIGHT ALIGNING
GOAL OR OR YOU LOOKING AT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH WILL WORK
SAID ABOUT THE STUDY- WE ARE-
AND THAT YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE
LOOKING BOTH AT SUPPLY AND
DEMAND BECAUSE THAT REALLY IS
GOT TO BE PART OF. THE EQUATION
I'M WE OBVIOUSLY NEED TO RAMP
DOWN OUR DEMAND IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S NO DEBATE THERE- WE
ALSO NEED TO RAMP DOWN OUR
SUPPLIES SO I THINK- HAVING
THOSE STUDIES AND HAVING
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE INVOLVED IN
IN THE STUDIES I THINK IS
REALLY CRITICAL I'M MOST
PLEASED THAT THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOLKS AT THE STATE
ARE VERY INVOLVED IN IN IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE TO ME
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PIECES- IS THAT WE
MAKE SURE- YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE KIND OF A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO LOOKING AT THE WORK
FORCE- LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
RAMPING DOWN PRODUCTION IN A-
YOU KNOW. MEASURED AND
RESPONSIBLE WAY ON MAKING SURE
THAT NOBODY GETS LEFT OUT- SO
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE STATE- AND REVIEWING
THIS STUDY SO I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT IT REALLY IS NOT
MUCH MONEY IN THERE- AND IS A
BIG A BIG QUINCY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS THAT LAST YEAR
SOMEONE THREE MILLION YEAH FOR
BOTH FOR BOTH- SUCH A MASSIVE
PROMOTES A WRIT LARGE WE'RE
UNDER SHOOTING IT TERMS OF HOW
BRING ALL THIS WORK OUT- WE
WERE FINDING CAL JIM RIGHT NOW-
THE TREE SO THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR SICK SEVEN IN THIS OR ANY
QUITE TO GOT A- USE UP. WHAT
GOT A WRESTLE AT. AND ABOUT
THIS CLIMATE OF. EN GET OIL
MAJORS TO WAY UP A SERIES. A
CHALLENGE THEM I LIKE THERE'S
SOME. NEAR TERM OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE. STRANGELY
ALIGNED INTEREST HERE- THAT
SEEM LIKE WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD THIS
YEAR- YEAH I THINK OF LIKE I
WANT KERN COUNTY. TO HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AND- SOME POWER OVER
WHAT'S IMPACTING THEIR HEALTH
BUT- YOU KNOW. YOU DOCTOR WHERE
PEOPLE PRAY. I GO TO SYNAGOGUE
AND ON PICO IN LA WE GOT.
THINGS GO PACIFIC. COAST ENERGY
PRODUCERS DOUG MATT. TO SITES
RIGHT LA ALL THEY WANT IS A
MONITOR RIGHT AND YET THEY'RE
GONNA BE BACK A LINE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN LA AND THERE'S OTHER
PLACES. BUT THEN YOU GOT A
LEASE SO CAN YOU JUST SEEMS
LIKE A RAW DEAL FOR COMMUNITIES
ACTUALLY. WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
IMPACTING THEM BUT- WE
APPRECIATE- YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE- MA'AM VICE CHAIR THIS
THAT'S ALL- CHAIR I THAT'S ALL
I HAD FOR THEM. THANK I JUST
HAVE TO THINK QUICK QUESTION
THE FOR ONE FROM BOYD. HAVE YOU
BEEN GIVEN ANY TIMELINE FOR
WHEN THE AUDITS AND REVIEWS ARE
GOING TO BE COMPLETE AND I'M
JUST WONDERING BESIDES THE
SPECULATION AND THE UNCERTAINTY
WITH THE- NEW POLICIES FROM THE
FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION ARE
YOU SEEING ANY IMMEDIATE SORT
OF CONCRETE EFFECTS ON YOUR
MEMBERS YES THERE ARE SEVERAL
MEMBERS WHO HAVE HAD TO- EITHER
LAY DOWN A RIG OR- YOU KNOW.
HAVE LESS EMPLOYMENT AS A
RESULT OF SORT OF WAITING WE
HAVEN'T GOT ANY CLEAR FINAL.
PERIOD OF TIME WHEN WE'RE GOING
TO SEE THINGS FLOWING AGAIN SO-
VERY ANXIOUS. TO HEAR THAT FROM
THE STATE AS THEY COMPLETE
THEIR REVIEWS THROUGH LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABS I KNOW
THOSE ARE ON GOING IN THERE.
DETAILED AND THEY TAKE TIME BUT
WERE ANXIOUS TO GET THEM
COMPLETE I'M CONFINED CONFIDENT
THAT. THEY WILL SHOW WHAT THEY
ALWAYS SHOW WHICH WE DO SO I'VE
BEEN THROUGH EIGHT STUDIES NOW.
JUST TO NOTE THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HELP OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN
FOR MISS BROADS- BRUSHED HIM-
OF ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ADMIT-
NEW INITIATIVES FROM THE NEWS
MINISTRATION IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT RISES TO THE TOP TO YOU AS
SORT OF THE MOST EXCITING FOR
YOUR GROUP YES DEFINITELY THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY RULE MAKING-
PROCESS- AND ESPECIALLY THE
POSSIBILITY A LIKELIHOOD THAT.
A SET BACK BOB WILL BE INCLUDED
BECAUSE THAT IS THE TOP
PRIORITY THAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM RESIDENTS BOTH AND CURRENT
AND IN LA- THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANT TO SAY SO THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S MOST EXCITING TO US
RIGHT WELL I WANT TO THANK THE
TWO OF YOUR MEN. MISCELLANY SO
HAVE NO. RIGHT I WANT TO THANK
OF YOU FOR COMING AND I WANT TO
COMMEND STAFF FOR THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS HEARING BECAUSE I.
REALLY APPRECIATE- NOW THAT
WE'RE KIND OF TOWARDS THE END
WE STILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTARY. BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT WE STARTED WITH THE VERY
ASPIRATIONAL- AND VISION OF THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND THEN
WENT TO LOOKING AT ALMOST SORT
OF IN A SNAPSHOT IN TIME OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION AND HOW
THAT'S UNFOLDING. AND NOW WE
HAVE. TWO SPEAKERS WHO AT THE
SAME TIME WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES BOTH OF
CONTINUING. OIL AND GAS
EXPLORATION. AND THE CHALLENGES
OF TRYING TO RAMP DOWN ON OIL
AND GAS EXPLORATION AND- I
THINK UNDERSTANDING THOSE
COMPLEXITIES THAT IT'S NOT AN
EASY. CONVERSATION IT'S NOT
LIKE THERE'S A QUICK EASY
ANSWER THAT'S GOING TO ADDRESS
ALL THOSE CONCERNS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND AS WE CONTINUE. OUR
THE STYLE I CAN CONTINUE THE
REGULATION- SETTING. A
FRAMEWORK THAT WERE IN HERE IN
THE CAPITAL SO I THINK YOU BOTH
FOR ENDING US ON THAT NOTE. IT
WAS REALLY- IS REALLY- VERY
CLEAR AND- I THINK REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND AS WE MOVE
NOW TO PUBLIC- TESTIMONY I WAS
ASKED TO READ INTO THE RECORD A
LETTER- WHICH I WILL DO- FROM.
US SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN SO
IF YOU TOLD ME ONE MOMENT THE
SENATOR DID ASK US TO READ THIS
INTO THE RECORD. SHE GETS THE
FOR COMMENT SHE DOESN'T HAVE A
TIME LIMIT- SO I WILL BE THIS
AS QUICKLY AS I CAN. AND IT. A
READ I WOULD LIKE. YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP STYLE SIDE TEARS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND RIGHT TO EXPRESS
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR TODAY
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THE SERVER
OIL SPILL OUT FUTURE THE-
PRINCE'S. FOR CALIFORNIA. SEE
WE CANNOT. WHERE TO CLEAN
ENERGY FEW. AND TOO MANY SINCE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PASSED KOREAN
CALIFORNIA I REMEMBER THIS
BARBARA SPILL IN NINETEEN NINE
THAT'S BUILD POINT MILLION OF
OIL THEN IN NINETEEN SO ONE
HUNDRED GALLONS A BUNKER FUEL
SPILLED IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AND IN NINETEEN NINETY AN OIL
TANKER SPILLED MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED GALLONS OFF HUNTINGTON
BEACH AND TODAY'S TOPIC THE
ALMOST ONE MILLION GALLONS OF
OIL AND WATER LEAKED IN KERN
COUNTY. I COMMEND GOVERNOR NEW
SOME FOR BLOCKING ALL NEW
FRACKING PERMITS UNTIL THEY CAN
BE INDEPENDENTLY REVIEWED I
ALSO SUPPORT HIS HALTING OF NEW
PERMITS FOR HIGH PRESSURE STEAM
INJECTED OIL DRILLING ENSURING
THAT THESE INVASIVE AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
EXTRACTION METHODS ARE SAFE AND
WON'T HARM HOME SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS AND PARKS IS VITAL TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL I CONTINUE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
REGULATE THE OIL INDUSTRY'S
EXTRACTION PROCESSES PARTICULAR
FRACKING SPECIFICALLY THE
FRACTURING RESPONSIBILITY IN
AWARENESS OF CHEMICALS ACT OF
WHICH I AM A CO SPONSOR IN THE
U. S. SENATE WOULD CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE THAT CURRENTLY EXAMS
FRACKING FROM OVERSIGHT BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
WE'RE COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THE
CHEMICAL WITH. THE FACT IN THE.
FIRST THE TRANSPARENCY OF THE-
PROCESS THE BILL WOULD BE SURE
THAT THE- AND FOR WRIST. CAN
ROUTE. IF TALKS FRACTURE
FRACKING CHEMICALS ARE FOUND IN
SURFACE WATER AN UNDERGROUND
DRINKING SOURCES. FURTHERMORE I
AM COMMITTED TO PERMANENTLY
BANNING OFFSHORE DRILLING IN
FEDERAL WATERS OFF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA'S TO CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR I REINTRODUCE THE
WEST COAST OCEAN PROTECTION ACT
WHICH WOULD PERMANENTLY
PROHIBIT OIL DRILLING IN THESE
WATERS WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL TO
COASTAL ECONOMIES AND HEALTHY
MARINE ECO SYSTEMS. NEARLY 70%
OF CALIFORNIANS OPPOSE OFFSHORE
DRILLING ACCORDING TO RECENT
POLLING BY THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA. I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT OUR BILL
RECENTLY PASSED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES. AS PART OF A
LARGER PACKAGE A BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION. MOST CRITICALLY I
BELIEVE THAT ALL FUTURE
DECISIONS ON FOSSIL FUEL
EXPIRATION IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED THROUGH THE LNS
OF THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY FACING
US ALL. CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
NATION AND TRANSITIONING AWAY
FROM FOSSIL FUELS AND WE MUST
ALL TAKE WE MUST TAKE ALL RISK
POSSIBLE MEASURES. TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ON THE ENVIRONMENT OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND PUBLIC HEALTH. IT
IS MY HOPE THAT THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE
REGULATORY AGENCY THAT OVERSEES
CALIFORNIA'S OIL INDUSTRY WILL
MAKE A MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE.
CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
DIVISION OF OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES TO THE GEO
THE GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
DIVISION AND UPDATING THE
AGENCIES PRIORITIES ARE
POSITIVE FIRST STEPS. TO INSURE
MORE EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT AND TO
EXPEDITE THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. I AM
HARKIN TODAY. I'M HARKEN THAT
TODAY'S HEARING IS BEING HELD
AND I COMMEND THE S. SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY FOR TAKING SERIOUSLY
THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE STATE
AGENCY. SINCERELY DIANNE
FEINSTEIN UNITED STATES SENATOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR WEIGHING
IN AND FOR- OF- SHINING A BIT
OF A SPOTLIGHT ON TODAY'S
HEARING. AND I ESPECIALLY WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO STAYED THIS LONG TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER YOUR
TESTIMONY. AT THIS POINT I
WOULD INVITE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO COME FORWARD. TO
ADDRESS AT THE COMMITTEE IF YOU
SO CHOOSE PLEASE LINE UP- DUE
TO THE HOUR WE ARE GOING TO
LIMIT TESTIMONY TO. THIRTY
SECONDS MAYBE TO A MINUTE
PLEASE TRY NOT TO BE REDUNDANT
YOU CAN- ALWAYS OFFER ME TO USE
AND WHO YOU REPRESENT- AND YOUR
NAME AND THAT WOULD BE MUCH
APPRECIATED WE WILL BE TIMING.
THESE COMMENTS. WE CAN ALSO
TAKE WRITTEN COMMENTS AFTER THE
FACT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS GIVING MY NAME IS DAVE
NOR ON THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
TAP THE CLOSEST CITY TO
MCKITTRICK WHERE THE SURFACE
EXPRESSION TOOK PLACE I MET
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR ABOUT TEN
MINUTES ONE ON ONE OUT THAT
SERVICE EXPRESSION SPOKE WITH
HIM AT LENGTH. ALSO WAS
DEBRIEFED AND INTERVIEWED BY
THE LA TIMES W. Q. E. D. MANY
OTHER NEWS AGENCIES THAT A
COMMON CONCERN THAT WAS WHY WAS
MYSELF AS MAYOR OF THE CLOSEST
CITY CONCERN FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF THE PEOPLE GIVEN
WHAT TOOK PLACE AT THE
MCKITTRICK SPILL ONCE AND I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE
FOLKS. I WORKED WITH- S. P. R.
I. DURING THE COURSE OF THAT
THEY PROVIDED THE PUBLIC THIRTY
ONE WEEKLY- NOTICES REGARDING
EXACTLY WHAT TOOK PLACE DURING
THE COURSE OF THAT SPILL WHEN
THE GOVERNOR WAS THERE WAS
FOLLOWED BY A CONGRESSMAN
SENATORS OTHER MAY OR
SUPERVISORS. I WAS THERE TO BE
WITH ALL OF THEM AND I MET WITH
ALL OF THE- NEWS AGENCIES AS
WELL THIRTY ONE WEEKS LATER
WHEN ALL THE OVERSIGHT AGENCIES
AGREED THAT THEY HAD COMPLETELY
REMEDIATED THAT'S BILL WITH-
ZERO NEGATIVE EFFECTS TO HEALTH
AND WELFARE NOT A SINGLE GLASS
OF DRINKING WATER. AND ONLY FOR
ANIMALS. NONE OF THOSE. ELECTED
SHOWED UP AND NONE OF THE
NEWSPAPERS SHOWED UP A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MAN HOURS LATER THEY
COMPLETED THAT TASK INCIDENT
FREE OPERATIONS PROFESSIONALS
THAT. I WAS THE ONLY ELECTED
OFFICIAL TO SHOWED UP. TO
SHARE. IN THE GOOD NEWS. IS
JUST TRANSITION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT JUST IF YOU WOULD
JUST BRIEFLY SURE AS OF TWENTY
THIRD WE'RE BEING TOLD YOU ALSO
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE MAYOR AND
BECAUSE YOU SHOWED UP HERE
TONIGHT AND I KNOW IT'S A LONG
DRIVE HOME SO. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. IT IS WILL INDULGES
BUT YOU'VE YOU BLASTED THROUGH
HER THIRTY SECOND REMARK BUT I
IT'S SO MUCH SIMPLER. WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE OKAY
I THANK YOU SIR AND THEN LASTLY
SO MANY PEOPLE WANT TO TALK NO
NO OF COURSE- GOING BACK TO
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND SENDS
TWENTY THIRTEEN STATE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INSTALLED SOME
TWELVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SOLAR ROOFS. SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
REGISTERED PLUG IN VEHICLES.
THE SAME TIME WE WENT FROM THE
UTILIZATION OF. SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. TO SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL LAST YEAR. SO WE
GOT THE LOW HANGING FRUIT. AND
WE STILL ARE CARBON BASED
SOCIETY WE ARE. BUT CALIFORNIA
DESERVES CALIFORNIA'S OIL IF WE
HAD TO QUANTIFY. OUR POLLUTION
BLOOM FOR BRINGING ALL OF THE
OIL FROM OVERSEAS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I DARE SAY THE
U. N. WOULD BE FINDING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE OWN THAT
POLLUTION WE OF RESPONSIBLE FOR
GONNA BE GLOBAL LEADERS. WE
NEED TO ROOM WE NEED TO LEAD BY
BEING RESPONSIBLE AND TAKING
NOTE OF WHAT WE TRULY DO COSTA
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MISTER. I DON'T SAID DUAL
STANDARDS HERE WELL I'M NOT I
KNOW YOU KNOW JUST COMBINED I
KNOW A MAYOR YEAH. ABOUT THAT.
YEAH HEY MY NAME IS KELLY YEARS
BEEN I'VE BEEN IN YOUR OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY FORTY FIVE YEARS
AND EMPLOYED BY SENATOR
RESOURCES COMPANY FOR NEARLY
THIRTY THREE YEARS I HANDLE
REGULATORY LEGISLATIVE AND
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FUNCTION FOR
SENECA WHO'S THE SIX LARGEST
OIL AND GAS PRODUCER IN THE
STATE WITH OPERATIONS IN
CURRENT FRESNO COUNTY IS
EMPLOYING NEARLY SEVENTY FIVE
FULL TIME OPERATORS ENGINEERS
GEOLOGISTS ACCOUNTANTS. CENTER
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES HAVE NO
COLLEGE DEGREE. THIS IS NOT
COUNT THE NEARLY FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED OPERATIONAL CONTRACTORS
IN OUR ON OUR PROPERTY WORKING
ON ANY GIVEN DAY. ARE THE
EIGHTY PLUS CONTRACT DRILLING-
OUR PRODUCTION RATE CONTRACTORS
ALSO ONSITE. AND I'LL MAKE IT
BRIEF YEAH IF YOU UP WE NEED A
BALANCE OF ENERGY TO KEEP OUR
LIVES IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
WORLD ECONOMY FLOURISHING YES
SIR- IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
IMPROVE OUR ENVIRONMENT YOU'RE
PROMOTE FOSSIL FUELS
INTEGRATING SOLAR WIND HYDRO
AND YES THE CLEANEST FUEL
SOURCE ON THIS PLANET. NUCLEAR.
HELLO AND ALEXANDER WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I WANTED TO BRIEFLY
UNDER SCORE AND ELABORATE ON A
POINT THAT WAS MADE BY INGRID A
MOMENT AGO WHICH IS THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S CRUDE RIVALS THE
TAR SANDS CREATING CARBON
INTENSITY AND I WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT THAT IS DO NOT ONLY TO
CARBON IMPACTS OF PRODUCTION AS
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT AT
LENGTH TODAY. BUT ALSO TO THE
MUCH GREATER CARBON IMPACTS OF
REFINING CALIFORNIA'S CRUDE
WHICH BECAUSE IT'S VERY HEAVY
TAKES MUCH MORE ENERGY TO BREAK
DOWN THE CARBON CHAINS AND
REFINING. AND ALSO IN ITS END
PRODUCTS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
CURTIS SO HEAVY IT CREATES- IN
THE REFINING PROCESS
DISPROPORTIONATE QUANTITIES OF.
PET COOK A VERY HEAVY BLACK
CARBON WHICH IS TOO DIRTY TO
BURN IN THE U. S. AND THEREFORE
IT IS SHIPPED OVERSEAS IT'S
ACTUALLY THE NUMBER ONE.
REFINED PRODUCT THAT IS
PRODUCED BY CALIFORNIA WERE
EXPORTED BY CALIFORNIA'S.
REFINERIES SO I WILL JUST SAY
THAT. WELL MANAGE DECLINE
SHOULD INCLUDE MITIGATION IT
ALSO NEEDS TO INCLUDE SIMPLY
TAKING OFFLINE THE CREW THAT IS
MOST PROBLEMATIC IN CARBON
INTENSELY WELCOME FURTHER-
WRITTEN TESTIMONY ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY KINGS ALEXANDER
THANK YOU. NEXT AND YOU OFFER
YOUR PAY. GOOD CHRISTY HALLE
SENTINEL PEAK RESOURCES I HAVE-
REALLY ENJOYED OBSERVING AND
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS I CALL YOU CAUSE ME
TO GO ALL WOOD THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING WHEN YOU'RE
CONSIDERING. HOW THIS
COMMUNITIES OIL AND GAS
RESOURCES ARE PRODUCED I'VE HAD
SOME AHA MOMENTS LISTENING TO
YOUR PERSPECTIVES IN YOUR LINE
OF QUESTIONING IT'S BEEN
VALUABLE. OUR OUR PLEDGE INTO
THIS WHOLE PROCESS AS A
COMPANIES TO BE AVAILABLE TO
EACH OF YOU I CAN SEE THAT FLOW
OF COMMUNICATION IS VITAL WE'RE
TALKING PAST EACH OTHER ON SOME
POINTS. OFF FOR ANY REMAINING
STAFF THIS YEAR I AM A REPEAT
THAT AVAILABILITY TO YOU TO
HAVE AN OPEN LINE OF
COMMUNICATION- BECAUSE IT IS
VITAL THAT WE US STAY OPEN TO
ONE ANOTHER'S. THOUGHTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THAT WILL TAKE YOU
UP ON THAT OFFER. GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS DONALD SANCHEZ- AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TONIGHT FOR A LONG ME TO SPEAK
TO YOU GUYS- ACOSTA MY NAME IS
DONALD SANCHO'S I WORK FOR
CYNICAL RESOURCES AND I WAS
EMPLOYED THERE. IN JUNE OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND HAVE NOW
WORKED IN THE BEAUTY DEPARTMENT
FOR OVER FIVE YEARS OVERSEE
PIPELINE OF FACILITY
REGULATIONS- SINCE STARTING AT
ASSEN ON MY WAY AND I HAVE. THE
PARENTS OF TWO BILLS GIRLS. AND
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WORKING
GAS INDUSTRY IS MY INCOME IN MY
CAREER HAS ALLOWED MY WIFE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO QUIT HER TEN
YEAR CAREER IN HUMAN RESOURCES
SO SHE COULD STAY HOME AND
RAISE OUR DAUGHTERS SOMETHING
THAT SHE'S ALWAYS IS ARE DO. SO
I'M DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR CYNICAL
REESE'SFROM WHAT SENATOR
RESOURCES FOR MY JOB AND THE
ABILITY TO GIVE ME TO PROVIDE
AN HONEST LIVING IN MY- FOR MY
FAMILY MY WIFE CHRIS QUIT A
HURRY CHARGE UP TO SO. WHEN OF
KIDS. I'M HERE I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNEDTHE TO
SOCCER MAKE THAT AND ALONG AND
IS THIS IS NOT AN INNER THAT I
WORK IN BUT WE PRODUCE A
PRODUCT THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS RELY ON EVERYDAY
THING SO BANNING IN STATE WILL
PRODUCTION WILL INCREASE OUR
FORM RELIANCE ON FOREIGN OIL
WHICH IS WHICH IS PRODUCED
WITHOUT CALIFORNIA'S STRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS OR
HUMAN RIGHTS PROTECTIONS. THANK
YOU I'M SORRY TO CUT YOU OFF
BUT YEAH WE GOT THE POINT AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT APPRECIATED
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS NICK ORTIZ THE
PRESIDENT OF THE GREATER
BAKERSFIELD CHAMBER WITH THE
LARGEST BUSINESS GROUP IN KERN
COUNTY BAKERSFIELD AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS AND
UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE INDUSTRY
BUT BEYOND THAT. THERE KEY
CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND REALLY SUPPLEMENTING OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. I MEAN
BECAUSE OF THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY- WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WHO ARE HOMELESS HAVE A PLACE
TO SLEEP. VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAVE A ADVOCATE IN A
SAFE SPACE- DISABLED KIDS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY A-
SPORTS AND PARTICIPATE IN
ACTIVITIES THAT WE'VE ALL TAKEN
FOR GRANTED- WE- REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE TRAJECTORY OF
STATE POLICY WE DO AND- I MEAN
IT HAS BEEN INTERESTING
ESPECIALLY. CENTER STERN AS YOU
SEE THE REALITY OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN YOUR YOUR POLICY WITH THE
ASPIRATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES- AND WE REALLY BELIEVE
AND- WE WANT TO BE- ACTIVE IN
THIS DISCUSSION AND WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF WHAT'S
NEXT FOR BAKERSFIELD IN KERN
COUNTY ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO WORKFORCE IN ECONOMICS. THE
CENTERPIECE OF OUR- GOALS HAS
TO BE ROBUST IN STATE.
PRODUCTION APPRECIATE THE OP.
CA IN THE HEARING THANKS FOR
BEING THE TRIP NO MR TEASE.
WELCOME GAVE MEMBERS THE UPSET
MANY MANY CHAD I'M THE- AND
REGULAR AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
CARE OF. I THE PRESS OF RE ON
THE CENTRAL WHERE I SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY CAN OPERATE. AS
WELL AS OUR OPERATIONS IN KERN
COUNTY. MY PRIMARY DAY TO DAY
RESPONSIBILITY IS ENSURING
PROTECTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT
OUR OPERATION IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE PRODUCE CLEAN OIL WHILE
BITING BY ALL STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LAWS- MY HIGHEST
PRIORITY IS MAINTAINING THAT
PRODUCTION ENVIRONMENT ENSURING
THE SAFETY OF OUR EMPLOYEES AND
ALSO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE OPERATE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A SAD
REALITY THAT. DUE TO THE
PRESSURES AND BIRDS OF A
REGULATION COMPANIES LIKE THE
CARE OF WHICH IS A FOURTH
GENERATION FAMILY OWNED COMPANY
IS NOW- HAVING TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND REALLOCATING OUR OUR
ACQUISITION CAPITAL RESOURCES
DIFFERENTLY- STATES LIKE
WYOMING AND TEXAS UNDERSTOOD.
THE RESULTS SORRY JUST DO YOU
MIND COULD YOU MIND SUBMITTING
WHATEVER THE REST OF YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY IS THERE TO
THE COMMITTEE ABSOLUTELY SO
YOUR FOR YOUR HOLY SHIFTING ALL
YOUR OPERATIONS OUT OF STATE
WELL WE'RE IN THE CHURCH WERE
IN THE TRANSGRESSES PHASE RIGHT
RIGHT UNDERSTOOD IT THANK YOU
FOR COMING UP I DON'T MEAN OUT
OF A JOB BUT I JUST WANT TO BE
TREATMENT HERE YEAH THANK YOU
HAVE A MAY. I CAN OF BLUE YOU
KNOW SPECIAL THERE THAT'S WHY
ANY THANK YOU FOR MAKING IT AND
WE WERE WOULD HAVE I KNOW IF
CENTRAL MEMBER HERE SO AND I'M
ALMOST CENTRAL I DON'T KNOW
COUNTY SOUTH YEAH YEAH IT AND I
HAD SOME CON. I WANTED THE
COMMENT THAT THE AND HAD MADE
AS WELL SO PLEASE WE ASK WON'T
JUST SHELVE THAT TESTIMONY
RIGHT HOW HAPPY TO ALL OKAY DO
APPRECIATE WELL. G. INDUSTRY- I
MOVED TO BAKERSFIELD THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS AGO AFTER COLLEGE
IN DETROIT FOR THREE YEAR STINT
WITH OIL COMPANY. I'VE BEEN
THERE THIRTY EIGHT YEARS NOW I
GOT A WIFE I'VE GOT THREE KIDS.
TO AFFIRM WITH ENGINEERING
DEGREES AND OIL BUSINESS
ANOTHER ONE WITH THE- WILL HAVE
ENGINEERING DEGREE IN JUST SIX
MONTHS. AND HE EXPECTS TO BE IN
THE BUSINESS TO. UNDERSTOOD SO
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO US
PERSONALLY AND MY FAMILY- THAN
WE SEE THE DEMAND IS. IS PRETTY
MUCH LEVEL AND THE PRODUCTION A
CALIFORNIA'S GOING DOWN IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GETTING MOST
OF OUR OIL COMING IN FROM
SAUDI. AND WE'RE HAVING TO
DEPLOY THE MILITARY TO GET THAT
pMILITARY. OR DO YOU WANT TO
DEPLOY ENGINEERS TO GET OIL.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING I'M
BRENDA WITH YOU AT THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY-
NONPROFIT OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION- WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE FOR THE HEARING HERE-
FOR ALL THE INFORMATION TODAY
WE HEARD SOME DISTURBING THINGS
TODAY- A LOT TO MAKE US WHO
QUESTION HOW MUCH WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR WATER HOW MUCH
WE'RE ADEQUATELY PROTECTING
AGAINST SPILLS AND HOW
SUSTAINABLE ON THIS INDUSTRY IS
RETIRED FROM THE INDUSTRY OF
THE BANK WE ALSO HEARD WE
INCLUDING WE HEARD A TALK ABOUT
HOW ISOLATED THE SIMURQ OIL
SPILL WAS AS IF THAT HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THEIR LACK
OF ABILITY TO CONTAIN THAT
SPELL. AND AT THE- FRAMEWORK
THAT LED TO THAT. TO WRAP UP
YES PLEASE. ALL WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE- TO DRILL INTO THIS
ISSUE AROUND AND TO REALLY GET
NOT JUST ABOUT THIS THINGS LIKE
THIS BILL BUT ABOUT A PHASE OUT
RICK RICK MUCH LARGER THANK YOU
AND WE WELCOME THAT FEEDBACK
FROM WHAT WE HEARD HERE TODAY
DO NOT FRAC THE ISSUE THOUGH IF
YOU DON'T MIND. YES YOU'RE
WELCOME A GOOD EVENING BRAND
ALSO SIERRA CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS WHO LIVE IN KERN
COUNTY- FOR THE SAKE OF BREVITY
I'LL SUBMIT OUR MINTS IN
WRITTEN FORM TO THE COMMITTEE
BUT WE JUST WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
THEN ALSO THE SENATE FOR RACE
POVERTY ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
BRIEFEST AWARD YOU WIN THE
AWARD FOR PREVIOUS COMMENTS.
GOOD EVENING- MY NAME IS ISAAC
PATTERN ANY ON THE AREA MANAGER
FOR HALLIBURTON HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING HERE ON
BEHALF OF- THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ARE WORKING HELD IN CHLOE'S
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SOME WHICH
ARE STILL HERE AND THEY'RE ONLY
HERE BECAUSE ON THE RIGHT BACK
HOME. SO MOSTLY REPRESENTING MY
FAMILY MY NEIGHBORS FRIENDS ALL
FROM BAKERSFIELD WHO ALL
BREATHE THE SAME AIR DRINK THE
SAME WATER AND WORK IN THE SAME
AREA THAT WE ALL LOVE- CUT OUT
MEN AND A HALF MY SPEECH. WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND ANY AND ALL
FORMS OF ENERGY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT WE DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION THAT- IF YOU DO
TRUE THE R. F. YOU ARE TRULY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND WELL BEING OF
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ASK YOU THAT YOU DO NOT
IMPLEMENT ANY FURTHER
REGULATIONS MORATORIUM'S OR
RESTRICTIONS ON A CLEAN SAFE
EFFICIENT. OIL NATURAL GAS IN
CALIFORNIA THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME JOHNSON I YOU ARE OVER
FROM FUSION ENERGY- BECAUSE OF
THE OIL INDUSTRY I WAS ABLE TO
BUY A HOME RAISE MY TWO KIDS.
AND I'M HERE TO SHOW MY SUPPORT
TO THE OIL INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU JUST BE THIS YEAR CLUB IN
YOUR BREVITY. AS A CUP RACE TO
THE BOTTOM HERE. HI MY NAME IS
BROOKE WATSON I'M A MOTHER AND
A GRANDMOTHER IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA WE RAISE TWO KIDS-
WHO WERE FED FROM THE OIL
INDUSTRY FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
I TRUST THESE MEN AND WOMEN
THEY ALSO HAVE FAMILIES THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT. AND I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE GOING
INTENTIONALLY DO ANYTHING TO
HARM BAKERSFIELD I SEE FOR SALE
SIGNS GOING UP IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. I'VE LOST FRIENDS
TO- LAYOFFS AND I JUST I WANT
TO PRESERVE MY WAY OF LIFE IN
BAKERSFIELD SO THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING INTO IT UNDERSTOOD YES
MA'AM THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS- GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS RAY
WATSON. AND NEXT WEEK I
CELEBRATE AND- MARK FORTY YEARS
IN THE OIL INDUSTRY. IN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBER WHO MOANS
AREA IS VERY FAMILIAR TO ME AS
IS- YEARS- SENATOR- I JUST WANT
TO SAY I'M NOT HERE AS A AS A
WORKER IN THE INDUSTRY AS MUCH
AS I AM. A FATHER AND A
GRANDFATHER. AND THE BOTTOM
LINE IS DEMAND. IS STILL. ONE
HAVE BARRELS A DAY WERE
PRODUCING LESS THAN HALF A
MILLION BARRELS A DAY SO THAT
MILLION BARRELS YOU KNOW WHERE
IT'S COMING FROM AMONG GONNA GO
OVER THAT BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS IF WE WANT TO REDUCE OUR
GLOBAL CARBON FOOTPRINT. WE
WILL REPLACE IS MANY OF THOSE
MILLION BARRELS A DAY COMING
AND MOUSE WERE WITH WHAT WE-
WHAT WE CAN DO HERE IT IS TRUE
WE CAN RAMP UP AND WE CAN DO IT
SAFER AND MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY THAN ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE EARTH. THANK YOU SIR. AT
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CARLOS
BUT I YOU I AM. FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN. ENGINEER
HUSBAND FATHER AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE INDUSTRY TO HELP MY
DAD OUT WHEN WE MOST NEED.
THANKS. HIS TALKHI- I'M SMITH
MCCUTCHEN WITH SENECA
RESOURCES- I WORK IN REGULATORY
AFFAIRS SO I'M JUST GONNA GO
AHEAD AND SKIP TO THE END HERE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEAD BY
EXAMPLE AND CONTINUE TO BE ONE
OF THE CLEANEST PRODUCERS IN
THE WORLD WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO FOLLOW OR STRICT
ABOUT MINUTES ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS I'M PROUD OF WHAT WE
DO AND CALIFORNIANS I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE DO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS RICHARD CHAPMAN
PRESIDENCY OF THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION OUR MISSION IS TO
ADVANCE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AS WELL AS
ECONOMIC WELL BEING AND OUR
STATE AND OUR REGION AND YOU
ALL HAVE A NICE COLORFUL-
COLORFUL FACT SHEET AYE. I
HEARD THAT THE AVERAGE
ATTENTION SPANSEIGHT SECONDS.
SAU QUIZ YOU AFTER THE FACT- WE
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY I TWO TWO FAX I
WANT TO HIT ON THAT MAY NOT BE
ON THE STREET. NUMBER ONE I
KERN COUNTY IS ACTUALLY IN THE
TOP FIVE FOR UPWARD MOBILITY.
AND THAT'S LARGELY IN PART
BECAUSE OF THESE OIL AND GAS
JOBS THAT PAY SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS. A YEAR ON
AVERAGE THAT'S ALMOST DOUBLE
THE COUNTY AVERAGE. ADELINE
THAT'S THOSE THAT- THAT TACT I
WANT TO SAY THAT- THE URBAN
INSTITUTE. A RECENT STUDY
SHOWED A CLEAR LINK BETWEEN
INCOME LEVEL AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES. AND SO I WANTED TO
JUST MENTION THAT AS WITH THEIR
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HEALTH AND
WELL BEING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
COURSE. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS JEFF TAPE A BATTALION
CHIEF WITH THE KERN COUNTY
FIGHT APARTMENT. AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO KIND OF REPRESENT
PUBLIC SAFETY FROM OUR AREA
SPECIFICALLY IT YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY ARE PART OF. THE SIX
GRADE BOOK. COUNTIES AS WE ARE-
WE HAVE TWENTY SIX GREAT BOOK
STATIONS AND- ONE THING I
WANTED TO JUST TOUCH ON QUICKLY
IS THAT WE GET ABOUT SIX MONTHS
FUNDING FOR THOSE GREAT BOOKS
STATIONS. I'M SORRY FOR MY-
ZERO UP IN LATE TUESDAY
SUPPORTER LANCE BUT AT. FIRST
SO THOSE ARE THE GREAT BOOK
DOES A CONSIDERED SORRY GREAT
BOOK STATIONS- YES YOU GOT LA
COUNTY YOU'VE GOT SANTA BARBARA
GET MORAN THE SIX OF US
UNDERSTOOD. AND THAT'S- AREA WE
SEE OF TAX REVENUES FROM THAT
ROUGHLY FOR ABOUT SIX MONTHS OF
THE YEAR MY POINT IS INDUSTRIES
LIKE THERE- INDUSTRY.
YEARS OF THOSE TWENTY SIX
STATIONS CAN REMAIN OPEN. WE
WOULD LOSE PROBABLY TEN TO
FIFTEEN STATIONS WITHOUT THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY SUPPORTING
US. WE ARE ALREADY THE LOWEST.
FIREFIGHTER PER PERSON- I GUESS
CAP OR WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL
IT. IN A COUNTY AS LARGE AS
OURS WERE ONE FOR EVERY THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED RESIDENTS OF KERN
COUNTY WERE LA IS ABOUT ONE
EVERY TWO THOUSAND. AND IF THE
STANDARDS ARE ONE EVER TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED. TO JUST PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE WE LOST TEN OF
THOSE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HUNDREDS OF SQUARE MILES
UNPROTECTED. OF STATE LAND THAT
WE CAN AND WE ALL KNOW FIRE
SEASON LASTS ALL YEAR ROUND SO
IT WOULD REQUIRE. MILLIONS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF MORE
TAX DOLLARS TO COVER THOSE
LANDS UNDERSTOOD THANK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICER THANK. HI
GOOD EVENING I FIRST OF ALL WE
MAY NOT AGREE ON EVERYTHING BUT
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
STAY TO LISTEN TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. HI MY NAME IS CALEY
ROSSI THEY WORK FOR AND A CAP
ENGINEERING AND DESIGN INK OUT
OF BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND I
AM THE OIL INDUSTRY. I'M HERE
BECAUSE I HAVE HOPE HOPE FOR A
BRIGHT FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
EARLIER THERE WAS THE AND
APPRECIATION FOR MISS BROCHURE
ABOUT THE HELP THAT SHE
PROVIDES THE COMMUNITY AND I
THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED THAT EVERYONE IN
HERE WITH ALL CAN DO WITHOUT
GETS THE SAME. ETHNIC AT THE
SAME ACCOLADE. ON OIL AND GAS
SERVICE AND EMPLOYMENT
INCURRING KERN COUNTY NOT ONLY
DOES THIS INDUSTRY PROVIDE HIGH
PAYING JOBS FOR THOSE THAT GO.
DIRECTLY EMPLOYED BUT ALSO
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE OUTSIDE OF THE INDUSTRY.
FOR INSTANCE OIL AND GAS
EMPLOYEES GRACIOUSLY DONATE TO
COUNTLESS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. STINGLEY THE
LOCAL ECONOMY BY CONTRIBUTING
TO LOCAL STATE TAXES. AND
EMPOWERS OUR COMMUNITIES
THRIVE. WE SHOP AT LOCAL
GROCERY SHORT STORES. PURCHASE
HOMES IN NEARBY NEIGHBORHOODS
EAT LOCAL RESTAURANTS. AND
HIGHER LOCAL CONTRACTORS. I'VE
BEEN THE UNDERSEA FOR SIX YEARS
I'VE HAD COUNTLESS
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEAVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PURSUE. OIL
AND GAS CAREERS OUTSIDE. AND I
CHOSE NOT TO DO THAT. AND THAT
IS BECAUSE- I LOVE BAKERSFIELD
IT'S MY HOME IT'S MY COMMUNITY
AND IT'S WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO
REMAIN. IF YOU TAKE AWAY MY
ABILITY TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT DO YOU SUGGEST THAT IDEA.
THANKS FOR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
WELL GREG COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR SAYING THEM I DO ALL THAT.
KERN COUNTY BORN AND RAISED-
OIL AND GAS FOR THE LAST TWENTY
TWO YEARS. RAISE MY KIDS ON IT
FINANCE THANK YOU CAN EXPECT
JUST IDENTIFY YOURSELF FELT ONE
WING US. WITH HALLIBURTON
THANKS SO TWENTY TWO YEARS WITH
HALLIBURTON TWENTY TWO YEARS
THEY FED MY KIDS. THAN ALL THE
FUNDS OF SOCCER ALL THAT. I'VE
ALSO BEEN FRACKING FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS. USED TO SO AND BY
YOU GUYS TO COME OUT LOOK AT
OUR PROCESS- TO MISS FEINSTEIN
ASKED THAT ALL CHEMICALS BE
DISCLOSED CORRECT. WE'VE BEEN
DOING THAT FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS. CALIFORNIA WITH THE
NUMBER ONE. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THINGS TOGETHER BEST INDUSTRY
BEST LEADERS FOR FRAC. WE'VE
GONE OUT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY TO SHOW THEM HOW TO DO
IT RIGHT TO ENVIRONMENTALLY
SAFE. JUST LIKE WE DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. GOOD THANK FRIEDMAN
SIR. THANK YOU LAST. THURMOND
YOU GIVE YOU IN THE DOOR RIGHT
YEAH DON'T BLOW THE BUDGET HERE
THOUGH. I'M NOT A MAYOR SO I
WILL TRY THAT. ANYWAYS I
THOUGHT THAT WHAT THE I WOULD
BRING UP IS THERE'S A LOT OF
FOCUS ON WHAT THIS INDUSTRY
DOES I'M SORRY ENERGY
INTERESTED HIM BY YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OR SOME STALLINGS
WERE. TEN LOVELY WITH MCPHERSON
ENERGY IS. WELL I WANTED TO DO
IS BRING A HIGHLIGHT TO YOU
THESE ARE GOVERNMENT NUMBERS
THIS IS PUBLISHED BY THE BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS AND THIS IS
FOR AN INDUSTRY. THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE TO SAY DOESN'T DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR PEOPLE. BUT
WHEN YOU COMPARE OUR INCIDENT
RATES YOU NORMALIZING ACROSS
OTHER INDUSTRIES. YOUR REALTORS
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GET
A HARD WORK THAN OUR EMPLOYEES.
CONTRACTORS DOING WORK IN THE
RESIDENTIAL INDUSTRY ARE FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY. TO BE HURT
AT WORK THAN OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
CONTRACTORS. DO YOU THINK AN
INDUSTRY THAT CARES THAT MUCH
ABOUT ITS PEOPLE. AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WOULD DO SOMETHING
THAT THEY DIDN'T THINK WAS
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
Y'ALL GIVEN US A LOT TO THINK
ABOUT- I WAS SPEAK FOR. OF MY
FELLOW CHAIR HERE BUT- IT'S
BEEN I OPENING HEARING.
QUESTIONS STILL REMAIN WE'RE
GONNA KEEP STUDYING THIS ISSUE
BUT MUSCLE WE JUST APPRECIATE
FOLKS COME IN FROM FAR AND
WIDE- UP TO SACRAMENTO I KNOW
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN COMPANY
YOU MORE MORE BUT- SINCE YOUR
LONG HEARING LIKE THIS AND
REALLY DIGGING INTO DETAILS-
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S YOUR JOB TO
BE HERE- I. WE APPRECIATE THE
INSIGHT AND KNOW IT MAY SEEM
QUITE INACCESSIBLE BUT I WOULD
SAY TO. WHOEVER MADE THE
COMMENT ABOUT HAVING MORE OPEN
DIALOGUE THAT I STAND READY TO.
IMPROVE THAT- THAT CHANNEL
COMMUNICATION AS WELL- BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT GONNA GET THROUGH
THIS TALKING AT EACH OTHER- SO
THANK YOU FOR. THAT THE
CIVILITY AND THE SERIOUSNESS
WITH THEIR WITH WHICH
EVERYONE'S BEEN APPROACHING THE
TOPIC TODAY AND- YES STAY TUNED
ANYTHING ELSE. IS LOAN. OKAY
WITH THAT DO YOU WANT TO BANG
IT. GIVE A GAVEL WE'RE
ADJOURNED ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOLKS.